hello aspiring ethical hackers and
Welcome to our channel in today's video
we are diving into the exciting world of
ethical hacking catering specifically to
beginners who are eager to embark on a
journey of cyber security exploration
ethical hacking is not just a skill it's
a mindset that empowers individuals to
safeguard digital landscape and protect
against cyber threats whether you are a
curious Tech Enthusiast or someone
looking to build a career in cyber
security this course is designed to be
your gateway into the fundamentals of
ethical hacking so bual up as we unravel
the mysteries of ethical hacking
together and just a quick info for you
if you want to upskill yourself master
cyber security skills and land your
dream job or growing your career then
you must explore simply learns cohort of
various cyber Security Programs simply
learn offers various certification and
postgraduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like MIT I kpur EC counsil
and many more through our courses we
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others and that's not all
you also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in Top Tire
product and security companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a cyber
security role as a fresher or move on to
higher paying job and profile if you're
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a cyber security
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest meet an she often
shops from www. shoppingcart tocom she
has her information like email ID
address and credit card details saved on
the website to enable a faster and
hassle-free shopping experience the
required information is stored in a
server one day an received an email
which stated her eligibility for a
special discount voucher from shopping
cart.com in order to receive the coupon
code she was asked to fill in her
shopping cart.com account credentials
this didn't seem fishy to her at the
time as she thought it was just an
account verification step little did she
realize the danger she would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how do you think this
happened well yes the email she received
was fake ANS shopping cart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a Cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker could
an have prevented this attack indeed she
could have with the help of cyber
security cyber security involves
techniques that help in securing various
digital components networks data and
computer systems from unauthorized
digital access there are multiple ways
to implement cyber security depending on
the kind of network you are connected to
and the type of cyber attacks you are
prone to so let's take a look at the
various cyber attacks that an could have
been exposed to one of the most common
types of cyber attacks is a malware
attack like Trojan adwar and spyware to
name a few had Anne downloaded any
suspicious attachments online or system
could have gotten corrupted by certain
malicious viruses embedded within the
attachments next is a fishing attack the
type of Cyber attack which an
experienced here the hacker usually
sends fraudulent emails which appear to
be coming from a legitimate Source this
is done to install malware or to steal
sensitive data like credit card
information and login credentials
another type of attack is the man in
the- Middle attack here the hacker gains
access to the information path between
Ann's device and the website server the
Hacker's computer takes over Ann's IP
address by doing so the communication
line between an and the website is
secretly intercepted this commonly
happens with unsecured Wi-Fi networks
and also through malware password attack
is one of the easiest ways to hack a
system here an's password could have
been cracked by using either common
passwords or trying all possible
alphabetical combinations to prevent
future cyber attacks Ann sought to
implement a few cyber security practices
first she installed a firewall as the
name suggests it is a virtual wall
between Ann's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware
reinforcements secondly and implemented
honey Poots just like how flowers
attract bees dummy computer systems
called honey pots are used to attract
attackers these systems are made to look
vulnerable in order to deceive attackers
and this in turn defends the real system
in addition to these she also decided to
use unique alpha numeric passwords
antivirus software and started avoiding
males from unknown senders that was
Ann's story cyber attacks are not just
confin to individuals but also to public
and private organizations the cyber
attacks carried out in such places are
more deadly and they result in colossal
losses motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains let's have a look
at a few of the cyber attacks that
companies are subjected to various
public sector organizations and large
corporations face the advanced
persistent threat a in this form of
attack hackers gain access to networks
for a prolonged period in order to
continuously gain confidential
information
companies also witness the denial of
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL injection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases
amidst a plethora of cyber attacks it is
indeed a challenge for organizations
with several networks and servers to
ensure complete Security this is not an
easy task and to help with this cyber
Security Professionals are hired to work
on identifying cyber threats and
securing a company's Network there are
multiple job roles in the field of cyber
security if hacking fascinates you then
the role of an ethical hacker is
something to be explored such
professionals try to exp a network
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do but only to identify those
vulnerabilities and resolve them for
protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more apt a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization so here's a question for
you identify the type of Cyber attack
where the hacker system takes over the
client's IP address a DDOS attack B man
in the middle attack c fishing attack d
password attack give it a thought and
leave your answers in the comment
section below three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers with the
increase in the production of global
Digital Data it is anticipated that
cyber attacks will quadruple in the near
future organizations are going to need
cyber security professionals who can
prevent these attacks a career in the
field of cyber security is lucrative and
a very smart decision for professionals
now we humans are highly tech-savvy in
today's times with the extensive use of
the internet and modern Technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our Digital Data such as
net banking information account
credentials and medical reports to name
a few have you heard about the deadly
one a cry ransomware attack the attack
happened in May 2017 in Asia and then it
spread across the world within a day
more than 230,000 computers were
infected across 150 countries the one
cry Cryptor encrypted the data and
locked the users out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to $600
in Bitcoin the users who used the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a toll on every sector top
tier organizations like Itachi Nissan
and FedEx had to put their businesses on
hold as their systems were affected too
now this is what you call a Cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can Define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks these illegal attacks
are often referred to as hacking hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems this is a misconception that
hacking is always wrong there are
hackers who work with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers are
individuals who illegally legally hack
into a system for a monetary gain on the
contrary we have white hat hackers who
exploit the vulnerabilities in a system
by hacking into it with permission in
order to defend the organization this
form of hacking is absolutely legal and
ethical hence they are also often
referred to as ethical hackers in
addition to these hackers we also have
the grey hat hackers as the name suggest
the color gray is a blend of both white
and black these hackers discover
vulnerabilities in assist system and
report it to the system's owner which is
a good act but they do this without
seeking the owner's approval sometimes
gry hat hackers also ask for money in
return for the spotted
vulnerabilities now that you have seen
the different types of hackers let's
understand more about the hacking that
is legal and valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story Dan runs a
Trading Company he does online training
with the money his customers invest
everything was going well and Dan's
business was booming until a hacker
decided to hack the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lump some Ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials Dan took the Hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and Dan
was liable to pay back the customers Dan
lost a lot of money and also the trust
of his customers after this incident Dan
gave a lot of thought as to what could
have gone wrong with the security
infrastructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable systems were before the
hacker penetrated into the network this
was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does to do
this job he hired an ethical hacker John
John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation so now you know hacking is
not always bad John in this scenario
exposed the vulnerabilities in the
existing Network and such hacking is
known as ethical hacking ethical hacking
is distributed into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how John our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step Jon takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like inmap
and hping for this purpose JN then tries
to spot the vulnerabilities if any in
the Target system using tools like inmap
and nextos this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after Jon makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system the metas sploit tool helps him
with this this phase is called
maintaining access Jon is a brilliant
hacker hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase Jon documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack looking into
the report Dan is now able to take a
call and see how to protect his
organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think JN is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like Jon then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh you must have reasonably
good knowledge of programming languages
such as HTML PHP python SQL and
JavaScript networking is the base of
ethical hacking hence you should good at
it ethical hackers should be well aware
of security laws so that they don't
misuse their skills finally you must
have a global certification on ethical
hacking to successfully bag a position
of an ethical hacker like John few
examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification C CompTIA pentest
plus and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few simply learn
provides a cyber security expert m
program that will equip you with all the
skills required by a cyber security
expert you could have a look at it by
clicking the link in the description so
here's a question for you in which phase
of ethical hacking will you install back
doors in the Target system a scanning B
maintaining access C clearing tracks D
reconnaissance give it a thought and
leave your answers in the comment
section below three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers the endless
growth of Technologies in this area is
directly proportional to the number of
cyber crimes cyber crimes are estimated
to cost $6 trillion in 2021 hence to
tackle these cyber crimes organizations
are continuously on the lookout for
cyber Security Professionals the average
annual salary of a certified ethical
hacker is $91,000 in the US and
approximately rupes 7 lakhs in India so
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like John and put an end to the cyber
attacks in the world data is the new
goal imagine how much data is generated
by just your smartphone every single day
be the pictures you click or the
messages you send nearly 41 million
messages are sent worldwide via WhatsApp
every single minute so safeguarding your
personal data against hackers has now
become our top priority did you know
that India leads the world when it comes
to ethical hackers with 23% of the the
worldwide hacking population from India
the top ethical hackers earn more than
twice of what software engineers in
India do but what makes ethical hacking
such a demanding industry ethical
hacking is the process of taking
security measures to safeguard data and
networks from malicious cyber attacks
the hackers use every tool at their
disposal to try and breach the security
barrier and find any potential
vulnerabilities the ethical in ethical
hacking denotes the lack of malous
intent since these sessions are often
permitted by the system owner or what
the network that is being hacked into to
fix any compromised entry points before
black hat hackers discover and exploit
them so what is a black hat hacker you
may ask a hacker who exploits security
vulnerabilities for monetary gains like
stealing or destroying private data
altering disrupting or shutting down
websites and networks is known as a
blackhead hacker on the other end of the
spectrum we have whad hackers who help
people secure the networks by stress
testing the platform against the most
dangerous of cyber attacks that is with
their consent of course but the most
neutral of the bunch are grayhead
hackers who may not ask for consent
before snooping on a foreign system but
they do inform the owner if they find
any vulnerabilities sometimes in
exchange for a small fee the security
breaches have become less and less
prevalent thanks to rigorous ethical
hacking campaigns and corporate
awareness programs the ability to fix
critical security issues before blackout
hackers leverage them has saved
organizations billions of dollars Google
IBM Microsoft and virtually every major
corporation Al looking to protect the
data so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that ethical hacking and information
security job market is set to rise by
nearly 28% by 2026 with salaries going
as high as
$225,000 perom so that's ethical hacking
wrapped up in 2 minutes to catch more B
size and detailed videos on different
Technologies subscribe to Simply learn
and stay updated in today's digital age
where cyber threats Loom large
understanding ethical hacking is crucial
by dwelling into the world of ethical
hacking you get a deep comprehension of
hacker techniques and vulnerabilities
which will enable you to strengthen your
security measures with the demand for
cyber Security Professionals soaring
learning ethical hacking opens doors to
wide range of exciting career
opportunities moreover it empowers you
to protect your personal data and
privacy while staying one step ahead of
evolving cyber threats by embracing
ethical hacking responsibility you
contribute to a safer digital
environment enhance problem solving
skills and Foster continuous growth get
ready to embark on an exciting journey
into the realm of ethical hacking and
discover its immense value in today's
interconnected world and if you are
someone who's interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elects to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a shot
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security from Schwan's College of
computing in collaboration with E counil
the link in the description box page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered take action
upskill and get ahead but before we
begin if these are the type of videos
you would like subscribe button and
click on the Bell to never miss an
update from Simply long without further
Ado let's get started started with
understanding why you must learn ethical
hacking there are a wide variety of
reasons of why to learn ethical hacking
let's discuss the important ones firstly
cyber security awareness next strengthen
security measures career opportunities
protection of personal data awareness of
cyber threats ethical use of skills
problem solving and continuous learning
now that we have few important reasons
let's discuss each one of these
important reasons in a bit more detail
firstly cyber security awareness
learning about ethical hacking provides
you with a deep understanding of the
techniques and methods used by hackers
this knowledge helps you identify
vulnerabilities in your computer systems
networks and applications enabling you
to better protect them the next one is
strengthening security measures by
learning ethical hacking you can
actively contribute to improving the
security of computer systems ethical
hackers often identify weaknesses in
organizations networks and provide
recommendations for enhancing security
measures followed by that we have career
opportunities the field of cybering and
there is a high demand for skilled
professionals by acquiring knowledge of
ethical hacking you can open up various
career opportunities in Industries such
as it security Consulting penetration
testing and incidence response next
ahead we have protection of personal
data understanding ethical hacking
techniques empowers you to safeguard
your personal data with privacy you can
Implement security measures to protect
your devices online accounts and
sensitive information from potential
attacks awareness of cyber threats is
the next one on the list the digital
landscape is constantly evolving and new
threats emerge regularly learning
ethical hacking helps you stay up to
date with the latest cyber threats
attack vectors and vulnerabilities
enabling you to proactive your measures
to mitigate the risks followed by that
we have ethical use of skills ethical
hacking emphasizes the responsible and
legal use of hacking techniques by
learning ethical hacking you gain the
knowledge of the ethical guidelines and
legal boundaries associated with cyber
security this ensures that your skills
are utilized for positive purposes
protecting individuals and organ
izations from malicious attacks next on
the list is problem solving skills
ethical hacking requires critical
thinking problem solving and analytical
skills through learning ethical hacking
you develop a systematic approach to
identifying and solving complex security
issues which can be valuable in various
aspects of life and other technical
domains next and the L is continuous
learning and growth cyber security is a
dynamic field that demands continuous
learning learning to keep up with
evolving cyber threats learning ethical
hacking ensures that you remain engaged
on ongoing education and skill
development fostering personal and
professional
growth now let's get into the important
aspect of today's tutorial that is
salary details for a certified ethical
hacker in the United States of America
the salary of an ethical hacker can be
based on various factors such as
experience skill level location industry
and the organization they work for
generally ethical hackers in USA tend to
earn higher salaries than other
countries due to the demand for cyber
Security Professionals entry-level
positions may start around $60 to
$80,000 perom while experienced
professionals with Advanced
certifications and specialized skills
can earn salaries exceeding
$150,000 per Anum the salary of fical
hacker in India can vary depending on
factors such as experience skill set
location and organization they work for
on an average a beginner level ethical
hacker in ending from three lakhs to 6
lakhs per anom as they gain more
experience and
expertise their salary can increase
significantly experien ethical hackers
with several years of experience and
advanced certifications can earn
salaries ranging from 8 to 20 lakhs or
more annually now proceeding with the
company's hiring ethical hackers several
companies hire ethical hackers to
enhance their cyber security defenses
and protect their systems here are some
prominent companies known for hiring
ethical hackers Google Facebook
Microsoft Apple Amazon IBM Cisco Intel
deit and evi are the most prominent ones
the topics that we are going to discuss
in this video are what exactly hacking
is the types of hackers the
classifications what is ethical hacking
the skills that that are required of an
ethical hacker the process that is
utilized by ethical hackers in their
daily activities and then lastly we are
going to discuss cryptography so let's
talk about hacking and what exactly
hacking is hacking refers to exploiting
weaknesses in a computer network to
obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some key words that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you're exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a Security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that
you're not allowed to do and when you
say a hacker is a person who tries to
hack it's basically a person with
malitia intent trying to gain access to
a system or a resource that they are not
authorized to access in the first place
how do they do it they find a varability
that is a weakness or a flaw and then
they misuse it to gain access to that
particular Network so here in the
diagram you can see that a sender on the
left hand side is trying to send some
data to the receiver on the right hand
side the hacker would try to gain
unauthorized access to the transmission
that is being sent and would try to
capture the data packets and read the
secrets Within let's look at a business
case scenario into hacking now there is
an organization uh everybody is going
around their own business when they
realize that their systems may have been
compromised now they're trying to look
at the customer data to ensure that that
has not been compromised and trying to
assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
has happened and based on that attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified by the hacker which means
that the data is no longer trustworthy
and thus cannot be used by the business
for any legal transactions so then the
hacker gives a call to the organization
or gets connected to the organization
demanding a ransom for the data to be
replaced to be taken back into the
original state where it was trusted and
thus the organization can utilize it for
business transactions
the organization has probably no backup
so they decide that they want to pay the
lumsum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues at as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to Leverage The misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization
security thus being able to hack them
and uh make these Ransom somewhere
demands so the company then wants to
figure out even if having a security
system in place how was the hacker able
to hack their systems thus one of the
employees comes up with a brilliant idea
of identifying viabilities in the
network uh to proactively search for any
flaws that have been left behind uh so
that they can plug those flaws and
nobody can misuse them thus they figure
out that they want to hire a ethical
hacker who would help them identify the
security posture of the organization
identify the weaknesses vulnerabilities
and flaws and help them remedy those
flaws so that in future scenarios these
scenarios will not happen so before we
go into an ethical hacker let's
understand what are the types of hackers
so what are the types of hackers hacker
is a technically skilled person uh who
is very Adept with computers they have
good programming skills they understand
how operating system works they
understand how networks work they
understand how to identify flaws and
viabilities within all of these aspects
and then they understand and know how to
misuse these flaws to get a outcome
which would be detrimental to the health
of the organization so there's six type
of hackers that have been identified
black hat hackers white hat hackers gray
hat script kitties Nations sponsored
hackers and a activists so blackhe hat
hackers are Bas basically uh the
malicious hackers who have malicious
intent and have criminalistic Tendencies
they want to harm the organization by
hacking into their infrastructure by
destroying their infrastructure by
destroying their data so that uh they
can gain from it from a monetary
perspective uh these guys are also known
as crackers the main aspect of these uh
people are that they have malicious
intent they try to do unauthorized
activities and they try it for personal
gain another important aspect to
remember is that a black hat hacker will
always try to hide their identity uh
they will spoof their online digital
identity by masking it by spoofing their
IP addresses Mac addresses and try to
remain anonymous on the network whiteed
hacker on the other hand is also an
ethical hacker or a security analyst
who's an individual who will do exactly
the same thing that a blackhead hacker
would do minus the malicious intent plus
the intent of helping the organization
identifying the flaws and remedying them
so that nobody else can misuse those
vulnerabilities so they are authorized
to act on the company's behalf they are
authorized to do that activity which
would help the company identify those
flaws and thus help the company mitigate
those flaws improving on their security
posture so these uh these kind of
Security Experts or ethical hackers
would help organizations defend
themselves against unauthorized attacks
gray hat hackers is a blend of both
white hat and black hat hackers so here
they can work defensively and
offensively both they can accept
contracts from organizations to increase
their security posture at the same time
they can also get themselves involved in
malicious activities towards other
organizations to personally gain or
benefit from them by doing unauthorized
activity script kitties are people uh
who are technically not much aware about
what hacking is uh they rely on existing
tools that have been created by other
hackers they have no technical knowledge
of what they're doing it's just a hit or
miss for them so they just get their
hands on a tool they try to execute
those tools uh if the hack works it
works otherwise it doesn't so these
people are basically who are noobs or
newbies who are trying to learn hacking
or uh just uh people who with malicious
intent who just want to have some fun or
trying to impress people around then we
have the nation or the state sponsored
hackers as the name suggest these
hackers are sponsored by their
government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers uh enrolled
in their pay on um on their uh
organizations to spy on their enemies to
spy on various countries and try to
figure out uh the aspirations of those
countries so this is basically a spying
activity where you technically trying to
get access to other Count's resources
and then try to spy on them to figure
out what their activities have been or
what their future plans have been and
then we have the activists who an
individual who has a political agenda to
promote and they promote it by doing
hacking so uh these guys what is the
difference between a blackhe hat hacker
and a hacktivist the blackhe Hat hacker
may try to hide their identity a
activist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their CA they
would probably do this by defacing the
website and posting the messages that
they want to promote on these websites
so what exactly is ethical hacking then
we have discussed the types of hackers
we have identified a malicious hacker as
a black hat hacker with the intent uh of
doing harm to an organization's Network
for personal gain we have discussed what
the ethical hacker is so an ethical
hacker would be doing the same activity
but in an authorized manner so they
would have legal contracts that they
would be signing with the organization
it would give them a definite unite
scope of what they're allowed to do and
what they are not allowed to do and the
ethical hackers would function within
those Scopes would try to execute those
test scenarios where they would be able
to identify those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhe hat hackers do
however the main difference here is that
these guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal games so who's an
ethical hacker again ethical hacker is a
highly intelligent Highly Educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
Adept at Computing they understand the
architecture they understand uh how
various components in a computer work
they can troubleshoot those components
and they can BAS basically be uh very
good with programming as well now when I
say programming we don't want the
ethical hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
Trojans or exploits which would help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they individuals who
perform a security assessment of their
companies with the permission of cons
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they have been configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire an ethical hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls what idss ipss inent detection
or intrusion prevention systems
antiviruses are already in place and
then they will ask the ethical hacker to
figure out a way to bypass these
mechanisms and see if they can still
hack the organization what is the need
of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those flaws to help
secure the organization from blackhe hat
hackers so ethical hackers would prevent
Hackers from cracking into an
organization's Network by securing the
organization by improving on their
security on a periodic basis and they
would also try to identify system
vulnerabilities Network vulnerabilities
or application Level vulnerabilities
that would have been missed or have
already been missed and then Tred to
figure out a way of plugging them or uh
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze and enhance an organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are uh they contain the alphabet A
through Zed uppercase and lowercase 0
through 9 as numerics and special
characters and they're randomized so
that the password becomes more more
stronger to prevent from Brute Force
attacks so what would an ethical hacker
do at this point in time they would try
to test the strength of the passwords to
see if Brute Force attacks or dictionary
attacks are possible and if any of these
passwords can be cracked they would
ensure that all the employees are
following the policies and all the
passwords are as secured as the policies
want them to be if there are any gaps in
the policies or the implementation of
the policy it is the ethical hacker
responsibility to identify those gaps
and warn the organization about it
similarly they would also try to protect
any personal information any data that
is owned by the organization that is
critical for the functioning of the
organization and they'll try to protect
it by from falling into the Hacker's
hands now what are the skills that are
required of an ethical hacker these are
the following skills so first and
foremost they should have good knowledge
with operating systems such as Windows
Linux Unix and Mac now when we say
knowledge about operating systems it's
not only about how to use those
operating systems but how to
troubleshoot those operating systems how
these operating systems work how these
operating systems need to be configured
how can may be secured for example
securing an operating system is not only
installing a firewall and an antivirus
but you need to configure permissions on
an operating system of what users are
allowed to do and what users are not
allowed to do for example limiting the
installation of applications how are we
going to do that we need to go into the
system center the security Center of
Windows and we need to configure
security parameters over there of what
are acceptable softwares and what are
not same with Linux and uh Mac softwares
operating systems so we need to know how
we can secure these operating systems
similarly all of these would have
desktop versions and server versions of
operating systems as ethical hacker we
need to know the desktop and server
versions both how to configure them and
how to provide services within the
organization on these servers so that
they can be consumed in a secure manner
by all the employees at the same time
they should also be knowledgeable of
programming languages or scripting
languages such as PHP python Ruby HTML
for programming if you will because web
servers come into the picture so again
they should not be great developers
where they can create huge applications
but they should be able to develop
scripts understand those scripts analyze
those scripts and figure out what the
output should be of those scripts to
achieve the hacking goals that they have
set out for an ethical hacker should
have a very good understanding about
networking no matter whether you're in
application security you're in network
security or you're in host based
security since a computer will always be
connected to a Network either a local
area network like a landan or the
internet we should know how networking
works we should know the seven layers of
the OSI model we should know which
protocols work on those seven layers we
should identify the tcpip model and how
OSI model can be mapped to the tcpip
model we should understand how TCP and
UDP work how how each and every protocol
is crafted how they are supposed to
behave for us to analyze and understand
any network-based attacks we should be
very good in security measures so we
should know where those vulnerabilities
would lie what are the latest exploits
available in the market and we should be
able to identify them we should be able
to know the techniques and the tools of
how to deal with security how to analyze
security and then how to implement
security to enhance it as well along
with that it is important that a
security analyst or ethical hacker is
aware of the local security laws and
standards why is that because an
organization cannot do any illegal
activity whatever responses that they
have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
Implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that they
are dealing with so the ethical hacker
should be aware of what security laws
are before they Implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming uh it's good to
have a certification in PHP Pearl python
Ruby and so on so forth why because most
of the organizations when they hire
ethical hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize uh in their testing scenarios to
be be honest there are hundreds of tools
out there what you see on the screen are
just a few examples of them uh nessus is
a vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within uh
operating systems within networks so
they come with their rade databases of
all the vulnerabilities that have
already been identified and the scan the
network against that database to find
out any possible flaws or any possible
vulnerabilities that currently exist on
the host or the operating system or on
the network similarly there would be
application scanners like actic or
Arachne that would help you scan
applications and identify flaws within
those applications as well now all of
these are automated tools the essense of
ethical hacker is when these tools churn
out the reports the ethical haer hacker
can understand these reports analyze
them identify the flaws and then craft
their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or they can bypass
the access security controls mechanisms
that are already in place how can they
do that with the tool called Metasploit
you see that Big M there on the right
hand side that M logo is for a tool
called Metasploit which is a penetration
testing tool what is a penetration
testing tool it is that tool that will
allow a ethical hacker to craft their
exploits or choose their exploits for
the vulnerabilities that have been
identified by nesses since we are
interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool NS identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metas helps us do that wire Shar
would be used in the background while we
are doing both the activities using
nessus or Metasploit to keep a track of
what packets are being sent and by
received on the network which will help
us analyze those packets so whenever I
run a NS scanner I would run a yre Shar
in the background it will capture the
data packets and I can go through those
data packets and analyze that data
packets to identify what nesses is
actually trying to do similarly when I
try to attack a machine using exploit on
metas exploit I will keep on wire shock
running in the background to capture the
data packets that have been sent and the
responses that I've received from the
victim so that I can also go through
those packets and analyze the responses
and analyze the attack whether it was
successful to what extent was it
successful and basically will also give
me a validation a proof of the activity
that has happened nmap is another
automated tool that allows me to scan
for open ports and protocols so why
would I use nmap because Pro ports and
protocols become an entry point for a
hacker to gain access to devices for
example when we connect to a web server
we connect through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 using https s so if
I'm connecting to a web server using
https it is safe to assume that Port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those connections similarly there would
be other services that may be left open
on the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then I can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that I'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
I want to do a SQL injection attack or
if I if nessus tells me that there's a
SQL injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
I can use an automated tool called SQL
map or SQL map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a SQL injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here I do not have to manually
create my own queries uh the equl map
tool would automatically create them for
me what I would do is I would use nessus
to identify that particular flaw if
nessus reports that flaw I would then go
use the tool SQL map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when I fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those uh databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management uh providing
them feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful to
they would also give recommendations of
what to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that that we would follow so there are
six steps that we would do as ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
recognizance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hacker
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a
windows-based server and I use a
particular tool to attack it but it
actually turns out to be a Linux based
server my attacks are going to be
unsuccessful so I need to focus my
attack based on what is there at the
other end so in my information gathering
phase I want to identify all of that
information once I have that information
done I'm going to scan those servers
using tools like nmap that we just
talked about and we're going to try to
see the open ports open services and
protocols that are running on that
server that can give me possible entry
points within the network or within the
device or within the operating system at
the same time along with the scanning
with nmap I would run a vulnerability
scanner the nessus vulnerability scanner
we talked about or acine etics for
applications and then I will try to
identify vulnerabilities in those
applications operating systems or
networks once I've have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access uh by either cracking passwords
or escalating privileges or exploiting a
avability that I I may have found during
the scanning phase once I have gained my
access I want to maintain my access why
because the vulnerability may not be
there for long maybe somebody updated
the operating system and hence the flaw
was no longer exist uh existing or
somebody changed the password that may I
may have cracked does I no longer have
access so what do I do to maintain my
access I install Trojans or backd door
entries to those systems using which I
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my my own time as long as those
devices are available over the network
so that's where I maintain my access I
have hacked them now I want to maintain
my access so I install a software which
would give me a backd door entry to that
device no matter what once I've done
this I want to clear my track so
whatever activity that I've been doing
for example installing a Trojan a Trojan
is also a software that would create
directory directories and files once
installed on the victim's machine so I
want to hide that if I have accessed
data stores if I have modified data I
want to hide that activity because if
the victim comes to know that something
has happened they would start they would
start increasing their security
parameters they might start scanning
their devices they may take them offline
thus my hack would no longer be
efficient the reason I'm clearing my
tracks is that the victim doesn't find
out that they have been hacked or they
have been compromised or even if they do
find out that they've been compromised
they cannot trace the compromise back to
me so I would be deleting references of
any of the IP addresses or Mac addresses
that I may have used to attack that
particular device and and this is where
I will be able to identify where those
logs were created where those traces are
once I take off those traces the victim
would not be any visor of whether they
have been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or or the expected output
of that attack I'll create a report
which would give a detailed analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their device
that need to be mitigated so that the
security can be enhanced so these are
the six steps that the ethical hacking
process would take uh just going through
this the uh recognizance is where you're
going to use hiking tools like nmap HP
to obtain information about targets
there are hundreds of tools out there
depending on what information you want
then in scanning again n map next p
these kind of tools to be utilized to
identify open ports protocols and
services in gaining access you're going
to exploit the vulnerability by using
the Metasploit tool that we talked about
in the previous slides in the
maintaining access you're going to
install back doors you can use metas at
the same time uh you can craft your own
scripts to create a Trojan and install
it on the victim's machine once you have
achieved that clearing tracks is where
you're going to clear all evidences of
your activity so that you do not get
caught or the victim doesn't even
realize that they have been hacked and
once you done all of this we going to
create reports that are going to be
submitted to the management to help them
understand the current security
evaluation of their organization so now
let's see how we can hack using social
engineering now what is social
engineering social engineering is the
art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you're able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's look
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of fake mails on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those Nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some South
African country and you out of 7 billion
people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million dollar through your
account and they want to give you 50% of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go on
to websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your prize
all of these are social engineering
attacks fishing attacks fake websites
fake Communications being sent out to
users to pray on their Gully bleeding
most of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge Lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those mails it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotion
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social injuring attack where
you can plead with them saying if I do
not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job job and
then that would put my family into
problems somebody would feel empathy or
sympathy towards you and help you reset
that password and give you access to
that account it's how good the attack is
and how convincing you are for the
success of this attack to happen so what
is a familiarity exploit attackers
interact with victims to gain
information which will benefit the
attackers to crack credentials as
passwords if we want to reset our
passwords what do we have as a mechanism
to resetting passwords we have some
security questions that we set up those
questions are nothing but but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to uh gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your LinkedIn
profile where per person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you in right similarly it might
also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh I mean if a person
can interact with you let's say they're
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it fishing as
discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing uh comes into
mind uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is a
open a generic attack whoever Falls
victim will fall victim so if I just
throw around a few USBS in the parking
lot obviously with Trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in their those pen drives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine then exploiting human
greed uh we just talked about the
Nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
pray upon the persons greed kicking in
and they clicking on those links in
order to uh get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the end user using the uh same key would
then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would look like EQ o r
XV GT for a end user it wouldn't make
any sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer and then
understand the meaning of that word so
this is just a substitution Cipher that
is being shown on the screen so what is
the alphabet the key is alphabet plus
three so C plus three alphabets that
becomes e o becomes q m becomes o so the
key that is utilize to scramble the data
is the character that you are at the
third character from there would be the
corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponded
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out uh or you
want to decrypt that data now as a
ethical hacker you wouldn't be for
paying a ransom uh to the hacker would
you so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going going to try to crack the
encryption mechanism how to crack the
cipher to decrypt that message and see
what's within it right decryption
without the use of a secret key that is
known as a crypt analysis Crypt analysis
is the reversing of an algorithm to
figure out what the decryption was uh
without using a key so Crypt analysis
can be done using various formats the
first one is a Brute Force attack second
is a dictionary attack third one is a
rainbow table attack a Brute Force
attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the key
to figure out what the key was it is
100% successful but may take a lot of
time a dictionary attack is very you
have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out uh the similarities between the text
that you have and the encrypted data
that you wanted to decrypt in the first
place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible comb
combination permutation of what the key
would be in dictionary attack you have a
word list that would tantamount to the
key and if you're you're trying to match
all the words listed in the text file or
the word list to see if any of those
words are going to work to decrypt that
data here in the rainbow table the
cipher text is compared with another
Cipher text you find out similarities
and then you try to work a reverse
engineer your way accordingly so let's
have a quick demo on cryptography before
we end this session so to begin with the
demo of cryp photography we are on a
website called spam mic.com which will
help us scramble the message that we
created into a completely a a format
which would be unrelated to the topic at
hand so if I say I want to encode a
message turn a short message into spam
so what this does is you want to send
across a secret message you type in The
Secret Message a short one it will
convert that into a spam mail you send
it across so whoever is reading that
spam mail would never get an idea of the
embedded message within it so if I want
to type in a message here hi this is a
secret message the password is ASD at1
234 and I want to send this out to
people or to one of my colleagues but I
want to send it out in a secret manner
so that others are not aware of this so
when I press on encode what the
algorithm would do is it will convert
this message into a spam mail so my
message hi this is a secret message the
password is atate 1 234 or ASD at 1 2 3
4 gets converted into this now if you
read it dear e-commerce professional
this letter was specially selected to be
sent to you this doesn't make sense
there is nowhere or no reference to the
actual message that I've already said so
if I copy this entire message and I send
it let's say via email to the recipient
now the thing is that the recipient
needs to know that I've encoded it using
spam mimic the algorithm needs to remain
the same so once they know that it is
Spam mimic what they can do is now in
this this instance what I'm going to do
is I'm going to open up a new browser
and I'm going to go to the same website
and at this point in time I'm going to
click on decode when I click on decode
I'm going to paste the message that I
have just copied there we are and this
message is now being copied into a
different browser and if I decode this
you will see that it will convert it
back to the original message that there
was so the key is there at spam mimic
and it is embedded within the message so
whenever we we paste the message in the
decode Factor it knows what the key was
and it can decrypt that message and give
me the actual message that was embedded
within it there we are the entire
message this is what we created in the
Google Chrome browser and in the Firefox
browser we decoded similarly if I want
to protect these kind of messages there
is an aspen
encrypt.me is ASD at 1 2 3 4 and then I
give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
I use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say AES which is the
strongest Cipher right now and I say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically uh if I
don't have the password over here if I
decrypt it you would see that the error
has occurred now if I type in the
password over here and then decrypt it
it will be able to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
ASD at the1 1234 so if I want to keep my
data secure from hackers I want to
scramble it in such a way that they
would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker and before we begin
if you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or
to become an ethical hacker by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts then
try giving a short to Simply lar
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from M schwarzman College
of computing the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
hello everyone and welcome to this video
on the hackers road map at the simply
land YouTube channel as vast as the
field of cyber security is there's often
an overflow of information about it at
the same time for people who wish to
know more about how to venture into the
cyber security or ethical hacking space
it is very important for them to know
what's the career progression what are
the skills needed and how a person with
no or bare minimum knowledge can take
the first step in this amazing career
well this video is for all those
individuals who wish to pursue a career
in the field of cyber security and
ethical hacking whether you are an
entry-level professional a college
graduate or an experienced professional
looking to understand how a career in
the field of cyber security progresses
and what additional skills and
responsibilities would you need as you
grow in the field then you are at the
right place so let's get started with
our topic the hackers road map and
before we begin if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
alits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply lar
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT shortsman College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will now get you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press on the Bell icon
to never miss on further content so stay
tuned with us until the end of this
video and don't forget to register your
opinion in the comment section below and
now we will start with what is ethical
hacking and how is it different from
hacking so in the world of cyber
security hacking can be broadly
categorized into two types ethical
hacking and unethical hacking ethical
hacking involves using the same tools
and techniques as malicious hackers to
identify and fix security
vulnerabilities before they can be
exploited and these expert known as
Whitehead hackers work with a focus on
security rather on theft and on the
other hand we have unethical hacking
that refers to unauthorized access to
digital devices or networks with
malicious intent performed by black
attackers and additionally there are
gray attackers who possess knowledge in
offensive and defensive computer use
sometimes working as Security
Consultants during the day and engaging
in blackhe hat activities at night it is
important to understand these
distinctions to protect against cyber
threats effectively now we'll see the
objective or roles of an ethical hacker
ethical hackers also known as whad
hackers use their skills and expertise
to identify vulnerabilities in system
and network before malicious hackers can
exploit them their primary objective is
to simulate real world attacks and help
organizations strengthen their security
measures the role of an ethical hacker
involves several key phases and we'll
see those roles and key phases so they
are responsible for reconnaissance
scanning can and maintain access clear
their tracks document their findings and
compile detailed reports so firstly they
conduct thoro Recon gathering
information about the target system or
organization this includes understanding
the organization structure Network
infrastructure and potential weak points
and through scanning they identify the
easiest and quickest methods to gain
access to the network and gather further
information and once acccess is gained
ethical hackers maintain it allowing
them to exercise their Privileges and
control the connected systems this step
helps them identify any potential
security flows and weaknesses within the
network they also work to clear their
tracks covering their footsteps to evade
detection and ensuring the the security
personel cannot Trace their activities
and throughout the entire process
ethical hackers document their findings
compile detailed reports on the
vulnerabilities discovered and provide
recommendations to address and mitigate
the identified security issues their
vulnerability goal is to help
organization strengthen their defenses
prevent data breaches and protect
sensitive information from falling into
the wrong hands ethical hacking is a
crucial aspect of cyber security as it
allows organizations to stay one step
ahead of cyber threats by leveraging the
skills of ethical hackers businesses can
proactively identify and address
vulnerabilities ensuring the overall
security and integrity of their digital
infrastructure so now we'll see the
skills that needed to be an ethical
hacker so now we'll see the skills so
the first skill is knowledge of computer
networks then it's the programming
languages than the knowledge of web
applications databases ethical hacking
tools and knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques then what
certificates that are required for an
ethical haer now we'll start with
knowledge of computer networks
understanding computer networks is
fundamental for ethical hackers this
includes Concepts such as IP addressing
Network protocols example TCP IP routing
switching and firewalls a strong grasp
of how networks function will enable you
to identify vulnerabilities and
potential entry points the next is
programming languages Proficiency in
programming language is essential for
Effective ethical hacking languages like
python Java C++ and scripting languages
such as Pearl or ruik are widely used in
this field programming skills enable you
to write custom scripts and tools
automate task and exploore
vulnerabilities and the next we have is
web applications in today's digital
landscape web applications are often the
target of attacks therefore a solid
understanding of web application
architecture protocols example HTTP and
security mechanisms example SSL TLS is
crucial knowledge of web programming
languages like HTML CSS JavaScript and
Frameworks like PHP or asp.net is also
beneficial then we have databases so
databases store and manage sensitive
data making them attractive targets for
hackers familiarize yourself with
database Management systems dvms such as
MySQL Oracle or Microsoft SQL Server
learn about database security including
access control in encription and
vulnerability assessment then we should
focus on the skill to have a knowledge
on ethical hacking tools so to perform
ethical hacking task efficiently you
should be familiar with various hacking
tools these include Network scanners
example and map vulnerability scanners
example nessas password crackers joone
the riper packet snipers W shck and
exploitation Frameworks metas sploit
mastering these tools will enhance your
Effectiveness as an ethical hacker then
you should have knowledge of of common
attack vectors and techniques that is
understanding common attack vectors and
techniques is vital for an ethical
hacker this includes knowledge of
different types of malware social
engineering Network attacks that is DDOS
and web application vulnerabilities
example crite scripting staying up to
date with the latest threats and attack
methodologies is crucial for Effective
defense the next is certificates so
obtaining relevant certifications
demonstrates your expertise and
commitment to the field certificates
like certified ethical hacker CH
offensive security certificate
professional OSP or coma Security Plus
are highly regarded within the industry
they validate your skills and can boost
your credibility when seeking ethical
hacking opportunities the CH
certification is a multiple choice exam
that evaluates your understanding of the
penetration testing structure and the
tools that are utilized inside it it
gives job Seekers the information
security field a head start by ensuring
that the certificate holder understands
the fundamentals such as information
gathering attacking computers or servers
Wireless attacks and social engineering
so the objective of CHS inform the
public that credentialed individuals
meet or exceed the minimum standards
second establish and govern minimum
standards of
credity third professional information
security specialist in ethical hacking
so now we'll have an exam overview so
the exam name is EC Council certified
ethical hacker and the exam duration is
240 minutes and you will get questions
that is 125 questions you will get in
the exam and it is a multiple choice
question exam and the passing score you
need is
70% and to register for the exam you
should go to PE view or ECC Exam Center
and eligibility criteria for CHS there
are two ways to satisfy the eligibility
criteria that is attend official CH
training and this can be in any format
example instructor lab training computer
Based training or live online training
as long as the program is approved by EC
Council and attempt without official
training in order to be considered for
the EC council certification exam
without attending official training you
must have two or more years of
documented information security
experience remit a non-refundable
eligibility application fee of $100
submit completed CH exam eligibility
form including verification from an
employer upon approval EC Council will
email your voucher number to register
for the CH exam so this was all about
the CH exam and now we'll move to the
steps to become ethical hacker so
ethical hacking is an exciting and
rapidly growing field that requires a
combination of technical skills
knowledge and a strong sense of Ethics
by following these steps you can begin
your journey towards becoming an ethical
hacker and contribute to enhancing cyber
security so step one that is knowledge
of computer systems and networks step
two you should have Proficiency in
programming languages step three
networking and security Concepts you
should have a knowledge of it third
knowledge of web application and
database fifth understanding of
operating systems step six familiarity
with ethical hacking tools step seven
problem solving and analytical thinking
step eight knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques step nine
certifications so now we will elaborate
all the steps one by one so we'll start
with knowledge of computer systems and
networks so to become an ethical hacker
it is crucial to have a deep
understanding of computer systems and
networks this involves familiarizing
yourself with the inner workings of
computer system Network protocols
operating systems and how different
components interact within a network
environment by gaining this knowledge
you will be better equipped to identify
vulnerabilities and assess potential
security risk and the next is Prof profy
in programming languages so programming
languages are an essential tool for
ethical hackers by gaining Proficiency
in programming languages such as python
C++ Java JavaScript SQL per and Ruby you
will be able to develop your own scripts
automate task and create exploit codes
these programming languages provide the
foundation for writing secure and
efficient code as well as manipulating
and analyzing data the next step is
networking and security Concepts to
effectively assess and secure networks
it is important to have a solid
understanding of networking and security
concept this includes familiarizing
yourself with topics such as Network
protocols network security principles
encryption techniques and firewall
configurations understanding how data is
transmitted secured and protected in a
network environment will enable you to
identify potential vulnerabilities and
Implement appropriate security measures
step four knowledge of web application
and database knowledge so in today's
interconnect World web applications and
databases are common targets for hackers
therefore it is crucial to develop a
strong understanding of web application
architectures web protocols and database
systems pay special attention to Common
vulnerability specific to web
applications such as SQ injection crite
scripting xss and crite request forgery
csrf by gaining expertise in these areas
you will be able to effectively assess
the security of web applications and
databases and provide appropriate
recommendations for securing them and
the next step is understanding of
operating systems so operating systems
form the backbone of computer systems
and are often targeted by hackers it is
important to gain a comprehensive
understanding of different operating
systems such as Windows Linux or Mac OS
this includes understanding system
configurations file permissions user
management and security mechanism
specific to each operating system this
knowledge will enable you to identify
vulnerabilities apply patches and secure
operating systems effectively step six
familiarity with ethical hacking tools
ethical hackers rely on a variety of
tools to assess and secure systems and
networks familiarize yourself with
popular ethical hacking tools such as
met spotl wi shock and map BB suit Ki
Linux canas SQL ninja and B these tools
provide functionalities for
vulnerability scanning Network sniffing
exploit development and penetration
testing and understanding how to use
these tools effectively will enhance
your capabilities as an ethical head now
we'll see the step seven that is problem
solving and analytical thinking so being
an ethical hacker requires strong
problem solving skills and the ability
to think analytically you will often
encounter complex systems and face
intricate security challenges developing
your problem solving abilities and
analytical thinking will help you
approach these challenges systematically
identify vulnerabilities and device
effective strategies to mitigate gate
risk it is essential to stay updated
with the latest security Trends and
Technologies to enhance your problem
solving skills and the step eight is
knowledge of common attack vectors and
techniques so to defend against
potential threats you must familiarize
yourself with common hacking techniques
and attack vectors used by malicious
hackers this include social engineering
fishing attacks password cracking
network based attacks and more
understanding how these attacks work and
the methodologies used will enable you
to to proactively identify and prevent
potential security breaches and now the
step nine that is certifications while
certifications are not mandatory to
start a career in ethical hacking they
can provide a structured learning path
and validate your skills and knowledge
consider pursuing certification such as
certified ethical hacker CH offensive
security certified professional OSP
certified information system security
professional cissp certified penetration
Testing Engineer cpte and certified
security analyst ecsa these
certifications demonstrate your
expertise and dedication to the field
enhancing your credibility as an ethical
hacker now we'll see the job roles in
ethical hacking field so starting with
like there are several job roles in
ethical hacking such as here's an
elaboration on E job role in ethical
hacking and we'll see some of the major
ethical hacker job roles so starting
with ethical hacker so an ethical hacker
is a skilled professional who legally
attempts to penetrate computer system
and networks to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses they use their knowledge
to strengthen the security
infrastructure and protect against cyber
threats and the next is network security
engineer network security Engineers
specialize in securing and maintaining
computer networks within an organization
they Implement and manage security
measures such as firewalls intrusion
detection systems and virtual private
networks that is VPN to protect
sensitive data then we have cyber
security analyst so cyber security
analyst Monitor and analyze systems for
potential security breaches or incidents
they investigate threats develop
security protocols and Implement
measures to protect against attacks the
next is penetration tester penetration
testers also known as ethical hackers
simulate real world attacks to identify
vulnerabilities in computer systems
networks and applications they conduct
Thor assessments and provide
recommendations for improving security
the next is information security manager
information security managers are
responsible for overseeing an
organization's overall security strategy
and ensuring the protection of sensitive
data they develop and Implement security
policies manage security teams and
handle incident response and the next is
cyber security engineer so cyber
security Engineers design and Implement
security systems including firewalls
encryption protocols and intrusion
detection systems they also conduct risk
assessments and perform security audits
to maintain a security
environment and the next is security
consultant Security Consultants provide
expert advice and guidance on security
strategies and solutions they assess
vulnerabilities develop security plans
and assist organizations in improving
their overall security posture in the
United States these requirements are
very high and this was all for this
tutorial did you know that in August
this year Google openly admitted that
some of its Gmail accounts were hack ban
Iranian group fortunately the event was
isolated and was taken care of but
rarely are security breaches this easy
to stop with more and more data moving
to the cloud the prospects of hacks like
these have grown in the past decade
exponentially consequently organizations
have now discovered the need to secure
the digital infrastructure against
various attack vectors fueling the need
for ethical hackers in the IT industry
so today's video is all about how you
can learn the ins and outs of hacking
and cyber security irrespective of your
learning background so welcome to our
video on how to become an ethical hacker
by simply learn before we get get
started Ure you subscribed to the
channel so you always stay updated with
the latest Technologies and Trends let's
first clear the air on an ethical
Hacker's role the term hacking has
inherently negative connotations however
this will only be applicable until the
duty of an ethical hacker is properly
understood ethical hackers are the good
people in the hacking field wearing the
white hat so what exactly is the
responsibility of an ethical hacker
instead of utilizing the extensive
computer expertise for criminal purposes
ethical hackers find gaps in data and
computer sec security for businesses and
organizations worldwide to defend
themselves against hackers with less
than noble intentions ethical hacking is
a subcategory of cyber security that
involves lawfully breaking a system
security mechanisms in order to discover
possible threats and data leaks on the
network ethical hackers can work for
cooperation as independent Freelancers
inh house security staff for its website
or its applications or as simulated
offensive cyber Security Professionals
as well all of these careers need
knowledge of current attack
methodologies and tools albe the
in-house expert may need to be
knowledgeable about a single kind of
software or digital asset but how can
you hone your ethical hacking skills
let's take a look at few steps one can
take while starting a career in this
field the first step is getting
comfortable with Linux there are
operating systems catered specifically
to ethical hackers like kly Linux and
parro security both are based on Linux
derivatives and have a plethora of tools
to make your hacking workflow easy and
relatively stressfree the better vers
you are with Linux and its terminal the
quicker you can achieve things when
hacking the next would be to master the
mother of all programming languages
which is the C programming language
since Linux and a lot of backend code
are written in C having a strong hand
over this programming language is very
important it's always helpful to learn a
couple more relevant languages like
python or JavaScript which will help you
dissect giant pieces of server code like
butter remaining Anonymous is vital in
the hacking sphere since giving a
malicious actor news of your existence
on a Target Network can cause him then
to flee or attack your device in instead
the usage of Mac address randomizers and
proxy chains is highly beneficial and
recommended when monitoring networks for
criminal activity and speaking of
proxies ethical hackers must understand
networking fundamentals and exactly how
they are established learning about
various networks and protocols might
help you exploit flaws an ethical hacker
with an extensive understanding of
networking tools such as wire shock nmap
and others can overcome field incidents
relatively unscathed the fifth skill in
our list is traversing the darkware
using the famous store browser
most of the internet is hidden behind
the Tor networks and getting a closer
look at the people who often are at the
Forefront of the hacking industry in the
dark web directly can help you
familiarize yourself with a certain
domain Secrets while keeping you updated
with the latest happenings in the cyber
crime World A major advantage that can
tip the skills in the Famer of an
ethical hacker is the knowledge of
cryptography or encryption encryption is
used in various elements of information
security including authentication data
Integrity anonymity and others password
and other sensitive information are
always encrypted on our Network a hacker
must understand how to recognize and
break these encryption standards
exploring vulnerabilities make you a
better ethical hacker simply keeps you
aware of the security measures that are
kept in place as industry standards
while handing you the most advanced
penetration testing tools on the market
learning how to scan networks and
systems for vulnerabilities that might
result in a security Beach ethical
hackers may also attempt to write
vulnerabilities to exploit the system in
question as a final tip join forums for
conversations with other hackers
worldwide to trade share expertise and
collaborate Discord Reddit Telegram and
other platforms all have communities
where you can join and collaborate with
fellow Learners to broaden your learning
Spectrum now that we understand some
basic skills ethical hackers need to
excel in this domain let us look at the
road map one can follow to get started
many ethical hackers begin their careers
by studying computer science you can
also acquire an A+ certification from
compia by appearing for and passing two
additional tests these test assess an
individual's understanding of PC
components and their ability to
disassemble and reassemble a PC however
before advancing in your profession you
must gather experience and obtain a
network Plus or a ccns certification the
network plus certification certifies
fundamental Network expertise such as
Network Administration maintenance
deployment and troubleshooting the CCNA
certification guarantees the same skills
and Stripes of foundation level
proficiency once qualified you can
advance to the next level of your career
in network support
you'll be responsible for monitoring and
upgrading installing security software
and testing for vulnerabilities you'll
obtain expertise in network security and
your goal should be offered as a
position as a network engineer as a
network engineer you will build and plan
networks rather than simply maintain
them your focus should now be on the
security part of your journey to
becoming an ethical hacker this is the
time to focus on earning a security
certifications such as Security Plus or
cisp the US Department of Defense has
approved the Security Plus accredition
with which covers testing on critical
areas such as Access Control identity
authentication and cryptography the
cissp certification is a worldwide
recognized security accredition that
validates the expertise of risk
management Cloud technology and
application development The Next Step
would be to start working in the
information security division an
information security analyst studies
systems and network security engages
with security breaches and strives to
implement Security Solutions for this
profession you should focus on
penetration testing to gain Hands-On
experiences some of the most essential
tools of the trade getting the certified
ethical hacker or the C certification
should be your top priority the training
will teach you all you must understand
to become a productive and ethical
hacker you will be engaged in a Hands-On
environment where you will be guided
through breaking into a network and
finding any security flaws after
obtaining this certification you can
begin marketing yourself as a
professional ethical hacker you have
already covered some skills one needs to
learn when starting their Journey
however an ethical hacker has certain
roles and responsibilities that must be
carried out ously the first of which is
threat modeling threat modeling is
optimizing network security by
identifying vulnerabilities and
determining counter measures for
avoiding or reducing an attack's impact
on the system a threat is a real or
projected negative incident jeopardizing
the organization's assets the role of an
ethical hacker is to give a thorough
assessment of potentially harmful
assaults and their potential
consequences they can also conduct
information security audits or a
risk-based evaluation of a company
security these regular exercises assess
Security's Readiness identify it system
weaknesses and offer strategies for
reducing future attack threats they also
assess how successfully security related
policies are implemented resulting in a
report that includes discovered flaws
and appropriate Solutions ethical
writers must be able to collect data
detect vulnerabilities and correlate
risks to create clear and unambiguous
professional reports these evaluations
are frequently used to justify
finalizing security asset expenditures
the market for trained ethical hackers
has never been this expensive according
to various surveys the job outlet for
ethical hackers and information security
analyst is supposed to grow by 33%
between 2020 and 2030 companies like IBM
Google and Microsoft are always on the
lookout for train cyber security
Personnel in this climate of data
breaches and security vulnerabilities we
hope this video has cleared some doubts
regarding where to start and what to
learn during this
journey when it comes to web app hacking
it generally refers to the exploitation
of applications bya HTTP which can be
done by manipulating the applications
via its graphical user interface this is
done by tampering with the uniform
resource identifier also known as a URI
or tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators post these online vains
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your convers ations or produce the back
end of your personal website usually
disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or
HTTP so so hackers attack the web server
to steal credential information
passwords and business information by
using different types of attacks like GS
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
Network packets without having to be in
the same building where the network is
located as wireless networks communicate
through radio waves a hacker can easily
sniff the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer
systems coming to our main focus for
today let us have a look at the top five
most essential ethical hacking tools to
be used in
2021 at the top of the chain lies
nmap nmap which stands for network maper
is a free and open-source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host
service up time it is most beneficial in
the early stages of ethical hacking
where a hacker must figure the possible
entry point to a system before running
the necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage any insecure
openings and thus breach the
device nmap users raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in used and
dozens other characteristics it was
designed to rapidly scan large networks
but works F against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked
device next on our list we have
Metasploit the Metasploit framework is a
very powerful tool that can be used by
cyber criminals as well as ethical
hackers to probe systematic
vulnerabilities on both networks and
servers because it's an open source
framework it can be easily customized
and used with most operating
systems with Metasploit the ethical
hacking team can use readymade or custom
code and introduce it into a network to
probe for weak spots as another flavor
of threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
fed into the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the
device a big advantage of Metasploit is
the ability to run full-fledged scans on
the target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
softwares having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the
list moving on we have the actic
framework acuns is an endtoend web
security scanner which offers a 360°
view of an organization security it is
an application security ing tool that
helps the company address vulnerability
across all their critical web
assets the need to be able to test
application in depth and further than
traditional vulnerability management
tools has created a market with several
players in the application security
space actic can detect over 7,000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross- site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other out of band
vulnerabilities it can scan all pages
web apps and complex web applications
running HTML 5 and JavaScript as well it
also lets you scan complex multi-level
forms and even password protected areas
of the
site actic is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as sast scanners sast tools
only work during development and only
for specific languages and have a
history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas Dynamic testing tools
also known as D have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal
issues next on our list we have
airgeddon this is a multi-use bash
script used for Linux systems to hack
and audit wireless networks like our
everyday Wi-Fi router and its
counterparts along with being able to
launch denial of service attacks on
compromised networks this multi-purpose
wi-fi hacking tool has very rich
features which support multiple methods
for wi-fi hacking including WPS hacking
modes WP attacks handshake captures evil
twin and so much
more it usually needs an external
network adapter that supports monitor
mode which is necessary to be able to
capture Wireless traffic that Traverse
the air
channels thanks to its open-source
nature air Garden can be used with multi
Community plugins and add-ons thereby
increasing its Effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
GHz and the 5 GHz
band finally at number five we have John
the Ripper John the Ripper is an
open-source password security auditing
and the password recovery tool which is
available for many operating
systems John the Ripper jumbo supports
hundred of hash and Cipher types
including for user passwords of
operating systems web apps database
servers encrypted keys and document
files some of the key features of the
tool include offering multiple modes to
speed up the password cracking
automatically deselecting the hashing
algorithm used by the passwords and the
ease of running and configurating the
tool to make it password cracking
easier it can use dictionary attacks
along with regular brute forcing to
speed up the process of cracking the
correct password without wasting
additional resources the word list being
used in these dictionary attacks can be
used by the users and allowing for a
completely customizable
process we also have a few honorary
mentions in our list that just missed
the cut net sparker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported vulner
abilities the burp suit professional is
one of the most popular penetration
testing and vulnerability finder tools
and it's used for checking web
application security the term burp as it
is commonly known is a proxy based tool
which is used to evaluate the security
of web- based application and to do
Hands-On testing moving away from
websites and applications yashar is a
free and open- Source packet analyzer
which was launched in 2006 it is used
for Network troubles shooting analysis
software and Communications protocol
development and education it captures
Network traffic on the local network and
stores data for offline analysis ysha
captures Network traffic from ethernet
Bluetooth wireless networks and frame
relay
connections now that we learn about the
different types of tools that can be
used when conducting an ethical hacking
audit let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits being able to identify defects
from an attacker's perspective is
game-changing since it displays all the
potential Avenues of a possible hack one
can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an
organization being able to gauge such
shortcomings before they become public
and can be used exploited is a benefit
most organizations make use of this is
not to imply that such security a aits
are only beneficial to the organization
paying for it when coming across
companies that provide certain Services
a reliable third party security audit
goes a long way in instilling trust and
confidence over their craft if the
ethical hackers cannot find any major
vulnerabilities that can be leveraged by
hackers it just accentuates the
technical bence of the organization and
its Engineers thereby increasing the
clientele by a substantial amount in
this we are going to discuss ethical
hacking and penetration testing so we
going to talk about the concepts about
what constitutes an ethical hack and
what is a penetration test we're going
to talk about the different types of
penetration test and how they can be
done we're going to talk about an
operating system called K Linux and
we're going to talk about its usage and
its importance in cyber security we'll
also be discussing the different phases
of penetration test and how people or
hackers would utilize these phases uh to
gain their objectives we will also be
discussing in what areas can we do a
penetration test how to do those
penetration tests we'll be discussing
quite a few bit of penetration testing
tools that are available in the Ki Linux
space and then we'll be looking at a
couple of demos at the end of the
session to understand how these tools in
the operating system can be utilized for
various hacks so let's start with with
what is ethical hacking now plainly
defined ethical hacking is locating
weaknesses or vulnerabilities of
computers and information systems using
the intent and actions of a malicious
hacker the major difference is here that
we we are hired to discover those
weaknesses in a legal and ethical manner
that means first and foremost our intent
should not be malicious we do not wish
any harm to the organization and
whatever we discover is reported back
and not misused once we report back we
would also be trying to help them out to
mitigate or remove those weaknesses of
vulnerabilities to enhance the company
security posture so essentially we would
have the same training or the same
knowledge as that of a malicious hacker
except that the intent is going to be
different the intent is going to help
the organization achieve security to
protect themselves against malicious
hackers and the second most important
thing about ethical hacking is that we
authorized to do that activity I cannot
in good faith hack somebody and then
tell them you know what I just I just
wanted to help you out and uh here are
your vulnerabilities and uh this is the
way you can prevent them I first need
the authorization from the other party
and only then can I perform an ethical
hack so in this example hacker attacks
an individual with malicious intent and
makes misuse of whatever information
they have gotten they steal the data
they maybe fry the operating system
Hardware destroy it and thus uh they
leave the victim without uh a device
with authorization an ethical hacker can
also attack the same individual minus
the destruction of course and the intent
is good so they're willingly finding out
the vulnerabilities and helping the
victim plug them out so that they
wouldn't be a victim of a malicious
attack now here the first thing is
authorization from the victim and the
second thing is the good intent where we
do not misuse those vulnerabilities and
we report them back to the victim or to
the client and help them uh patch those
vulnerabilities that's the main
difference between a white hat and a
black hat so Security Experts are
normally termed as white hat hackers
malicious hackers are termed as black
hats now the responsibilities of ethical
hacker are multi fold first and foremost
you have to create scripts test for
vulnerabilities first have to identify
those in the first place so there's
vulnerability assessment identifying
those vulnerabilities and then you're
going to test them to see the validity
and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is a risk risk
is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a possibility of getting
hacked so let's say I as a ethical
hacker run a vulnerability scanner on a
particular client I identify 10
different vulnerabilities within those
10 vulnerabilities I do a risk
assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the
once they get hacked and the loss could
not only be loss of data it could be
Financial losses it could be loss of
reputation penalties they have to pay to
the client for breaches or penalties
that they may have to pay for pay the
governments in case of breaches that
happened that uh couldn't be controlled
another responsibility of the ethical
hacker is to set up policies in such a
way that it becomes difficult for
hackers to get access to devices or to
protected data and finally train the
staff for network security so we got a
lot of employees in an organization we
need to train the staff of what is
allowed and what is not allowed how to
keep themselves secure so that they
don't get compromised thus becoming a
vulnerability themselves to the
organization the policies that we have
talked about are administrative policies
to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted
and till you create that password you're
not allowed to log in or you're not
allowed to register so let's move on to
understand what is penetration testing
now for penetration testing there's a
phase called vulnerability assessment
that happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing but running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
information systems so you have
identified that flaw maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be uh a buffer over overrun flaw
or it could be a simple password
cracking attempt your idea is to create
those tools create those attacks and try
to penetrate into those areas where
security is weak uh the essense of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks could be anything
like a fishing attack a password
cracking attack a denal service attack
or any other viabilities that you have
identified uh during the vity scan so
what is K Linux and why is it used Ki
Linux is an operating system oftenly
used by hackers and ethical hackers both
because of the tool sets that the
operating system contains it is a
Operating System created by
professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a dbn based operating system
with Advanced penetration testing and
security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus or tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of the attacks man in-the
middle attacks sniffing password
cracking any of these attacks would be
possible with all the tools available
you just need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said hundred of hundreds of tools
that are used for various information
security tasks like uh computer
forensics reverse reverse engineering
information finding even uh getting
access to different machines and then uh
creating viruses worms Trojans anything
that you will 600 plus tools in the Kali
Linux operating system there are
periodic updates that are given out to
the operating system as well it is open
source that means it is free to utilize
you can even have the source code you
can modify it if you want to there's
customizations available for all the
tools you can download third party tools
and install them if you want there's a
white support for wireless uh network
cards multiple languages are being
supported at the time at the same time
as well and you can create a lot of
attacking uh scripts you can create
attacking tools and you can write your
own exploits as well on K Linux so this
all all in all helps you create a very
robust system where you can create your
own taxs and then launch them against
unsuspecting victims now that is illegal
so as far ethical hacking is concerned
once you have authorization you're going
to identify which tools to be utilized
you're going to get the appropriate
permissions and only then are you going
to attempt those attacks let's talk
about the phases of penetration testing
now there are five different phases the
first one is the recognizance phase also
known as the information gathering phase
this is the most important phase for any
hacker this is where the hacker or the
ethical hacker if you will will gather
as much information about the target's
victim or Y vers the V the victim right
so once you have that information you
would then be able to identify what tool
sets to include and how to attack the
victim for example you you want to find
out the IP addresses the domains
subdomains the network architecture that
is being utilized you want to identify
operating systems that are being
utilized the network IP ranges that are
being utilized and so on so forth you
might want to identify employees within
an organization for social engineering
attacks in the future email addresses
telephone numbers anything and
everything that will help you validate
and give you information about the
target is something that you want to do
in the recognizance phase at this point
in time we are not going to question
whether whatever information we are
getting is useful or not only time will
tell depending on the various attacks
that we will be building up later on
this becomes your Baseline this becomes
your database with all the information
about the victim so that you can come
back from later stages back to the
recognizance phase to look at the
information that You' have gathered and
then you can f tune your attacks once
you have done that you're going to uh
then start the scanning phase based on
the information that you have gathered
you're going to identify live machines
within the network once you've
identified the life machines you'll scan
them for open ports protocols and
procedures any processes that are
running and then we going to identify
vulnerabilities Within These processes
and Within These open ports so in the
scanning phase uh why do we need to find
live machines because we want to find
out the machines that have booted up
have an operating system and are running
on the network if an machine is not
available on the network or is in a
shutdown mode that machine cannot be
hacked through a technical attack then
it will be a physical attack where you
physically go to the machine and then do
whatever you want to do with it for a
technical attack you will have to
identify the machines that have booted
up then you're going to scan the open
ports because that's going to be our
entry point and on the port would be a
service that is running so you scan the
service as well identify the version of
the service and then do a vulnerability
scan to identify if there are any
vulnerabilities on those services that
are running and then based on all of
this information we are going to develop
our attacks as we go on so once we have
this we we go onto the gaining access
phase where we are going to attack and
try to get access to our victims
machines could be a social engineering
attack based on the information
gathering we have done in the technical
assessment in scanning phase if you have
identified a vulnerability you're going
to identify a relevant exploit and then
use that exploit to try to gain access
or we might just craft a Trojan and try
to uh execute that Trojan on the
victim's machine to uh check if we can
get access through that particular
manner once we have the access could be
even a simple password cracking attack
which we have been able to accomplish
and we have cracked the password of the
person and now we have gained access to
that person's computer right but these
attacks would be temporary for example
we have cracked a password somebody
changes the password every 30 days after
that period our attack would be useless
if a Trojan is executed we get a
connection to that machine for once but
then how do we get get a repeated
connection over and over again if we
want to reconnect to that machine so
that's where we come into the
maintaining access phase where we
install uh root kits key loggers
sniffers and things like that where we
could get a backd door entry to the
victim's machine if we have already been
successfully installed a trojen we would
want to add the Trojan to the startup
menu so that every time the operating
system starts the Trojan gets
automatically executed and thus we
maintain the back door entry to that
victim's machine once we have done all
of this all these activities are going
to leave a trace in the victim's machine
so if you install a Trojan a Trojan
being an application would create
directories and files a virus would be
destructive in nature if you're
executing a script it will leave some
logs behind if we even login through the
cracked password that we have it will
create a login entry at for that
particular time stamp along with the IP
address that we utilized in the covering
tracks we are essentially trying to
avoid detection by deleting traces of
our activity that means that we need to
identify where logs are been stored we
need to address those logs and we need
to delete them or modify them in such a
way that our activity is not traceable
so these are the five main phases of a
penetration test gather as much
information as you can scan for machines
ports protocols and services running on
the victims device try to gain access by
password cracking prions exploits for
the V lities if any maintain that access
by installing further software which
will allow you to get back door access
to that particular system and then try
to cover your tracks by deleting all
traces of your activity once successful
the victim will have no idea and you
have a backd door entry and you can
monitor the victim to the extent that
you want now in an ethical Hacker's
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
the attacks we have got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
manners first is the blackbox test the
blackbox test is where no information is
given to the ethical hacker about the it
infrastructure so they have no idea what
it is they start right from the first
phase of the information gathering
gather as much information they can and
based on the gathered information they
try to create and launch attacks to see
if they are going to be successful now
not only does it test the knowledge of
the penetration tester it would also
test the security implementations that
the organization has done to see whether
they can identify the attack and prevent
it in the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the it infrastructure is
given think of it from a employees
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges like an administrator but is
just a a regular employee does that
means that they got limited access
within the organization based on which
they get some knowledge of the it
infrastructure so this is an attempt of
an Insider uh simulation attack where a
regular user may want to try to misuse
the access that they've been given and
then try to gather information or try to
gain access to other devices which they
are not authorized to the third test is
white box where there's full knowledge
of the it infrastructure that has been
given so this is again a simulation of
an Insider attack a malicious Insider if
you will but at this point in time the
person has complete knowledge of the
infrastructure could be in an
administrative position and then they
are trying to leverage their access to
see if they can get information or they
can compromise any stuff any of the data
so the three attacks would be the first
one blackbox where we are simulating uh
external threat a hacker sitting outside
the organization trying to gain access
the gray box is an inside threat where
there is a regular employee who is
trying to get access to infrastructure
that they are not authorized for and
then the third audit is a white box
audit where there's an administrator who
has all the leverage all the access and
the visibility within the infrastructure
and then they're trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test thus compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of the user so first and
foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in the network all of these
are devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some V
Liberties behind if we as ethical
hackers are able to identify these flaws
these misconfigurations these
vulnerabilities we could then try to
exploit them and try to to gain access
to the network and devices within that
Network by uh getting access to the
network in the first place then we have
the web applications web applications
are nothing but softwares that are
developed over or deployed over a web
server and are made available over the
intranet or the internet for example uh
websites that we visit or web
applications like Facebook if you will
right so if these applications have vnab
abilities within them we then try to
attack the web based applications and
thus try to bypass Authentication get
access to database or try to leak
information through those applications
if not then we try to attack the client
side now web application is at the
server level and is hosted by the
deployer so that's at the server side
the client side is where we as users are
using a computer with a browser and
trying to interact with the web
application now the browser and the
operating system that we are utilizing
would have its own vulnerabilities does
identifying a client side viability and
then exploiting it to either either hack
the client or then piggy back on the
client connection and try to get access
to the server so either you could attack
the network the web application or the
client side itself or you could attack
wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphones
tablets faets all of those connected to
them if you're able to access any of
these devices through the wireless it
would help you gain access to other
devices on the wireless as well and then
social engineering so this is where
you're trying to attack humans you're
tracking an employee of a corporation to
reveal some confidential information
knowingly or unknowingly by tricking
them with fake Mals or fake websites or
malicious emails that you have sent to
them uh which they have failed to
recognize as malicious and they click on
it thus getting victimized social
engineering attacks are always uh
successful because of the gullibility of
humans empathy sympathy humans basically
have emotions emotions can be toyed with
and then taken advantage of if the
person is not careful enough for example
the most common social engineering
attack that we see is the Nigerian fraud
where we receive an email that someone
somewhere has died and has left a huge
estate behind a few hundred million doar
and we have been identified as the
person through whom they want to
transfer the money to a foreign land to
save on taxes what are the chances of
that happening on a daily bases right
how many princes are there so that's
something that we do not verify it's
just the I guess the greed if you will
of striking it rich quickly that makes
us believe these kind of emails uh we
have also received emails of lottery
tickets that we have won over a period
of time without even having bought a
lottery ticket so if you haven't bought
one what did you win but we don't ask
these questions we just get excited
about the amount of money that we have
won and then we try to bet on our luck
and try to see if that uh email is going
to fructify or is it just another scam
so social engineering attacks are dime a
dozen these days and we need to be very
careful on what we trust on the internet
let's look at the penetration testing
tools there are hundreds and thousands
of tools out there most of these have
been concised and collected together and
hosted on a operating system known as
Kali Linux that we have talked about
earlier now the predecessor to K Linux
was backtrack backtrack is no longer
continued it has been discontinued and K
Linux has taken uh the place of back
crack within which are all the tools
that you see on your screen Metasploit
is one of the most favorite p ntion
testing tools of hackers and ethical
hackers uh there are a lot of inbuilt
exploits over there and we'll be doing a
demo at the end of the session on this
and map is the information gathering
tool which will scan for live devices
scan for open ports protocols and
services beef would be an application
testing tool that would help us uh find
exploits within applications nessus
vulnerability scanner is a network and a
host based scanner that would help you
identify V abilities within such hosts W
shock is a network Network sniffer which
allows you to capture Network packets
and and analyze them to see if there are
there is any information worth capturing
within those packets SQL map is a
automated tool used for SQL injection
attacks so you don't even have to craft
your queries for SQL injection it will
be done by the SQL map tool you just
need to identify whatever is possible
through the queries that this SQL is
going to create and then based on the
activity that you've identified you just
need to read find your search parameters
to get access to the database we'll be
doing a demo on SQL map or SQL map as
well and then there is John the Ripper
John the Ripper is a tool that is used
for password cracking so dictionary
attacks Brute Force attacks are done
using John the Ripper what is a
dictionary attack a dictionary attack is
an attack where we create list of all
probable passwords store them in a txt
file and run that list against the
password tool to see if any of those
passwords are going to match a Brute
Force attack is trying the same attack
attack but with every permutation and
combination of the alphabet that we have
and we're going to try to figure out uh
if we are able to crack the password at
all so these are just some of the tools
for every tool there are another
supporting 100 tools or more than that
uh like for NS vulnerability scanner
you'll have callus vulnerability scanner
you have uh GFI lard and there are other
lots of other softwares out there but
these are some of the most commonly
utilized tools let's look at the metas
sploit attack Metasploit is a framework
of penetration testing that makes
hacking very simple you just need to
know how to utilize the tool you need to
identify the vulnerability associate it
with a particular exploit and then run
the exploit on Metasploit uh we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits in active exploits it's
exploits a specific computer runs until
execution and then exits uses brute
force and exits when an error occurs in
a passive exploit these exploits wait
for incoming requests and exploit them
as soon as they connect they can also be
used in conjunction with email and web
browsers so in passive exploits we
create a payload we uh like a reverse
connection payload we send it to the
victim once the victim installs that
software the machine will then initiate
a connection to us our machine will be
in a listen mode and then we will once
the software is executed at the and we
would then try to connect and exploit
that particular vulnerability this is
the uh practical that we'll be doing on
metasite so let's move on with the demos
and then we'll see uh what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look at some of the demos that we
had uh talked about in the ethical
hacking and penetration testing module
we are going to look at three different
demos the first one is going to be a SQL
injection attack that we're going to
perform on this tool that we have the
second one is a password cracking attack
on Windows 7 and a third one is a meta
based or a metas based shell shock
attack on a Linux based web server so
let's get cracking I've powered on this
virtual machine uh which is the ovas
broken web application it is a tool that
is provided for for people who want to
enhance their skills and they can
practice uh how to do these attacks in a
legal manner so we are going to go to
this site I'm just going to open up my
browser the IP address is 7113 to and
that's the OAS broken web application
that we want to utilize we're going to
head off to mutil Day 2 and we are going
to look at a SQL injection attack where
we want to bypass authentication now
this takes us to the login screen so we
can just try our luck here and see that
the authentication mechanism works the
account does not exist so the username
and password that we have supplied is
not the correct one so we want to ensure
that there's a SQL database and uh we
can uh try to attack it and see uh if we
can bypass the authentication now uh
what we want to do is we want to create
a SQL based malformed query that can
give us a different output so I'm just
going to type in a single quote over
here and type login and you can see that
this is now suddenly recognized as a uh
operator and there's a error that is
given out compared to the login that we
tried uh earlier when we used a proper
text based login mechanism it gave us
the account does not exist but here the
single code gave us a error and it shows
us how SQL works this is the query that
we had created now in the trainings that
you have for ethical hacking there would
be explanations of what these queries
are all about how the syntax works here
we just going to see if we can create a
malform query to log in as the user in
this case so what I'm going to do is uh
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it R one equals one space
hyphen hyphen space and if you now click
login you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database and Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
at a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of a page I
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we
calling upon when we connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user or password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or and
give it a condition single quote r 1
equals 1 space hyphen hyen space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it would
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the SQL
uh injection attack that we wanted to
look at let's move on to password
cracking now this is a Windows 7 machine
that we have I'm just going to do a very
basic password cracking example we're
just going to log in now here the
assumption is that we are able to log in
we have access to a computer and we want
to check out other users who are using
this computer and see if we can find out
their passwords so that uh we can log in
as a different user steal data if
required and we wouldn't be to blame if
there are any lcks that are created so
here we've got a tool called can and
able that is installed right here now
I'm already an administrator on this
machine I'm checking out other
administrators who share the same
privileges or any other user who may be
on this system whose password I can
crack and thus I would be able to get
access through their account and then do
any malicious activity right so this
allows me to go into a cracker tool and
it allows me to enumerate this machine
and identify all the users and passwords
that are there in this particular
machine right so I'm just going to click
on the plus sign and I'm going to import
uh hashes from a local system so where
are these files stored where does
Windows store its passwords and what
format are they stored and what this
tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as a
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users are hacker admin test the
one that we logged in as and then
there's a user called virus as well and
you can see that this is the hash value
of the password that is being utilized
now there's a particular format uh for a
hash value for Windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if I want to crack this password
there various attacks that we can do for
example a dictionary based attack or a
Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so
we're going to try to create an llm hash
attack and here we're going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and uh lower case a through Zed
uppercase a through Zed numeric 0
through and all the special characters
let's say the password is between 7 and
16 characters and this is the character
set that we want to try the Brute Force
attack on what is a Brute Force attack
it is an attack where the computer is
going to try each and every permutation
and combination out of this character
set and try to figure out if the
password is going to be correct so if we
click Start it's going to start with a
particular characters and then it is
going to identify if that ntlm hash is
going to work against this character and
you can see the time is going to be
finished nominal over here so it's not
necessary that this attack would be
viable it will be 100% successful given
the time frame however the time frame is
huge enough for this attack to become a
little bit redundant there are other
attacks that we can do which can easily
identify this data for us as well but
that is something that we will look on
in future videos so that's how we can
get access to users and passwords uh
there are different mechanisms where
let's say we don't have login access
then what are we going to do how we can
create a fake user login or how we can
remotely access a machine and then try
to get the same access and that is what
we going to try to do in the next demo
on a Linux machine so what we are doing
in a Linux machine could also be doable
on the Windows machine with a different
exploit so what I'm going to do is this
is the Linux web server that I have that
I'm going to power on I'm going to use a
k Linux machine to hack that device and
I'm going to just power off my Windows 7
machine give it a minute till it boots
up now this is also a demo Ma machine
that we have which has its own
preconfigured vulnerabilities so here
we've got something from the pentesters
lab uh and has a shell shock
vulnerability imp implemented inside
shell shock vulnerability affects Linux
Mac and Unix based operating systems for
a particular version of The Bash shell
bash is the bone again shell which is
the command line interface in these
operating systems so what we are trying
to do here is we're going to use the Ki
Linux machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we're going to use metas sploit to
attack this machine now the first and
foremost thing is we want to identify
the IP address we have no idea what the
IP address is we are in the same subnet
so we are assuming that we able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my IP address is
this with a subnet mask of 255 255 25.0
so I want to see if there are any other
machines that are live in the same
subnet and we are doing a ping Swip over
here to identify which machines are live
in a minute we'll get all the IP
addresses 71.1 2 133 254 and 128 we know
that we are 128 at this point in time uh
254 is the DHCP server so we assuming
that 133 is the machine that we want to
look at and let's then try to see if we
can scan that machine 133 and we're
going to do an intense scan to find out
which ports are open what services are
running over there and if it is we the
pintest machine that we were looking for
you can see of the start Port 22 and
Port 80 and somewhere here it's going to
give us the ports that are open and the
details about those ports and somewhere
here it will tell us that this is the
pentester lab machine that we wanted
which is correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what
we're going to do is I'm going to use
another GUI based tool called Sparta
which I can just find out from here
Sparta uses two tool tools in the
background a nmap tool and a tool called
ncto so we just going to start scanning
192 168
71133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information there we are that's the ncto
tool coming in scanning on Port 80 which
is uh which means that it's a web server
using HTTP it tells us it's an up HT
httpd
2.2.2 and gives us the 22 port number as
well if we head over to the tab of ncto
or let's look at the screenshot first
this is what the website would be
looking like and ncto gives us the
options over here it tells us that there
is a vulnerability over here for shell
shock and this is the path where the
vulnerability is going to exist so what
we going to do we go back to the command
line sorry we open up a new one minimize
all these other windows and we going to
open up metas spit metas flid is a
penetration testing tool that is used by
most hackers and ethical hackers to test
applications and test uh existing
exploits and vulnerabilities so just
give it a minute till it starts you can
see there are already around 1,700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in metasite
in this version so all of these are
windows based if we scroll up we will be
looking at other vulnerabilities as well
or exploits the unique exploits LX OSX
multi exploits and we're looking for uh
exploit for um multi- based Apache or
HTTP let's go up uh let's look at so
this is the one that we're looking for
Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victim's machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin SL status enter
now with the exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and it will give us a list of
all the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP connection which is this so we know
it's a Linux operating system we want
this uh payload to be set so set payload
let enter that's the payload coming in
show options now that we have set the
payload this is the options for the
exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payloads as well so we
are creating a reverse TCP connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
local host or lhost 192
16871 1228 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack I can see that it
has created a MPR session at the victim
site and it has opened up a session so
if I do a PWD now PWD is a Linux command
for present working directory and it
will show us that we'll connect it to
where to du duub CGI hyen bin do an LS
it will list all the files that's the
status file over there do a CD back
slash it will take us to the root of
this machine and if you're someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security that is by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional while he sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered Jude is waiting at the airport
to hop on her flight back home when she
realizes that she missed making an
important Bank payment she connects her
laptop to the public WiFi at the airport
and goes ahead to carry out the bank
transaction everything goes well and
Jude completes her
transaction after a couple of days she
was wiped off her feet when she learned
that her bank account was subjected to a
cyber attack and a hefty amount was
wiped from her account after getting in
touch with the bank Authority she
learned that her account was hacked at
the airport she then realized that the
public Wi-Fi she used might have caused
her this trouble Jude wishes that had
her bank transfer escape the Hacker's
eyes she would not have been a victim of
a Cyber
attack Bank officials advise her to use
a bpn for future transactions especially
when connecting to an open or public
network like most of us Jude had come
across the term VPN several times but
didn't know much about it and little did
she think that the repercussions of not
using a VPN would be this bad let's
understand how the hacker would have
exploited jud's transaction in the
absence of a VPN in this process judee's
computer first connects to the internet
service provider ISP which provides
access to the internet she sends her
details to the bank server using her IP
address Internet Protocol address or IP
address is a unique address that
recognizes a particular device be it a
laptop or smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects judee's Bank details
without being detected more often or not
in such an attack payment information is
likely to be stolen the targeted data
here are the victim's username passwords
and other personal information such an
unsecured connection exposed Jude's IP
address and Bank details to the hacker
when it passed through the public
network so would Jude have been able to
secure her transaction with the help of
a VPN well yes picture Jude's Bank
transaction to be happening in a tunnel
that is invisible to the hacker in such
a case the hacker will not be able to
spot a transaction and that is precisely
what a VPN does a virtual private
Network more often known as bpn creates
a secure tunnel between your device and
the internet for using a VPN Jude's
First Step would be to install
software-based technology known as the
VPN client on her laptop or smartphone
that would let her establish a secure
connection the VPN client connects to
the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP here the VPN client encrypts judee's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure next
the VPN client establishes a VPN tunnel
within the public network that connects
to the VPN server the VPN tunnel
protects Jude's information from being
intercepted by the hacker judee's IP
address and actual location are changed
at the VPN server to enable a private
and secure connection finally the VPN
server connects to judee's bank server
in the last step where the encrypted
message is
decrypted this way judee's original IP
address is hidden by the VPN and the VPN
tunnel protects her data from being
hacked this explains how VPN makes your
data Anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network and the
difference between a normal connection
and a VPN connection after learning
about this Jude was certain that she
should start using a VPN to carry out
her online transactions in the future
this is also applicable to each one of
us even if you work remotely or connect
to public Wi-Fi using a VPN is the
safest option
in addition to providing a secure
encrypted data transfer vpns are also
used to disguise your whereabouts and
give you access to Regional web content
VPN servers act as proxies on the
internet this way your actual location
cannot be established VPN enables you to
spoof your location and switch to a
server to another country and thereby
change your location for example by
doing so you can watch any content on
Netflix that might be unavailable for
your re
meet Jonathan he is an investigative
journalist who occasionally researches
and publishes news articles contrary to
the government's
ideologies on one such occasion he could
not access a Global News website dealing
with uncensored information it seemed
his IP was blocked from visiting the
news website with his IP blocked
Jonathan turned to a popular proxy
service that was able to unblock the
news website thereby allowing an open
internet to all users
just like how your friend gives a proxy
attendance for you a proxy server serves
as a standin user to keep the real
client private but what is a proxy let's
understand its working by taking a look
at how Jonathan was able to access
geoblock content without much hassle a
proxy server acts as a Gateway or
intermediary server between a user and
its destination website when Jonathan
wasn't able to access the news website
he connected his system to a global
proxy server once connected the proxy
server assigns a new IP address to
Jonathan's system an IP address of a
different country where the website is
not censored following this process
whenever Jonathan visits that website
the website administrators see the new
IP address assigned via proxy server and
sees no reason to deny access to their
account once the proxy server is able to
access the website it's passed on to
Jonathan's system via the same channel
regarding accessibility to proxy servers
you must first set it up on your
computer device or network next check
the steps required for your computer or
network as each operating system has its
setup procedures in most cases however
setup entails using an automated
configuration script there are plenty of
free proxy services available on the
internet however the safety of such
proxies is rarely verified most free
proxies will provide an IP address and a
Rel port for connection purposes reputed
proxy providers like smart proxy and
bright data that run on subscription
models will most likely provide
credentials to log into when
establishing the connection this extra
step acts as authentication that
verifies an existing subscription on the
proxy provider server unlike free
providers that are open to all when it
comes to hiding IP addresses many people
consider a VPN to be the primary
solution while that's true up to some
some extent there are a few things
proxies do differently in the case of
vpns extra encryption is also carried
out to create a secure tunnel between
the user's device and a VPN server a VPN
is usually much faster more secure
thanks to multiple layers of encryption
and has little to no downtime proxies
tend to be comparatively unsafe with the
service owners having the exact IP
address of the enduser and having no
guarantees regarding downtimes and
reliability
if you want to know more about how vpns
work do watch how Jude could have
protected her banking credentials using
vpns in our detailed video linked above
now let's take a small quiz to check how
much we have learned what can a VPN
connection provide that a proxy service
cannot a new IP address B multiple
layers of encryption C access to
geoblock content D authentication
credentials think about it and leave
your answers Below in the comment
section and three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers what about
the benefits of a proxy service though
besides allowing access to blocked
content proxies can serve as an
efficient firewall system they can also
filter content from thirdparty websites
allowing control over internet usage in
many cases browsing speeds are
stabilized compared to vanilla Internet
thanks to proper optimization on the
base proxy server the element of privacy
proxy provides is highly lucrative to
people looking to hide their actual IP
address from as many crying eyes as
possible one can easily argue the
benefits of using vpns over proxies for
added security measures however a few
basic tasks don't warrant maximum
privacy for the user's side as in other
cases for example many consumers
worldwide find proxy Services more
convenient since all major operating
systems starting from Windows to Android
allow proxy configur figuration without
the hassle of installing new
applications as is in the case of a VPN
in addition there are services online
that function as web proxies allowing
users to access block content without
any setup from there end they can enter
the target URL and the web proxy will
route data from its physical server this
level of freedom is hard to come by in
the case of vpns making proxies an ideal
solution for casual browsing with the
next generation of Internet exchanges
focused on maximum privacy and security
a variety of ways have been enforced to
maintain them as such censorship has
been shifted from the streets to the
digital domain forces the standard
citizen to derive alternative ways to
maintain anonymity major weapon in this
battle for privacy and security is the T
browser an independent browser meant to
browse the internet while reing
information through the T Network it
serves as a meaningful alternative to
the standard internet browsing habits to
better understand the purpose of this
this browser and such you must learn
about the work of the T Network
featuring its own routing protocol the
to browser is an easy way to maintain
anonymity while browsing without
emptying one's wallet let's take a look
at the topics to be covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the T Network and its
significance in the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
Tor directories in order to circumvent
government
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the to browser and the
distinct advantages the T Network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a t to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the T browser
anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open-source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the tour was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid RIS in development and
innovation of digital products has given
way to frequent data breaches and cyber
thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and security T is one
such underground Network that was
implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the T
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the T Network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user requester Final
Destination these random random users
are volunteer devices which are called
as nodes or relays the T Network
disguises your identity by encrypting
the traffic and moving it across
different to relays within the network
the T Network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router to
operate within the Tor Network a user
has to install the T browser any address
or information requested using the
browser is transmitted through the T
Network it has its own feature set which
will will be covering over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the to network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the sender has data package to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind however
since the data can easily be captured
while being transmitted the security of
this exchange is not very reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the to browser
installed on the client system the
network sends the information to node
one's IP address which encrypts the
information and passes it on to node 2's
address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node
three address this is the last address
which is also known as the exit node
this last node decrypts the encrypted
data and finally relays the request to
the Final Destination which can be
another device or a server end this
final address thinks the request came
from the exit node and grants access to
it the encryption process across
multiple computers repeats itself from
the exit node to the original user the
Tor Network obfuscates user IP addresses
from unwanted surveillance by keeping
the users request untraceable with
multiple servers touching the data it
makes the tracking very difficult for
both both isps and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the to browser was developed by
a nonprofit organization as a part of
the T project in 2008 and its first
public release was announced the to
browser is a browser Fork from the
popular Firefox that anonymizes your web
traffic using the to network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right
solution before the to browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers centor and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the T
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the T network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these do
onion websites which are only available
within the to network onion is a special
used top level domain which designates
an anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these onion links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activities and sales onion
Lings provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over tour
is slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users to browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced tore as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving TOS
anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the to browser
over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonimity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network doubting the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track track of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation
since the onion routing protocol
transfers data between multiple servers
of random countries the domains being
blocked become available when used via T
usage of these encryption messaging
platforms is easily enforced using the T
browser which otherwise would have been
a difficult task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference to is completely free and
open source all of the code for the
browser and the network can be audited
and has been cleared for security
concerns when it comes to VPN there are
many different brands which have
open-source clients but the same cannot
be said for their counterparts some have
partly open source while some have
completely locked up their code so that
they cannot be stolen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the sender it goes through all of
those delay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one to
one between the client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multi-layer
encryption of T is consistent if you use
to browser every single request passes
through the same layer of encryption and
follows the same routing protocol in the
case of a VPN different companies offer
different levels of encryption some have
multihop some prefer a single onetoone
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the Tor Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward when in in
the case of VPN many such vpns are
hosted by adware companies or are being
monitored by Central governments to note
the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding in of the T browser and
its routing let us take a look at how
the T browser can anonymize and protect
our internet
usage on opening up the T browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the T
Network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the tour browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the tour browser will be little delayed
and the speed will be hampered because
of the multiple layers of encryption
like we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the outof the Box settings that come
inbuilt with the tour browser similarly
we have an option of cleaning up the
data let's say if you want to refresh
your location and you want to use a
different ID for the next browsing
session if you just restart it once and
we can have to check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this time
as you can see we have Netherlands right
now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that
you cannot be tracked when in browsing
the internet like we discussed we have
some onion links that can only be used
on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the T
browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the T
Network this is kind of an alternative
Wikipedia website where we can find
articles to read and more information to
learn similarly we have another onion
link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is
specifically for dark web
members this operates over the Tor
Network and this is used by mostly
journalists and people who want to
anonymize their internet transactions
when it comes to dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall this would make
our properly easy accessible to
trespassers and robbers and place our
homes at Great risk right hence fencing
our property helps safeguarded and keeps
trespassers at Bay similarly imagine our
computers and networks without
protection this would increase the
probability of hackers infiltrating our
networks to overcome this challenge just
like how boundary walls protect our
houses a virtual wall helps Safeguard
and secure our devices from Intruders
and such a wall is known as a firewall
firewalls are security devices that
filter the incoming and outgoing traffic
within a private Network for example if
you were to visit your friend who lives
in a gated community you would First
Take permission from the security guard
the security guard would check with your
friend if you should be allowed to entry
or not if all is well your access is
granted on the other hand the security
guard would not Grant permission to a
trespasser looking to enter the same
premises here the entry access depends
solely on your friend the resident's
discretion the role of the security
guard in this case is similar to that of
a firewall the firewall works like a
gatekeeper at your computer's entry
point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports the firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
there Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network this
is when a firewall comes to your Rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet the firewall
rejects the malicious data packet and
thus protects your network from hackers
on the other hand traffic from trusted
websites is allowed access to your
network this way the firewall carries
out quick assessments to detect malware
and other suspicious activities thereby
protecting your network from being
susceptible to a Cyber attack firewalls
can either be Hardware or software
software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network linksy routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall
besides this there are other types of
firewalls designed based on their
traffic filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall if the incoming
Network traffic is not forur the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the the stateful inspection
firewall these types of firewalls not
only examine each Network packet but
also checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection such firewalls are also
referred to as Dynamic packet filtering
firewalls our next type of firewall is
called a proxy firewall this draws close
comparison to how you give proxy
attendance for a friend like how you
take the authority to represent your
friend the proxy firewall pretends to be
you and interacts with the internet
they come between you and the internet
and thereby prevents direct connections
this protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they're
also known as application Level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
inst institions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content it's the year
2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer after a
long gaming session Richard tries to
shut it down but finds some random text
file on the desktop that says Ransom
note the text file mentioned how a
hacking group had encrypted Richard's
game files and private documents and he
had to pay a ransom of $500 worth of
bitcoin in a specified Bitcoin address
Richard quickly checked his files only
to see them being encrypted and
unreadable this is the story of how the
Tesla Crypt ransomware spread in 2015
which affected thousands of Gamers
before releasing the master key used for
encrypting the files so what is
ransomware for Richard to be targeted by
such an attack he must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link both of them
can function as gateways for a
ransomware breach ransomware is a type
of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
the password ATT Tex file is available
to the victim explaining how to make the
ransom payment and unlock the files for
it just like Richard found the rans some
no text file on his desktop even after
the money has been paid there's no
guarantee that the hackers will send the
decryption key or unlock the files but
in certain sensitive situations victims
make the payment hoping for the best
having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
Richard an opportunity to learn more
about this and he began his research on
the topic the spread of ransomware
mostly starts with fishing attacks to
know more about fishing attacks click
the link in the button button above
users tend to click on unknown links
received via emails and chat
applications promising rewards of some
nature once clicked the ransomware files
installed on the system that encrypts
all the files or blocks access to
computer functions they can also be
spread via malware transmitted via
untrusted application installation or
even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access a
computer can be accessed remotely using
this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is the type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a log
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers once the files are
encrypted finding the decryption key is
impossible unless the ransomware variant
is old and the keys are already
available on the Internet scareware is
fake software that claims to have
detected a virus or other issue on your
computer and directs you to pay to
resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with popup
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security one must always have backups of
their data cloud storage for backup is
easy but a physical backup in a hard
drive is always recommended keeping the
system updated with the latest security
patches is always a good idea apart from
system updates one must always have
reputed antivirus software installed
many antivirus software like kasperski
and Bit Defender have anti someware
features that periodically check for
encryption of private documents when
browsing the internet a user must always
check for the lock SYM on the address
bar which signifies the presence of
https protocol for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there's a website no more
ransom. org it has a collection of
decryption tools for most well-known
ransomware packages it can also help
decrypt specific encrypted files if the
list of anti-ransomware tools TOS didn't
help the
victim malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for for two different types
of malware virus and
Trojan firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan Horse Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create back doors into our
system to allow the cybercriminal to
steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting install into our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan horse functioning for
troan horses entry way into our system
is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the tro
program gets installed and infect the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus and
rions let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is know
known as the boot sector virus this type
of virus damages the booting section of
the system by infecting the masterb
record which is also known as MBR this
damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
macro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system system
on a larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
troan the first type of troan is the
back door tro version they are designed
to create a back door in the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of our system to
the hacker this way the Cyber criminal
can steal our system data and may use it
for illegal activities next we have
cricos Rion they enter the system by
clicking the random popups which we come
across on the internet they ATT the user
to give their personal details for
different transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the
cybercriminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the Trojan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding virus is and troan
let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in a
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind his systems
problem option a macro virus option b
Ransom troen option C backd Door troan
give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and troan
in our
system to detect virus or troan activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data
and lastly we have frequent system
crashes due to virus infection which
damages the operating system for Trojan
we have frequent system crashes and
system also faces slow reaction time
then we have there are more random
popups from the system which may
indicate troan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the dextop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a Trojan program
next let's take a look at a famous Cyber
attack for virus and a Trojan
hor for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back to access
into our
systems next for the troan horse we have
the emot troan program which is a
specific spefically designed for
financial theft and for stealing Bank
related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or Trojan
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses can this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
budge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified website can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for prion we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any Trojan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against iion horses is a
good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and information effect
of viruses is more drastic in
comparision to the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non REM programs whereas fren horses are
remote accessed and lastly viruses have
the ability to replicate itself to harm
multiple files whereas Trojan does not
have the replication ability so let's
begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when they send a
query to the application will form a
malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database uh basically gets cracked or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called oasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this
on till this power is on I'm going to
show you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just look for
OAS broken web application project
download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net click on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for-profit
organization and uh periodically uh
releases the most top 10 risks that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so to to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine host it in
a vmw workstation or Oracle virtual box
and you can uh then try your skills on
it right so just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 71. 132
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 1921
132 and you'll see the oasp broken web
application project and there are lot of
training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth pH so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutally day over
here uh this gives you the uh o top 10
risks for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest
one so far uh but the difference between
2013 and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them uh the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1 one
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh attacks blind
SQL injection and then there is a tool
called SQL map which is available freely
on your Linux machines Ki Linux or parro
Linux whichever you want to use uh for
your practice targets and so on so forth
so if I just take you here for bypass
authentication and this is a regular
login page that an application may have
right you look at a username you look at
password you type that in and you log in
so let's say I don't know a password
here I'm just going to type in the
username test password is
pswd I try to log in and it shows me
that the account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work the I
did try type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote or 1 equals 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it give me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and uh we're going to look at
the basics of SQL injection so looking
at that small demo looking now let's
look at uh what types of SQL injections
are available so the first is inband SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within inband error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a Time based attack and the
third one is out of bound SQL injection
attack now what is inband SQL injection
attack inband is where we either
attempting the error based or the union
based what is error based uh we send a
query to the the database we craft a
query to the database and uh it
generates an error M message and it
dumps the error message right in front
of us on the screen that uh makes us
realize that there is a flaw and there
there is some information that is dumped
on the screen which we can then further
utilize to craft our further queries as
we go ahead whereas Union base is the it
is where we combine multiple statements
at the same time so if you look at the
URL earlier in the URL you would see a
large structure in that URL uh we can
try to add more two or more statements
within the URL itself to combine them
and then confuse the database into
executing both the statements together
and giving a data dump at the same time
right so what would a error-based uh SQL
injection look like if I go back to the
same database uh which is here right and
if you remember the username we gave a
single quote r 1 equals 1 space hyphen
hyen space we give it the condition
right so basically what it did was this
a single code is an operator that goes
to the database selects the default uh
table uh in the user tables in this
database column and then Compares it to
the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was one equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default uh user table
that was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the account doesn't exist comes
back again because the condition was
false and instead of comparing the user
account to the password it basically uh
compared the user account to the
condition so if I give it a single quote
or 1 equals 1 hyphen hyphen space
uh and log in you can see that this is a
correct condition and thus we are able
to log in now before we even go to that
extent if I just forget the condition
over here and I just give it a single
code the operator and I send this
operator to the database and I click on
login you will see that it generates an
error which is right on top and it tells
us the line the uh file where the error
happened and you can see it happened in
the MySQL handler. PHP file right and
then it give us the message you have an
error in your SQL syntax check the
manual that corresponds to your MySQL
server version for the right syntax to
use now why would a hacker want to do
this in the first place because there
are different types of databases so
there is a MySQL Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL
Oracle SQL IBM db2 all of these are
variations of the SQL database uh they
use the SQL language however every
database has its own Command right there
they have their own syntax they have
their own uh specific commands that are
utilized for the database so in this
scenario the hacker wants to identify
what database is being currently
utilized so they can craft those
particular queries so now with this
injection with just me sending the quote
and the error getting generated I now
come to know that we are using a MySQL
server and the version of that server is
5173 and uh the rest of the information
about uh where the handlers are located
and so on so forth right this gives the
information to the hacker of how they
want to proceed next what kind of
queries they want to create what kind of
syntax they want to utilize so error
based attack is where you generate these
kind of Errors uh and you get this
information the union base is where you
craft your queries within the URL or you
can try to combine multiple statements
within the input fields and try to
generate a response from that then we
come to Boolean based SQL injection uh
sends a SQL query to the database which
forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a false
result so basically if the input is
false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input B the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attacker will come to
know which input is true with this he
can then access the database of the
website so you're trying to figure out
by sending out multiple inputs uh and
then analyzing the output to see what
exactly uh which command exactly worked
what was the resultant output of that
command thus from this kind of an
information the hacker can infer their
next step forward then you have time
based SQL injections uh now there are
times when a database administrator and
app application administrator has done
some security configuration and does
have disabled vero's error messages now
what is a verbos error message the error
message that we saw right here is a
verbos error message that means that the
message gives out details the message
gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if they have sanitized these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot not
figure out what database is then what do
you do right for example if I just take
you to Simply
learn
and take you to a UR that is supposedly
not accessible you can see that it gives
a generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbose error that we saw
here so this gives us a detail error of
what went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this site where
there's some there's a lot of security
that goes in here so you can see that it
doesn't generate a error it just get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what does a hacker do so the hacker
then injects a Time
based uh query in the URL which allows
us to verify whether the command is
being executed or not so uh we put in a
time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is is possible however if
we inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitized them
so you have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed at a user
level with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there's an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how a website works right uh how
SQL works on a website now the website
is constructed of HTML hypertext markup
language uh which would include
javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheets for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when when the query
reaches the application the application
would then go ahead and generate the SQL
query uh at the client side you'll have
uh all these scripting languages coming
in uh on the front end uh that we can
utilize to craft queries and then send
them across at the server side you'll
have uh databases like Oracle MySQL Ms
SQL and so on so forth that will then
execute those queries right so just to
give you an example if I use a tool
called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so so let's continue with that so this
is a get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in and
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quote single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single quote right there so uh that's
where where we use that operator and
that's where the exception error
occurred so these are the kind of
queries that are structured by the
application and then taken on to the
database for execution when we type in
uh it is a HTTP get request with the
username and password within that query
uh that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a SQL query
sends it to the database and the
database responds with the appropriate
response so how do we prevent SQL
injection in the first place use
prepared statements and parameterized
queries uh these statements make sure
that the parameters passed into SQL
statements are treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
quote was an operator this shouldn't be
allowed to be utilized in the first
place right so here what we are doing
here is a secure way of running a SQL
query in the jdbc using a parameterized
statement Define which user we want to
find so there's a string the email comes
in connection to the database we are
going to figure out how the connection
is going to be passed how it is going to
be created construct the SQL statement
we want to run specifying the parameter
right so we Define how is it going to be
uh created what is going to be created
what can be passed to the database and
what should not be passed to the
database so that is one way of uh
utilizing prepared statements and
parameterized queries then we have
object relational mapping most
development uh teams prefer to use
object object relational mapping
Frameworks to the translation of SQL
results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping uh where we map
certain objects and allow that to be
executed and then escaping inputs it a
simple way to protect against most SQL
injection attacks many languages have
standard functions to achieve this right
so you need to be very careful while
using Escape characters in your code
base when a SQL statement is constructed
not all injection attacks rely on abuse
of quote characters so you need to know
what characters are being utilized uh in
the configuration that you have created
in the structure that you have created
in the code that you have created uh
which characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
feed out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of uh preventing SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or uh some other service for a single
sign on mechanism does uh you rely on a
third party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook Lo
logins right uh for the Layman you
normally go on to Facebook and you allow
if you're using a game right if you
start playing a game you're allowed to
log into the game using your Facebook
credentials or your Google credentials
now that is not just for ease of use but
the game user the developer has
outsourced the authentication mechanisms
to third party such as Facebook or
Google because they understand that that
authentication mechanism is as safe as
can be Facebook and Google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of Security
Experts and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is topnotch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the Sure Shot method of uh
mitigating or minimizing the uh threat
in the first place so at this point in
time you have realized that the
application has some vulnerabilities for
SQL injection and instead of recoding or
restructuring the application uh you
want to take the easier way out or the
cheaper way out so what you do is you uh
you install a web application firewall
and you configure the web application
firewall to identify malicious queries
and stop them uh at the firewall level
itself so they never reach the
application and thus the vulnerabilities
on the application don't get
executed buy better
software and keep on updating the
software so it's not necessary that once
you have a software and you install it
it's going to be safe for Life new
viabilities are discovered every day
every hour and it may so happen what is
secure today maybe completely insecure
tomorrow or the day after right so you
need to keep on upgrading the software
if there are no upgrades available and
the vity still exist you might want to
migrate to a better software and does uh
ensure that you don't get hacked right
always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to uh
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you uh getting and based on those
queries you want to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are
creating are not detrimental to the
health of the software that you have
Jane is relaxing at home when she
receives an email from a bank that asks
her to update her credit card pin in the
next 24 hours as a security measure
judging the severity of the message Jane
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one the
website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
inteled credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a truck Ed Source its
basic purpose is to trick the victim
into revealing sensitive information
like passwords and payment information
it's based on the word fishing which
works on the concept of baits if a
supposed victim catches the bait the
attack can go ahead which in our case
makes Jane the fish and the fishing
emails the bait if Jane never opened the
malicious link or was cautious about the
email authenticity an attack of this
nature would have been relatively
ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials a fishing attack
starts with a fraudulent message which
can be transmitted via email or chat
applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the isite website more
often than not the websites are designed
to look as authentic as possible once
the victims submit information using the
link be it a password or credit card
details the data is sent to the hacker
who designed the email and the fake
website giving him complete control over
the account whose password was just
provided often carried out in campaigns
where an identical fishing mail sent to
thousands of users the rate of success
is relatively low but never zero
between 2013 and 2015 corporate giants
like Facebook and Google were tricked
off of $100 million due to an extensive
fishing campaign where a known common
associate was impersonated by the
hackers apart from credit access some of
these campaigns Target the victim device
and install malware when clicked on the
malicious links which can later function
as a botn net or a target for ransomware
attacks there is no single formula for
there are multiple categories of fishing
attacks the issue with Jane where the
hacker stole her bank credentials falls
under the umbrella of deceptive fishing
a general email is sent out to thousands
of users in this category hoping some of
them fall prey to this scam spear
fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
draw drawback of deceptive fishing
techniques on the other hand a simple
screenshot of a Spotify playlist being
shared on social media indicates a
probable point of entry the hacker can
send counterfeit messages to the Target
user while implying the source of such
messages being Spotify tricking them
into sharing private information since
the hacker already knows the target uses
Spotify the chances of victims taking
the bait increased substantially for
more important targets like CEOs and
people with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10f which can be called
a case of wailing the hackers prepare
and wait for the right moment to launch
their fishing attack often to steal
industry secrets for rival companies or
sell them off at a higher price apart
from just emails farming focuses on fake
websites that resemble their original
counterparts as much as possible a
prevalent method is to use domain names
like Facebook with a single o or YouTube
with no e these are mistakes that people
make When Ty typing the full URL in the
browser leading them straight to a
counterfeit web page which can fool them
into submitting private data a few more
complex methods exist to drive people
onto fake websites like ARP spoofing and
DNS cash poisoning but they are rarely
carried out due to time and resource
constraints now that we know how fishing
attacks work let's look at ways to
prevent ourselves from becoming victims
while the implications of a fishing
attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relative ly
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that a redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or pop-up
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti-fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
email emails from legitimate ones the
best way to prevent fishing is browsing
the internet with care and being on
alert for malicious attempts at all
times start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xss is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
Attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious code infected web page or
online application the web page or
application serves as a vehicle for the
malicious script to be sent to the user
browser forums message boards and online
pages that enable comments are
vulnerable vehicles that are frequently
utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser browser must then
parse this user input in VB script
ActiveX Flash and even CSS cross-side
scripting attacks are conceivable they
are nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript o to the fact that JavaScript
is most important to most browser
experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different CLI side programming languages
as
well cross-side scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of it its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client site code adds
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike servers side languages such as
PHP JavaScript code runs inside your
browser and cannot impact the website
for other visitors it is sandboxed to
your own Navigator and can only perform
actions within your own browser window
while JavaScript is client site and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously the manner of attack can
range in a VAR variety of phase it can
be a single link which the user must
click on to initiate a JavaScript piece
of code it can be used to show any piece
of images that can be later used as a
front end for malicious code being
installed as malware but the majority of
Internet users unaware of how metadata
works or the ways in which web requests
are called the chances of victims
clicking on a redirecting links is far
too high cross-side scripting can occur
on the malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displ to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and sends it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting let us learn
more about how this kind of attack
works now first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately reses the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways depending on the type of
attack the malicious script may be
reflected on the victim's browser or
stored in the database and executed
every time when the user calls the
appropriate function the main reason for
this attack is in appropriate users's
input validation where the malicious
input can get into the output a
malicious user can enter a script which
will be injected onto the website's code
then the browser is not able to know if
the executed code is is malicious or not
therefore this malicious script is being
executed on the victim's browser or any
faked form if that is being displayed
for the users there are many ways to
trigger an xss attack for example the
execution could be triggered
automatically when the page loads or
when a user hovers over specific
elements of the page like hyperlinks
potential consequences of cross-site
scripting attacks include capturing
keystrokes of a user redirecting a user
to malicious websites running web
browser based exploits obtaining cookie
information of a user who is logged into
a website and many more in some cases
cross side scripting attack leads to
complete compromise of the victim's
account attackers can trick users into
entering credentials on a fake form
which can then provide all information
to the attacker with the basic working
of a cross-side scripting attack out of
the way let us go over the different
ways hackers can leverage vulnerable web
applications to gather information and
eventually breach those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
xss attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected accss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying faked
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious Cod
code and then spread the same URL via
email or social media a user who clicks
on this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser the script
is not stored in the web application and
malicious code is shown only to one user
the user that opens the link executes
the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this
because when a malicious script is being
saved on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored xss attack
can affect many users also as the script
is being stored on the web server it
will affect the website for a longer
time
in order to perform stored xss attack
the malicious scripts should be sent
through the vulnerable input form for
example can be a comment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted VI an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database the consequence of this might
be that the script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and if for example able to
gain access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently St in the web app the users
visiting the app after the information
retrieve the script the malicious code
then exploits the flaws in the web
application and the script and the
attack is visible on the server side or
to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
Dom attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order order to perform xss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious quote the
exploits flaws in the browser on the
user side and the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-side
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of fears one
can Safeguard against such attacks let's
go through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier excess
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent accesss attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
security suit or actic security
suit still manual testing is highly time
consuming and costly and therefore not
possible to be done for every iteration
of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using autom Ed security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected accss
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server site as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
you need to display user data restrict
the places where the user input might
appear any input displayed inside a
JavaScript tag or a URL shown on the
site is much more likely to be exploited
than the input that appears inside a
division or a span element inside the
HTML body protecting against accesss
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page rather than
trying to determine if the data is user
provided and could be compromised we
should always play it safe and Escape
data whether it is user provided or not
unfortunately because there are many
different rules for escaping you still
must choose the proper type of escaping
before settling on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of of escaping
to those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-side
scripting click checking and other code
injection attacks resulting from the
execution of malicious content in The
Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports this flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flaw the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third party if a browser does not
support HTTP only and a website attempts
to set an HTTP only cookie the HTTP only
flag will be ignored browser browser
thus creating a traditional script
accessible cookie as a result the cookie
becomes vulnerable to theft of
modification by any malicious script
next on our docket is a live
demonstration where we solve a set of
cross-site scripting problems starting
from the basic level to the topmost
level six
we're going to start at level
one in this web application it
demonstrates the common cause of cross
side scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if we interact with a
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge
let's see why the most primitive
injections work here right away let's do
a simple query and inspect the resulting
HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quat as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the P
load should be included in the URL to
perform successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily we just going to write the script
over
here and we going to press search
as you can see we have successfully
launched our first cross-site scripting
attack we can see an alertbox popup with
the necessary message and a similar
process can be used to steal browser
cookies and passwords albeit with
different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily xss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat applications
chat app conversations are stored in a
database and retrieved when a user wants
to see the conversation therefore if a
malicious user inject some JavaScript
code all visitors will be infected this
kind of cross-site scripting attack is
more powerful and it is more riskier
than reflected crossed scrip attacks and
that's why is known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I get
whatever I typed in simply appeared on
the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand why
we're going to toggle the code of here
and check the index.html
file important
part is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parser will not execute a
script tag when it proces htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
javascripts we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we loading
an image that doesn't exist which causes
to trigger an on error event in on error
event the it will execute our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see clicking on any
tab causes the tab number to be
displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute of JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use the existing IMG tag and change
the source to something that doesn't
exist hence forcing it to fall in to
execute an on error even which I will
pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of attack
in this application there is a timer on
the page that means whatever numbers we
put in the Box a countdown starts and
then when it finishes the application
alerts that the countdown is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without baking
the JavaScript code the parameter value
is directly added to the start timer
method without any filtering what we can
try to do here is to inject an alert
function to be executed inside the on
loan event along with the start timer
method we going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here
now when me press on create
timer and we have a popup with xss level
complete we can now move on to level
five in this web application this
application xss is different cuz this
challenge description says cross-side
scripting isn't just about correctly
escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cuz the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected
the href attribute value of next link is
confirm which is exactly the value of
the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
be used to inject a JavaScript code to
the href attribute of the next
link the following is the best way to do
it as soon as the user clicks on the
link script will be
triggered
we're going to press anything random and
now that we click next we can see the
xss level five that we had provided in
the URL as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level
six in this sub application it show some
of the external Java Script is
received if you analyze the URL you can
see that the script is loaded ready the
vulnerability lies within how the code
handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method another the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own Javascript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
applications URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not using https but
anything like that to bypass the regular
expression for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
used different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a Dos
attack these dos attacks are getting
more extreme with hackers getting easy
access to botet farms and compromised
devices as can be seen in the graph
three of the six strongest DDOS attacks
were launched in 2021 with the most
extreme attack occurring just last year
in 2020 lately cyber criminals have been
actively seeking out new services and
protocols for amplifying these DS
attacks active involvement with hacked
machines and Bot Nets allow further
penetration into the consumer space
allowing much more elaborate attack
campaigns apart from General users
multinational corporations have also had
their fair share of problems GitHub a
platform for software developers was the
target of a DS attack in 2018 widely
suspected to be conducted by Chinese
authorities this attack went on for
about 20 minutes after which the systems
were brought into a stable condition it
was the strongest DS attack to date at
the time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation DS attacks are still at
large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space hey
everyone this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on what is a DS
attack let's learn more about what is a
Dos
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a DS attack comes from
multiple systems generally these attacks
work by Drowning a system with requests
for data this could be sending a web
server so many requests to serve a page
that it crashes under the demand or it
could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control
center the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DS campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botn net and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how dos attack
work a DS attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
any time to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the bot net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests to
the Target thereby taking up all the
servers available bandwidth these can be
simple ping requests or complex attacks
like SN flooding and UDP flooding the
aim is to overwhelm them with more
traffic than the server or the network
can accommodate the goal is to render
the website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of Dos attack
a hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DS
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attacks focus on clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balancers and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the do
attacks these protocol attacks include
SN floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is poofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application layer attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in request per second these are
relatively sophisticated attacks that
Target the application and operating
system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network band up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking
a single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many ds attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a dets attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launched
the these DS attacks to hold
multinational corporations at Ransom the
resources are jammed and the only way to
clear the way is if the target company
agrees to pay a designated amount of
money to the hackers even a few minutes
of inactivity is detrimental to a
company's reputation in the global
market and it can cause a spiral effect
both in terms of market value and
product security index most of the time
a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a
while dto attacks have also found use in
the political segment certain activists
tend to use DS attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
Forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dilemas or even protest against
corporations let's take a look at a few
ways that companies and individuals can
protect themselves against redos
attacks the company can employ load
balance balancers and firewalls to help
protect the data from such attacks load
balancers reroute the traffic from one
server to another in a dor attack this
reduces the single point of failure and
adds resiliency to the server data a
firewall blocks unwanted traffic into a
system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a Dos attack in
action early detection of a DS attack go
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most important stage in
DOS mitigation is where you will look
for patterns of Dos attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DS criminals the cloud also has
greater band Android than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased STS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a Dos attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since DS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cash version of your content
in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of DS attacks on a system
for our demo we have a single device
that will attack a Target making it a
Dos attack of sorts once a botet is
ready
multiple devices can do the same and
eventually emulate a DS attack to do so
we will use the virtualization software
called VMware with an instance of parro
security operating system running for a
Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use wire shark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly this is Linux next slide
which is a target machine and this is
parro security which is used by the
hacker when trying to launch a DS attack
this is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if config
and here we can find the IP address now
remember we're launching this attack in
VMware now the both the instances of
parro security and Linux light are being
run on my local network so the address
that you can see here is
192.168
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hping
3 hping 3 is an open-source package
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
Yar is a network traffic analyzer you
can see whatever traffic that is passing
through the Linux light drro is being
displayed over here with the IP address
the source IP and the destination IP as
to where the request is being transfer
to once we have the Dos attack launched
you can see the results coming over here
from The Source IP which will be par
security Now to launch the hping 3
command we need to give PSE sudo access
to the console which is the root
AIS now we have the root axis for the
console the hping 3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it which are as
you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p8 and the IP address of the
target which is2 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the
parent security OS is the client and
Linux slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shock it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the uh requests coming
in from this IP which is 192 168 72.1
128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the requests keep on coming and we
can see the http
flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a
backend now remember Linux light is a
drro and such Linux dros are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system has
become completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from paret
security you can see whatever I pressed
nothing is responded even the wire shark
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux Destro is being used as
a backend for a server or a database can
not access anything else the system has
completely stopped responding and any
request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a Dos attack multiple systems such
as multiple par security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on Cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key Ing and eventually
finding the right one boot Force attacks
are simple and reliable there is no
prior knowledge needed about the victim
to start an attack most of the systems
falling prey to Brute Force attacks are
actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find the one that works due
to this repeated trial and error format
the strength of password matters a great
deal although with enough time and
resources Brute Force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts and encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a br Force attack can be time consuming
and difficult to perform if methods such
as data aisc are used and at times
downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only limit
ation is the number of characters for
example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8-digit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to get the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and arduous process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely due to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how bruteforce Works let's see if
we can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to Brute Force
attacks a hack laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload by FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plane format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of its standing Brute
post attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or password is
compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two Factor authentication
involves receiving a onetime password on
a trusted device before a new login is
allowed this OTB can be obtained either
via email SMS or specific 2fa
applications like Ai and Aegis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for 2i course
are much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of BR Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is
is a good way to prevent Brute Force
attempts many websites lock account for
30 minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with Wi-Fi taking the re in
every household it's natural that the
security will always be up for debate to
further test the security index and
understand brot Force attacks we will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen we first
need to capture a handshake file which
is a connection file from the Wi-Fi
router to a connecting device like a
mobile or a laptop the operating system
used for this process is parot security
a Linux distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called airgeddon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary Scripts that
are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the WL X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you you can see
above it's written it is in manage mode
right now so we're going to select
option two which is to put the interface
in monitor
mode and its name is now dou land zero
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter we have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example the station that you can see
56 26 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BSS ID is supposed to
be which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C we will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do Air
replayer
Attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a to cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the hand shap file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with airack plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have
generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 route so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
you go with only uppercase characters
and numeric
characters go with option
7even and it's going to start
decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this pass phrase over here
the first five or six digits are a it
starts working its way from the end from
the last character it keeps trying every
single combination you can see the last
the fourth character from the right side
the D it'll eventually turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the sing single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world cyber
attacks are frequently making headlines
in today's digital environment at any
time everyone who uses a computer could
would become a victim of a Cyber attack
there are various sorts of cyber attacks
ranging from fishing to password attacks
in this video we'll look into one such
attack that is known as botet but before
we begin if you love watching Tech
videos subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon never to miss an update to
begin with let's take a look at some of
the famous bot
attackes the first one is Mirai bot
which is a malicious program designed to
attack like vulnerable iot devices and
infect them to form a network of bots
that on command perform basic and medium
level denial of service attacks then we
have the zoos bot is specifically
designed for attacking the system for
Bank related information and data now
let's see what exactly a botnet
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
deves are known as Bots and the hijack
criminal known as bot harder remotely
controls them the Bots are used to
automate large scale attacks including
Data Theft server failure malware
propagation and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
botn net is let's dive deeper into
learning how bot net works during the
preparation of a botet network the first
step involves preparing the botet Army
after that the connection between the
bot net Army and the control server
established and the end the launching of
the tag is done by the B Herer let's
understand through a
illustration firstly we have a bot Herer
that initiates the attack according to
the control server commands the devices
that are infected with the Mal programs
and begins to attack the infected system
let's see some details regarding the
preparation of the bot net
Army the first step is known as the
prepping the botn net Army the first
step is creating a bot net is to infect
as many as connected devices as possible
this ensures that there are enough Bots
to carry out the attack this way it
creates Bots either by exploiting the
security gaps in the software or
websites or using fishing attacks they
are often deployed through Trojan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with the specific malware
that connects the device back to the
control bot server a bot Herer uses
command programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to admin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the B
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the B Herer issues a command to
the server it is then related to the
clients to perform malicious actions
then we have peer-to-peer model here
controlling the infected Bots involves a
peer-to-peer Network that relies on a
decentralized approach that is the BS
are topological interconnected and act
as both C and C servers that is the
server and the client to the hackers
adopt this approach to avoid detection
and single point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some counter measure against
bot net attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates after that we
should avoid clicking random popups or
links that we often see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti- spyware softwares and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack the internet is
an endless source of information and
data still in some cases we come across
some occurrences like cyber attacks
hacking force entry which may affect a
Time on the web hi everyone and welcome
to the simply La Channel today we will
discuss a topic that secretly records
our input data that is known as key
loggers but before we begin if you like
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data regularly
this is Jacob from the information
Department who is here to inform her
about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect a system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these lock files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key Ling program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
a
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers ARS is API based the most common
key logging case which uses apis to keep
a log of the type data and share it to
its origin for malicious purposes each
time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggest just they are based
key loggers that store the form data
that is if we often use web forms or
different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might might use it
to Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or sec security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different KES of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system
now to prevent our system from getting
infected by the key loging program let's
take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it
the system says the library is already
installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
key log textt file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given as
along with the time
stamp as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed is
pred
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Press
key
info a string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
when
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its cycle
that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function as
listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the log file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the botton
over here we see the key log text that
is the text file that we created let's
open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learned what exactly key loggers are
then we understood what different modes
are present how the system get infected
with the key loging problem then we
learned how to detect the problem into
our system then we learned what
different types of key loggers are
present on the net we also understood
how hackers use the recorded data from
the program and we also learn whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging problem or not and lastly ly we
understood what different points can be
taken to prevent the entering of the key
logging problem into the system and
before we begin if you someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security or to become an ethical hacker
by graduating from the best universities
or a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts and
try giving a short to Simply Larch
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schmith College of
computing the course link is mentioned
in the description box below that will
navigate you to the course page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered before we learn
about the Pegasus platform let us
understand what spyware is and it's
working spyware is a category of malware
that can gather information regarding a
user or a device straight from the host
machine it is mostly spread by malicious
links via email or chat applications
when a link with the malware is received
clicking on this link will activate the
spyware which allows the hacker to spy
on all our user information with some
spy systems even clicking on the link
isn't necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such spy system that is
making the rounds in the tech industry
today is Pegasus the Pegasus is a
spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform since Pegasus has
existed since as early as 2016 a highly
intricate spy program that can track
user location read text messages scan
through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillance for
any client that wishes to buy its
services initially the NSO group had
designed the software to be used against
terrorist factions of the world with
more and more encrypted communication
channels coming to the Forefront Pegasus
was designed to maintain control over
the data transmission that can be a
threat to National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on eventually the
primary clients became Sovereign Nations
spying on Public Information that is
supposed to stay private became really
easy with the service multiple devices
can be affect With the same spyer system
to create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages just
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus spyware targets such
occurrences byp passing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa
once the malicious links are clicked a
spyware package is downloaded and
installed on the device after the
spyware is successfully installed the
perpetrator who sent the payload to the
victim can monitor everything the user
does Pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes to the
device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex py software like Pegasus
can access the root files on our mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the Android
and iOS operating systems leaking such
private information is a massive blow to
the security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
talk web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action fature
you usually in spam emails the malicious
code is activated when the user clicks
the malware link a user doesn't need to
click the link in the new version of the
Pegasus and a few other spyware programs
once the message arrives in the inbox of
WhatsApp Gmail or any other chat
applications the spyware gets activated
and everything can be recorded and sent
back to the central server the primary
issue with being affected by spyware as
a victim is detection unlike Crypt
Miners and Trojans spying Services
usually usually do not demand many
system resources which makes them tough
to detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of Performance
Set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longetivity
by the users they do not check
meticulously for any other causes that
is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if we are
well aware aare of the causes of such
attacks how do users fall free to such
spyware programs a by installing
untested software B by clicking on the
third party links from email and
messages C by not keeping the apps and
phones updated or D all of the above let
us know your answers in the comment
section below and we will rev the
correct answer next week but what about
the unaffected devices the vulnerable
ones while we cannot be certain of our
security there are a few things we can
do to boost our device be it against
Pegasus or the next big spyer on the
market let's say we are safe now and we
have the time to take the necessary
steps to prevent a spy attack what are
the things we can go for our primary
goal must always be to keep our apps and
the operating system updated the latest
security patches the vulnerabilities
that the exploits Target are often
discovered by developers from Google and
apple which send the security patches
quickly this can be done for individual
apps as well well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen pre
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spy platform altogether
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of sideloading
Android applications using do APK files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into our
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spy is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false ve of democracy
altogether even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both rhetorically and
literally hey everyone today we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar wind attack the
global statistics indicate that upward
of 18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn the date is December 8th 2020
firei a global leader in company
specializing in cyber security released
a blog post that caught the attention of
the entire it Community a software known
as Orion which was developed by solar
Windon incorporat had become a victim of
a remote access Trojan or a rat the
breach was estimated to be running since
the spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the reveal sent the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for their platform in order
to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this breach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion Hing to
corporations and governments worldwide
Oran was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization's Network infrastructure
that bought the platform solar winds
claims they have more than 300,000
clients including US government agencies
and several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferbly services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for solar
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled the software
update was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers backd
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believ the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix this
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from from
Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar winds hack was it one a virus
a remote access Trojan a spyware or a
worm let us know your answers in the
comment section right away and we will
reveal the correct answer in a week
coming to possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also also a
strict no as is installing applications
from unverified sources the solar wind
hack is estimated to cost the parent
company nearly $18 million as
reparations making it one if not the
biggest hacks in cyberspace history as
recently as of July 2021 the hackers
accessed some us attorneys Microsoft 365
email accounts as part of the attack
criminal organizations like the FBI and
CIA are determined to figure out the
culprits responsible for this debacle
however the intricacy and the full
extent of the breach makes it a way more
complicated job than it looks on paper
the day is 26th February
2022 the world is hit with breaking news
that Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a activist
Collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade this was in response
to the Russian aggression on Ukrainian
territory in the hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and and highlight the damage to life
Meed out by the Kremlin in Ukraine they
also hacked 120,000 Russian troops
personal information and the Russian
Central Bank stealing 35,000 files this
served as a clear indicator of how cyber
War can changed the momentum in battle
something which people had never seen so
closely so what is cyber War a digital
assault or series of strikes or hacks
against a country is sometimes referred
to as a cyber War it has the AB ility to
cause havoc on government and civilian
infrastructure as well as disrupt
essential systems causing State harm and
even death in this day and age the
internet plays a bigger role than just
watching videos and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry Financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence cyber War has become the new
means to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves the
nation State attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's a in June 2021 Chinese hackers
targeted organizations like rizon to
secure remote access to their networks
stet was a computer worm designed to
attack Iran's nuclear facilities but
evolved and expanded to many other
industrial and energy producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague the applying rules and
sanctions based on digital assault is
even tougher making the field of cyber
warfare a lawless land not bound by any
rules or policies there are multiple
ways in which these attacks can be
carried out a major category of Cyber
attack is espionage Espionage entails
monitoring other countries to steal
critical Secrets this might include
compromising vulnerable computer systems
with bot Nets or spear fishing attempts
before extracting sensitive data in
cyber warfare the next weapon in cyber
war is sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with ties
to the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorists to steal
or destroy information by overwhelming a
website with bogus requests and forcing
it to handle them denial of service
attacks prohibit real users from
accessing it attacking parties May used
this form of assault to disrupt key
operations and systems and prevent
citizens military and security officials
and research organizations from
accessing sensitive websites but what
benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
globally without having to travel
thousands of miles as long as the
attacker and Target are connected to the
internet organizing and launching Cyber
Wars is Rel relatively less tedious Than
Physical Warfare people living in or
battling for a country are subjected to
propaganda attacks in an attempt to
manipulate their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world starting from
communication channels to Secure Storage
servers crippling a country's footprint
and control on the Internet is very
damaging but what are some of the ways
we as Citizens protect ourselves in the
case of a cyber war in the unfortunate
event that your country involved in
Warfare be sure to fact check every
piece of information and follow only
trusted sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of War
drastically it is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being being attacked
having devices segregated in a network
goes a long way in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses and if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security
that is by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who alits
to switch careers with cyber security by
learning from the experts and try giving
a short to Simply Lars postgraduate
program in cyber security with modules
from the MIT schwarzman College of
Engineering and the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered during data
transmission there are various external
factors which can affect the
transmission of data over a network
channel to prevent such cases from
happening we use Internet Protocol
security which we'll be discussing in
the session on IP explain hi guys and
welcome to yet testing video by simply
learn but before we begin if you are
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to miss an
update from us now without further Ado
let's take a look at the agenda for the
session to begin with we will look into
what is IP SEC continuing with why do we
use IPC in our
Network followed by components of
IPC modes of Ip security as for the last
topic we will look into working steps
involved in IP security let's begin with
the first heading that is what is
IPC IPC Internet Protocol security is
defined as a set of framework and
protocol to ensure data transmission
over a network
channel this protocol was initially
defined of two main protocols for data
security over a network channel which
were authentication header which is
responsible for data integrity and
anti-replay
services and the second protocol is
encapsulating security payload in short
ESP which includes data encryption and
data
authentication now let's move on to the
next setting that is why do we use ipsc
in network
IP SEC is used to secure sensitive data
and information such as company data
clinical data Bank data and various
sensitive information regarding an
institution which are used during data
transmission over a network
channel the use of vpns that are virtual
private networks and apply PPC protocols
to encrypt the data for inin
transmission
let's continue with why do we use IPC
Services IPC is also used to encrypt
data for application layer in the OSI
model and provide security for sharing
data over Network routers and data
authentication let's take a look at the
working of ipx
services to begin with we have two
different system system one and system 2
which will establish a network channel
and then the encryption of data will
takes place when one host will share the
data to the second host during this ipx
services will secure the data that is to
be transferred over the network channel
by applying router encryption and
authentication now let's move on to the
next topic that is components of
IPC the ipx services comprises of
multiple protocols that ensure the data
transmission over the network channel
the first one is encapsulating security
payload protocol in short
ESP this protocol of Ip security
provides data encryption and
authentication
services and it also authenticates and
encrypt the data packet in the
transmission
Channel moving on we have authentication
header in short
ah similar to ESP the authentication
header also provides all the security
services but it does not encrypt the
data it also protects the IP packet and
adds additional headers to the packet
header the modified IP datagram looks
this way where the IP components are
included at the second position the
seventh position and the sixth position
along with the authentication of data
services over the network
channel moving on we have Internet key
exchange ik
ke this protocol provides provides
protection for Content data and also
changes the attribute of the original
data to be shared by implementing sha
and md5
algorithms they also check the message
for authentication and then only is
forwarded to the receiver side for
example this is the original data packet
we are used to with IP head UPA TCP UDP
and data whereas this is the modified IP
site data packet where ESP header is
added between IP header and the TCP
protocol now let's move on to the next
heading that is modes of Ip
SEC there are basically two types of Ip
modes available for data transmission
over the network channel where the first
one is tunnel mode this mode of
transmission is used to secure gateway
to Gateway
data it is applied when the final
destination of the data is to be
connected to a sender site through a
connection Gateway over the Internet for
example we have two host host a and host
B through the host a we are sending a
message to host B which will pass
through a Gateway at host a point and it
passes through a gateway to host B
then this is a basic format for Gateway
to Gateway data
transmission and the given IP datagram
format is used for tunnel mode now let's
move on to the second mode of Ip SE that
is transport mode this mode of IPC is
used to protect protocols like TCP or
UDP and is used to ensure end to endend
communication unlike tunnel mode the
transport mode data at authentication
header and encapsulating security
payload for security purpose in the IP
header this this is the modified IP
datagram for transport mode the point to
be noted is the IP SE header is always
added between IP header and TCP
header now let's move on to the last
heading for the session on IP SE that is
the working steps involved in IP
Security in general there are five steps
involved in the working of Ip sec to
ensure data transmission over a network
channel the first step is host
recognition in the first step the host
system will check if the packet is to be
transmitted or Not by automatically
triggering the security policy for the
data which is implemented by the sender
side for proper
encryption then the second step is known
as ik Phase 1 in this step the two host
devices the sender and the receiver site
will authenticate each other to
establish a secure network channel
it is comprised of two modes the main
mode this provides much better security
with a proper time
limit and the second mode known as
aggressive mode as the name suggests it
establishes the IP protocol much faster
in comparison to main mode let's move on
to the third step which is ik Phase 2
after the second step the host decide
the type of cryptography algorithm to to
apply over the session in the network
channel and the secret key for the
algorithm to be used to encrypt the data
for
transmission then we have IP SEC
transmission this step involves the
actual transfer of data over the network
channel using various protocols used in
ipx security which are implemented under
the tunnel
condition and the last step is IPC
termination after the completion of data
exchange or session time out the IP SEC
tunnel is terminated and the security
key established is discarded by both the
host system network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand this aims at
securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network the every company or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses so recently network
security has become the central topic of
cyber security with many organizations
involving applications from people with
skills in this area it is crucial for
both personal and professional networks
most houses with highspeed internet have
one or more wireless routers which can
be vulnerable to attacks if they're not
adequately
secured data loss theft and sabotage
risk may be decreased with the usage of
a strong network security system the
workstations are protected from
hazardous F thanks to network security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network by dividing information into
various sections encrypting these
portions and transferring them over
separate Pathways network security
infrastructure offers multiple levels of
protection to th man in the medal
attacks preventing situations like
eavesdropping among other harmful
attacks it is becoming increasingly
difficult in today's hyperconnected
environment as more corporate
applications migrate to both public and
private clocks additionally modern
applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team Network traffic
and infrastructure must be protected in
these cases since assaults on businesses
are increasing every single day we now
understood the basics of network
security but we need to understand how
network security works in the next
section in slightly more
detail network security revolves around
two processes authentication and
authorization
the first process which is
authentication is similar to access
cards which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building in other
words authentication checks and verifies
that it is indeed the user belonging to
the network who is trying to access or
enter it thereby preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example Network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network based on the network users role
the process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network
architecture is complex and faces a
threat environment that is always
changing and attackers that are always
trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities these fun abilities can
exist in many areas including devices
data applications users and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
down times can cause widespread
disruption and massive damage to an
organization's bottom line and
reputation it is essential that these
protection measures are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and its working
let's cover to the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenant of
network security is the layering of
protection for massive networks and
store data that ensure the acceptance of
rules and
regulations as a whole there are three
types the first of which is physical
security the next being Technical and
the third being
administrative let's look into physical
security first this is the most basic
level that includes protecting data and
network to unauthorized Personnel from
acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network this
include external peripheral and routers
that might be used for cable connections
the same can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems physical
security is critical especially for
small businesses that do not have many
resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized ized users the other is a
defense against malevolent
actions the last category is
Administrative this level of network
security protects user Behavior like how
the permission has been granted and how
the authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks this
level also suggests necessary amendments
that have to be done to the
infrastructure I think that's all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security in which our next topic we're
going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with the
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employees lighter symmetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app player security can
lead to Performance and stability issues
data theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denal
of service attacks or DDOS attacks HTTP
floods hql injections cross-site
scripting Etc most organizations have an
arsenal of application layer security
protections to combat these and more
such as web application firewalls secure
web gway services Etc now that we have
the theory behind network security has
been covered in detail let us go through
some of the tools that can be used to
enforce these network security
policies the first first two to be
covered in the section is a firewall a
firewall is a type of network security
device that keeps track of incoming and
outgoing Network traffic and it decides
which traffic to allow or deny in
accordance to a set of security rules
for more than 25 years firewalls have
served as Network Security's first line
of defense they provide a barrier
between trustworthy internal protected
and regulated networks from Shady
external networks like the internet at
some points the next tool which can be
used to bolster network security is a
virtual private Network or VPN for short
it's an encrypted connection between a
device and a network via the Internet
the enip connection AIDS the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to e stop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of
VPN technology is common in both
corporate and personal networks next we
cover the importance of intrusion
prision systems in Networks security or
IPS
Frameworks an intrusion prevention
system is a network security tool that
continually scans the network for
harmful activity and response to it when
it does occur by reporting blocking or
discarding it it can be either Hardware
or software it's more sophisticated than
an intution detection system or an IDs
framework which can just warn an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an IPS it actually takes against that
activity the next tool in this section
and the final one are going to be
behavioral analytics behavioral
analytics focus more on the statistics
that are being carried over and stored
through months and years of usage on
some kind of similar pattern is noted
whe the it administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further
enhanced now that we have covered all
that we need to know about network
security the necessary tools it's
different types Etc let's go to the
benefits of network security as a
whole the first which is protection
against external threats the objective
for cyber assaults can be as varied as
the Defenders themselves although
they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security posture
that considers routine software updates
May assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry
points the next benefit is protection
against internal threats the human
aspect continues to be the cyber
security systems weakest link Insider
risk can originate from current or
former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive
disasters the third benefit is increased
productivity it nearly impossible for
employees to function when networks and
personal devices are slow to a craw by
viruses and other cyber attacks during
the operation of website and for the
company to run May significantly
minimize violations and the amount of
downtime required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious Lings
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit is brand trust
and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development
customers today place a premium on
maintaining brand loyalty through a
strong cyber security stance since this
is the fastest way to get other
businesses back get referrals and sell
more tickets overall additionally it
helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities for potential future
endeavors and development with the rise
in censorship and general fear over
privacy loss consumer security is at an
all-time high risk technology has made
our life so much easier while putting up
a decent Target on our personal
information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos Sub
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell iccon to never miss an update from
Simply learn so here's a story to help
you understand cryptography meet an Anne
wanted to look for a decent discount on
the latest iPhone she started searching
on the internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50% discount on
the first purchase once Anne submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after devastated and
quickly realized she had failed to
notice that the website was a HTTP web
page instead of an https one the payment
information submitted was not encrypted
and it was visible to anyone keeping an
eye including the website owner and
hackers had she used a reputed website
which has encrypted transactions and
employees cryptography a iPhone
Enthusiast could have avoided this
particular incident this is why it's
never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today we take a
look into what cryptography is and how
it works we learn where cryptography is
being used in our daily lives and how we
are benefiting from it then we will
understand the different types of
cryptography and their respective uses
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
description in action let's Now
understand what cryptography
is cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties encryption is a primary route
for employing cryptography by adding
certain algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography for example when simply
learn is jumbled up or changed in any
format not many people can guess the
original word by looking at the
encrypted text the only ones who can are
the people who know how to decrypt the
coded word thereby reversing the process
of
encryption any data pre- encryption is
called plain text or clear text to
encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers they
are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
cipher text and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content wonder what else we would lose
if not for
cryptography any website where you have
an account can read your passwords
important emails can be intercepted and
their contents can be read without
encryption during the transit more than
65 billion messages are sent on WhatsApp
every day all of which are secured
thanks to endtoend encryption there is a
huge Market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description of course there is no
single solution to a problem as diverse
as explain there are three varant of how
cryptography works and is in practice
they are symmetric encryption
asymmetric
encryption and hashing let's find out
how much we have understood until now do
you remember the difference between a
cipher and Cipher text leave your answ
in the comments and before we proceed if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up before
moving ahead let's look at symmetric
encryption
first symmetric encryption uses a single
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data it is comparatively
less secure than asymmetric encryption
but much faster it is a compromise that
has to be embraced in order to deliver
data as fast as possible without living
information completely vulnerable this
type of encryption is used when data
rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times Cesar Cipher and
igma machine are both symmetric
encryption examples that we will look
into further for example if Alice wants
to send a message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message symmetric
encryption uses one of the two types of
ciphers stream ciphers and block ciphers
block ciphers break break the plane text
into blocks of fixed size and use the
key to convert it into Cipher text
stream ciphers convert the plane text
into Cipher text one bit at a time
instead of resorting to breaking them up
into bigger chunks in today's world the
most widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is AES 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard which has a
key size of 256bit with 128bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available other
primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the dees the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it
unreadable asymmetric encryption on the
other hand has a double whammy at its
disposal there are two different keys at
play here a public key and a private key
key the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is done with a
public key and the decryption is done
with a private key that no one except
Bob has access to both the keys are
necessary to read the full
message there is also a reverse scenario
where we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decp the message this
mechanism also proves that the sender is
authenticated and there is no problem
with the origin of the
information RSA encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its Founders
reest Shamir and Edelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the Diffy helpman key exchange
which relies on a oneway function and is
much tougher to break into the third
variant of cryptography is termed as
hashing hashing is a process of
scrambling a piece of data beyond
recognition it gives an output of fixed
size which is known as the hash value of
the original data or just hash in
general the calculations that do the job
of messing up the data collection from
the hash function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in Blain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered password's
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentic indication since the function
will always return the same value for
the same
input cryptography has been in practice
for centuries Julius Caesar used a
substitution shift to move alphabets a
certain number of spaces beyond their
place in the alphabet table a spy can't
decipher the original message at first
glance for example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use the substitution
shift of plus two a becomes c b becomes
D and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus
three becomes D ww dfn this Cipher has
been appropriately named the Caesar
Cipher which is one of the most widely
used
algorithms the Enigma is probably the
most famous cryptographic Cipher device
used in ancient history it was used by
the Nazi German armies in the world wars
they were used to protect confidential
political military and administrative
information and it consisted of three or
more rotors that scrambled the original
message depending on the machine State
at that time the decryption is similar
but it needs both machines to stay in
the same state before passing the cyer
text so that we received the same plane
text message let's take a look at how
our data is protected while we browse
the internet thanks to cryptography here
we have a webbased tool that will help
us understand the process of RSA
encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the cipher text in
order to get the plain text back as we
already know RSA encryption algorithm
falls under the umbrella of asymmetry
key
cryptography that basically implies that
we have two keys at play here a public
key and a private
key typically the public key is used by
the sender to encryp the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message the there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well in RSA we have the choice of key
size we can select any key from a
512-bit to 1024-bit all the way up to a
496 bit key the longer the key length
the more complex the encryption process
becomes and thereby strengthening the
cipher text although with added security
more complex functions take longer to
perform the same operations on similar
size of data we have to keep balance
between both speed and strength because
the strongest encryption algorithms are
of no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here now
we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on past phases the tool we are
using right now generates the sudo
random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always is the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other they cannot be substituted with
any other key and in order to encrypt
the original message or decrypt the
cipher text this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself in this
scenario let's try and encrypt a word
simply
learn we have to select if the key being
used for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process C
of scrambling the information since we
are using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over
here the cipher we are using right now
is plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well once we click on
encrypt we can see the cipher text being
generated over here
the sudo random generating functions are
created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different Cipher
text this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption
part the receiver gets this Cipher text
from the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always be the same used
during the encryption
process once we click decrypt you can
see the original plain text we had
decided to encrypt this sums up the
entire process of RSA encryption and
decryption now some people use it the
other way around we also have the the
option of using the private key to
encrypt information and the public key
to decrypt it this is done mostly to
validate the origin of the message since
the keys only work in pairs if a
different private key is used to encrypt
the message the public key cannot
decrypt it conversely if the public key
is able to decrypt the message it must
have been encrypted with the right
private key and hence the rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key and use that to encrypt the plain
text and select the same in this
checkbox as well you can see we have
generated a completely new Cipher text
this Cipher text will be send to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for
decryption let's select the correct
checkbox and decrypt and we still get
the same
output now let's take a look at
practical example of encryption in the
real
world we all use the internet on a daily
basis and many are aware of the
implications of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at wikkipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
H stands for secured let's take a look
at how it secures our
data wi shck is the world's formost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is leaving a machine and to understand
how vulnerable it is
is since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to
[Music]
Wikipedia let's search for something
that we can navigate the website
with okay once we get into it a little
you can see some of the requests being
populated over
here let's take a look at the specific
request these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice
versa as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way to put this in
perspective let's take a look at another
website which is a HTTP web
page this has no encryption enabled from
the server end which makes it vulnerable
to attacks there is a login form here
which needs legitimate user credentials
in order to Grant access let's enter a
random pair of
credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data
transfer unsurprisingly we weren't able
to get into the platform instead we can
see the data
packets let's apply a similar filter
that will help us understand what
request this website is
sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here see whatever username and
password that we are entering we can
easily see it with the wire shark now we
used a dummy pair of credentials if we
select the right data packet we can find
our correct credentials if any website
had asked for a payment in information
or a legitimate credentials it would
have been really easy to get a hold of
these to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online there are two types of
encryption in
cryptography symmetric key cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography both of
these categories have their pros and
cons and differ only by the
implementation today we are going to
focus exclusively on symmetry key
cryptography let us have a look at its
applications in order to understand its
importance
better this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving onto
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial symmetric cryptography
helps in detecting bank fraud and boost
the security index of these payment
gateways in
general they are also helpful in
protecting data that is not in transit
and rests on servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no delay while
browsing the internet we need symmetric
encryption to browse secure https
websites so that we get an allaround
protection it plays a significant role
in verifying website server authenticity
exchanging the necessary encryption Keys
required and generating a session using
those keys to ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure HTTP website
format so let us understand how
symmetric key cryptography works first
before moving on to the specific
specific
algorithms symmetric key cryptography
relies on a single key for the
encryption and decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the pl
text into Cipher text and vice versa as
you can see in the image the key used
for encryption is the same key needed
for decrypting the message at the other
end the secret key shouldn't be sent
along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the defy Helman
key exchange protocol for
example for example if Paul wants to
send a simple message to Jane they need
to have a single encryption key that
both of them must give secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious
actors it can be generated by either one
of them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into Cipher text using a
specific substitution Cipher by Paul in
that case Jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to deip the cipher
text once it reaches her irrespective of
the scenario where someone manages to
grab the cipher text mid transit to try
and read the message not having the
secret key renders everyone helpless
looking to snop in the symmetric key
algorithms like the data encryption
standard have been in use since the
1970s while the popular ones like the
EES have become the indust standard
today with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of Paramount importance to keep
it secret on All
Occasions the side effect of having a
single key for the encryption and
decryption is it becomes a single point
of failure anyone who gets their hand on
it can read all the encrypted messages
and do so mainly without the knowledge
of the sender and the receiver so it is
the priority to keep the encryption and
decryption key private at all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin if the sender somehow
transmits the secret key along with the
cipher text anyone can intercept the
package and access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's Integrity is is
writing on the promise that the users
can keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public provided we manage to keep the
key secret we still have to choose what
kind of ciphers we want to use to
encrypt this information in symmetri key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a
look streams ciphers are the algorithms
that encryp basic information one bit at
a time it can change depending on the
algorithm being used but usually it
relies on a single bit or bite to do the
encryption this is the relatively
quicker alternative considering the
algorithm doesn't have to deal with
blocks of data at a single time every
piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream ciphers
each binary digit is encrypted one after
the other the most popular ones are the
rc4 salsa and Panama the binary data is
passed through an encryption key which
is a randomly generated bitstream upon
passing it through we receive the cipher
text that can be transferred to the
receiver without fear of man in the
middle attacks the binary data can be
passed through an algorithmic function
it can have either X or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or heximal format to give our final
Cipher
text on the other hand block ciphers
dissect the raw information into chunks
of data of fixed size the size of these
blocks depend on the exact Cipher being
used a 128bit block Cipher will break
the plain text into blocks of 128bit
each and encrypt those blocks instead of
a single digit once these blocks are
encrypted individually they are chained
together to form a final Cipher
text block ciphers are much slower but
they are more tamper proof and are used
in some of the most widely used
algorithms employed
today just like stream ciphers the
original Cipher text is converted into
binary format before beginning the
process once the conversion is complete
the blocks are passed through the
encryption algorithm along with the
encryption key
this would provide us with the encrypted
blocks of binary
data once these blocks are combined we
get a final binary
string this string is then converted
into heximal format to get our Cipher
text today the most popular symmetric
key algorithms like AES Dees and 3des
are all block Cipher methodology
subsets with so many factors coming into
play there are quite a few things
symmetric cryptography excels at while
falling short in some
other symmetric cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography there is
only one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption similarly the performance of
symmetric encryption is much more
efficient under similar computational
limitations fewer calculations help in
better memory management for the host
system bulk amounts of data that need to
be encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetry key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication Channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday Communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt vast amounts of data with very
less
overhead Dees algorithm stands for data
encryption
standard it is a symmetric key Cipher
that is used to encrypt and recpt
information in a block byblock manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they're later chained together to form
our final Cipher text which is then sent
to a receiver DS takes the original
unaltered piece of data called the plain
text in a 64-bit block and it is
converted into an encrypted text that is
called the cipher text it uses 48 bit
Keys during the encryption process and
follows a specific structure called the
fistal Cipher structure during the
entire process it is a symmetric key
algorithm which means DS can reuse the
key is used in the encryption format to
decrypt the cipher text back to the
original plain text once the 64-bit
blocks are encrypted they can be
combined together before being
transmitted let's take a look at the
origin and the reason thees was
founded DS is based on a fistal block
Cipher called Lucifer developed in 1971
by IBM cryptography researcher host fist
Dees uses 16 rounds of this fist
structure using a different key for each
round it also utilizes a random function
with two inputs and provides a single
output variable DS becames the
organization's approved encryption
standard in November 1976 and was later
reaffirmed as a standard in 1983 1988
and finally in 1999 but eventually DS
was cracked and it was no longer
considered a secure solution for all
official roots of
communication consequently triple Ds was
developed triple s is a symmetry key
block Cipher that uses a double Ds
Cipher encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple Ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using DS for encrypting messages in
order to search for a better alternative
a public wide competition was was
organized and helped cryptographers
develop their own algorithm as a
proposal for the next global standard
this is where the rile algorithm came
into play and was later credited to be
the next Advanced encryption standard
for a long time DS was the standard for
data encryption for data security its
rule ended in 2002 when finally the
advanced encryption standard replaced
Dees as an acceptable standard following
a public competition for a
place to to understand the structure of
a fistal Cipher we can use the following
image as a reference the block being
encrypted is divided into two parts one
of which is being passed onto the
function while the other part is exor
with the function's output the function
also uses the encryption key that
differs for each individual round this
keeps going on until the last step until
where the right hand side and the left
hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final Cipher text for the
decryption process the entire procedure
is reversed starting from the order of
the keys to the block sorting if the
entire process is repeated in a reverse
order we will eventually get back our
plane text and this Simplicity helps the
speed overall This was later detrimental
to the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was
compromised a fistal block Cipher is a
structure used to derive many symmetric
block ciphers such as Dees which as we
have discussed in our previous comment
pistal Cipher proposed a structure that
implements substitution and permutation
alternately so that we can obtain Cipher
text from the plain text and vice versa
this helps in reducing the redundancy of
the program and increases the complexity
to combat Brute Force
attacks the fistel cipher is actually
based on the Shannon structure that was
proposed in 1945 the fistel cipher is
the structure suggested by horse ftil
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers
the Shannon structure highlights the
implementation of alternate confusion
and diffusion and like we already
discussed the fistal Cipher structure
can be completely reversed depending on
the data however we must consider the
fact that to decrypt the information by
reversing the fal structure we will need
the exact polinomial functions and the
key
orders to understand how the blocks are
being calculated we take a plane test
which is of 64-bit and that is later
divided into two equal halves of 32 bit
each in this the right half is
immediately transferred to the next
round to become the new Left half of the
second row the right hand is again
passed off to a function which uses an
encryption key that is unique to each
round in the fistal Cipher whatever the
function gives off as an output it is
passed on as an XR input with the left
half of the initial plane text the next
output will become the right half of the
second round for the plain text this
entire process constitutes of a single
round in the fistal
Cipher taking into account what happens
in a polinomial
function we take one half of the block
and pass it through an expansion box the
work of the expansion box is to increase
the size of the half from 32bit to 48
bit text this is done to make the text
compatible to a 48 bit Keys we have
generated
beforehand once we pass it through the
EXO function we get a 48-bit text as an
output now remember a half should be of
32-bit so this 48-bit output is then
later passed on to a substitution box
this substitution box reduces its size
from 48 bit to 32bit Output which is
then later exort with the first half of
the plain
text a block Cipher is considered the
safest if the size of the block is large
but large block SI sizes can also slow
down encryption speed and the decryption
speed generally the size is
64-bit sometimes modern block cers like
AES have a 128bit block size as
well the security of the block ciper
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process earlier 64-bit
keys were considered sufficient modern
ciphers need to use 128bit Keys due to
the increasing complexity of today's
computational
standards the increasing number of
rounds also increase the security of the
block Cipher similarly they're inversely
proportional to the speed of
encryption a highly complex round
function enhances the security of the
block Cipher Al we must maintain a
balance between the speed and
security the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed there is
no use of an algorithm it if it cannot
be implemented in a real life framework
that can help organizations to encrypt
or decrypt the data in a timely manner
now that we understand the basics of
fistal ciphers we can take a look at how
Dees manages to run through 16 rounds of
the structure and provide the cipher
text at the end now that we understand
the basics of Fel ciphers we can take a
look at how DS manages to run through 16
rounds of this structure and provide a
cipher text in simple terms DS takes the
64-bit plain text and converts it into a
64-bit Cipher text and since we are
talking about asymmetric algorithms the
same key is being used when it is
decrypting the data as
well we first take a 64-bit key plane
text and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the initial
permutation function has the job of
dividing the block into two different
parts so that we can perform fistal cyph
structures on
it there are multiple rounds being
procured in in the DS algorithm namely
16 rounds of FAL Cipher structure each
of these rounds will need keys initially
we take a 56-bit cipher key but it is a
single key we pass it onto a round key
generators which generates 16 different
keys for each single round that the
fistal Cipher is being run these keys
are passed on to the rounds as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bit ke is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation Bongs in the polinomial
functions of the faal
ciphers when passing through all these
rounds we reach round 16 where the final
key is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the rounds are
swapped and we get a final Cipher text
this is the entire process of Dees with
16 rounds of FAL ciphers encompassed in
it to decrypt a cipher text back to the
plane text we just have to reverse the
process we did in the DS algorithm and
reverse the key order along with the
functions this kind of Simplicity is
what gave Dees the bonus when it comes
to speed but eventually it was
detrimental to the overall efficiency of
the program when it comes to security
factors DS have five different modes of
operation to choose from this one of
those is electronic codebook each 64-bit
block is encrypted and decrypted
independently in the electronic code
book format we also have Cipher block
chaining or the CBC method here each
64-bit block depends on the previous one
and all of them use an initialization
Vector we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding Cipher
text becomes the input for the
encryption algorithm it produces a sud a
random output which in turn is exer with
the Plaine
text there is an output feedback method
as well which is the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding
DS a counter method has a different way
of approach where each PL text block is
exor with an encrypted counter the
counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by cryptographers
worldwide let's take a look at the
future of
DS the dominance of Dees ended in 2002
when the advanced encryption standard
replaced the es encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done
following a public competition to find a
replacement nist officially withdrew the
global acceptance standard in May 2005
although triple Ds has approved for some
sensitive government information through
2030 n also had to change the DS
algorithm because its Kei length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the key
and DS found itself a victim of ongoing
technology iCal advances in Computing we
have received a point where 56-bit was
no longer a challenge to the computers
of cracking note that because DS is no
longer the nist federal standard it does
not mean that it is no longer in use
triple Ds is still used today and is
still considered a legacy encryption
algorithm to get a better understanding
of how these keys and Cipher Tex look
like we can use an online tool for our
benefit as we already know to encrypt
any kind of data a key is mandatory this
key can be generated using mathematical
functions or computerized key generation
program such as this website offers it
can be based on any piece of text let's
say the word is simply
[Music]
learn in our
example once the key is settled we
provide the plain text or the clear text
that needs to be encrypted using the
aforementioned key suppose a sentence
for this example is this is my first
message
we have satisfied two prerequisites the
message and the key another variable
that goes into play is the mode of
operation we have already learned about
five different modes of operation while
we can see some other options here as
well let us go with the CBC variant
which basically means the cipher block
chaining method one of cbc's key
characteristics is that it uses a
chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of Cipher text to
depend all on the preceding Cipher text
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjacent blocks as well a
single bit error in a cipher text block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks rearrangement of the
order of these for example can cause the
decryption process to get
corrupted regarding the manner of
displaying binary information we have
two options here we can either go with
base 64 or the heximal format
let's go with the base 64 right
now as you can see the cipher text is
readily available b64 is a little more
efficient than hex so we will be getting
a smaller Cipher text when it comes to
b64 albeit the size of both the formats
will be the same the hex has a longer
Cipher text since B 64 takes four
characters for every three bytes while
hex will take two characters for each
bite hence B 64 turns out to be more
efficient now to decut the cipher text
we go by the same format we choose base
64 we copy the cipher text onto a
decryption tool and we have to make sure
that the key we are using is exactly the
same we choose similar mode of
operation and we choose the correct
encoding format as well which is base 64
in this
case as you can see the decryption is
complete and we get a plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt
anything unfortunately DS has become
rather easy to crack even without the
help of a key the advanced encryption
standard is still on top when it comes
to symmetric encryption security and
will likely stay there for a
while eventually with so much computing
power growth the need for a stronger
algorithm was necessary to safeguard
personal data as solid as Dees was the
computers of today could easily break
the encryption with repeated attempts
there rendering the data security
helpless to counter this dilemma a new
standard was introduced which was termed
as the advanced encryption standard or
the AES
algorithm let's learn what is Advanced
encryption
standard the AES algorithm also known as
the reile algorithm is a symmetric block
cite Cipher with a block size of 128
bits it is converted into Cipher text
using keys of 128 192 or 256 bits it is
implemented in software and Hardware
throughout the world to encrypt
sensitive data the National Institute of
Standards and Technology also known as n
started development on AES in 1997 when
it was announced the need for an
alternative to the data encryption
standard the new internet needed a
replacement for Dees because of its
small key size with increasing computing
power it was considered unsafe against
entire key search attacks the triple Ds
was designed to overcome this problem
however it was deemed to be too slow to
be deployed in machines
worldwide strong cases were present by
the Mars rc6 Serpent and the two fish
algorithms but it was the rindal
encryption algorithm also known as AES
which was eventually chosen as the
standard symmetri key encryption
algorithm to be used used its section
was formalized with the release of
federal information processing standards
publication 197 in the November of 2001
it was approved by the US Secretary of
Commerce now that we understand the
origin of AES let us have a look at the
features that make AES encryption
algorithm
unique the AES algorithm uses a
substitution permutation or SP Network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a dier text it has a series of
linked operations including replacing
inputs with specific outputs that is
substitutions and others that involve
bit shuffling which is
permutations at the beginning of the
encryption process we only start out
with a single key which can be either a
128bit key a 192bit key or a 256bit key
eventually this one key is expanded to
be used in multiple rounds throughout
the encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on bite data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the dees
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16 bytes the
number of rounds during the encryption
process depends on the key size that is
being used the 128bit key size fixes 10
Rounds the 192bit key size fixes 12
rounds and the 256bit key holds 14
rounds a round key is required for each
of these rounds but since only one key
is input into the algorithm the single
key needs to be expanded to get the key
for each round including the round
zero with so many mathematical
calculations going on in the background
there are bound to be a lot of steps
throughout the procedure let's have a
look at the steps followed in
AES before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES
encryption everything in the process is
stored in a 4 into for Matrix
format this Matrix is also known as a
state array and we'll be using these
State arrays to transmit data from one
step to another and from one round to
the next
round each round takes straight array as
input and gives a straight array as
output to be transferred into the next
round it is a 16 byte Matrix with each
cell representing one
byte with each four bytes representing a
word so every state array will have a
total of of four words representing
it as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in let's say the number of rounds
are n then the key has to be expanded to
be used with n+1 rounds because the
first round is the key zero
round let's say n is the number of
rounds the key is expanded to n + one
rounds it is also a state array having
four words in its vicinity every key is
used for a single round and the first
key is used as a round key before any
round
begins in the very beginning the plane
text is captured and passed through an
exort function with the round key as a
supplement this key can be considered
the first key from the n+1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a bite
substitution
process beyond that there is a provision
to shift rows in the state arrays later
on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mixed column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round the last four steps mentioned are
part of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input in the
last round however we skipped the mix
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining
unchanged but what are these bite
substitution and row shifting processes
let's find out regarding each step in
more
detail in the first step the plain text
is stored in a state array and is exor
with the k0 which is the first key in
the expanded key set this step is
performed only once on a block while
being repeated at the end of each each
round as per iteration
demands the state array is exor with the
key to get a new state array which is
then passed office input to the sub
bytes
process in the second stage we have byte
substitution we leverage an Xbox called
as a substitution box to randomly switch
data among each element every single
bite is converted into a heximal value
having two parts the first part denotes
the row value and the second part
denotes the column value the entire
State array is passed through the sbox
to create a brand new state array which
is then passed off as an input to the
row shifting process the 16 input bytes
are replaced by looking at a fixed table
given in the design we finally get a
matrix with four rows and four
columns when it comes to row shifting
each bit in the four rows of the Matrix
is shifted to the left an entry that is
a fall off is reinserted to the right of
the line the change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left the third line is
shifted two positions to the left and
the fourth line is shifted three
positions to the left the result is a
new Matrix that contains the same 16
bytes but has been moved in relation to
each other to boost the complexity of
the
program in mixed columns each column of
four bytes is now replaced using a
special method mathematical function the
function takes four bytes of a column as
input and outputs for completely new
bytes we will get a new Matrix with the
same size of 16 bytes and it should be
noted that this phase has not been done
in the last round of the
iteration when it comes to adding a
round key the 16 bytes of the Matrix are
treated as 128 bits and the 128 bits of
the round key are exort if it is the
last round the output is the cipher text
if you still have a few rounds remaining
the resulting 128 bits are interpreted
as 16 bytes and we start another similar
round let's take an example to
understand how all these processes work
if our plain text is the string
2192 we first convert it into a
hexadecimal format as follows we use an
encryption key which is that's my K Fu
and it is converted into a heximal
format as
well as per the guidelines we use a
single key which is then later expanded
into n +1 number of keys in which case
it's supposed to be 11 keys for 10
different
rounds in round zero we add the round
key the plane test is exort with the k0
and we get a state array that is passed
off as an input to the substitution by
its
process
when it comes to the substitution byes
process we leverage an sbox to
substitute the elements of each bite
with a completely new bite this way the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the row shifting
process on the next
step when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three
the state array that we received from
the row shifting is passed off as an
input to mix columns in mixed columns we
multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which I receive a
new Straight array to be passed on on to
the next
step we add the name State array as an
exor with the round key of the
particular iteration whatever state
array we receive here it becomes an
output for this particular
round now since this is the first round
of the entire encryption process the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the new
Round We repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text once the final State array can be
denoted in the hexadecimal format this
becomes our final Cipher text that we
can use for transferring information
from the sender and
receiver let's take a look at the
applications of AES in this
world AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients highly secure
mechanisms like WPA and WPA2 psk are
extensively used in securing Wi-Fi
endpoints with the help of Riles
algorithm it also helps helps in SSL TLS
encryption that is instrumental in
encrypting our internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for
communication AES is also prevalent in
general file encryption of various
formats ranging from critical documents
to the media files having a large key
allows people to encrypt media and
decrypt data with maximum security
possible AES is also used for processor
Security in Hardware Appliances to
prevent machine hijacking among other
things as a direct successor to the dees
algorithm there are some aspects that
AES provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a
look when it comes to key length the
biggest flaw in DS algorithm was that
small length was easily vulner Able by
today's standards eses has managed to
NAB up 128 192 and 256bit key lens to
bolster the security further the block
size is also larger in AES owing to more
complexity of the algorithm the number
of rounds in Dees is fixed irrespective
of the plane text being used in AES the
number of round depends on the key
length that is being used for the
particular iteration thereby providing
more Randomness and complexity in the
algorithm
the dees algorithm is considered to be
simpler than AES even though AES beats
Dees when it comes to relative speed of
encryption and decryption this makes
Advanced encryption standard much more
streamlined to be deployed in Frameworks
and systems worldwide when it compares
to the data encryption standard hello in
our last video on cryptography we took a
look at symmetry key cryptography we
used a single private key for both the
encryption and decryption of data and it
works very well in theory let's take a
look at a more realistic scenario now
let's meet Joe Joe is a journalist who
needs to communicate with Ryan via
longdistance messaging due to the
critical nature of the information
people are waiting for any message to
leave Joe's house so that they can
intercept it now Joe can easily use
symmetric cryptography to send the
encrypted data so that even if someone
intercepts the message they cannot
understand what it says but here's the
tricky part how will Joe send the
required decryption key to Ryan the
sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily key sharing is a risk
that will always exist when symmetric
key cryptography is being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
manage to fix this problem this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on asymmetry key cryptography
let's take a look at what we are going
to learn today We Begin by explaining
what asymmetry key cryptography is and
how it works we take a look at its
application and uses we understand why
it's called publicy cryptography and
then learn a little bit about RS
encryption and then we learn about the
advantages of asymmetric key
cryptography over symmetric key
cryptography
let's understand what asymmetry key
is asymmetry encryption uses a double
layer of protection there are two
different keys at play here a private
key and a public key a public key is
used to encrypt the information
pre-transit and a private key is used to
decrypt the data post Transit these pair
of keys must belong to the receiver of
the message the public keys can be
shared via messaging blog posts or key
servers and there are no resp
restrictions as you can see in the image
the two keys are working in the system
the sender first encrypts the message
using the receiver's private key after
which we receive the cipher text the
cipher text is then transmitted to the
receiver without any other key on
getting the cipher text the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt it and
get the plane text back there has been
no requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key
cryptography the public public key known
to everyone cannot be used to decp the
message and the private key which can
decp the message need not be shared with
anyone the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys as often as
possible to understand this better take
the analogy of your
mailbox anyone who wants to send you a
letter has access to the box and can
easily share information with you in a
way you can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it this
is how the private key comes to play no
one can intercept the message and read
its contents since it's encrypted once
the receiver gets its contents he can
use his private key to decrypt the
information both the public key and the
private key are generated so they are
interl and you cannot substitute other
private keys to decrypt the data in
another example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob let's say tre's called me
today she must use Bob's public key
while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decrypt the message and hence
complete Securities attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the
key since this type of encryption is
highly secure it has many users in areas
that require High
confidentiality it is used to manage
digital signatures so there is valid
proof of a document
authenticity with so many aspects of
business transitioning to the digital
sphere critical documents need to be
verified before being considered
authentic and acted upon thanks to
asymmetric key cryptography senders can
now sign documents with their private
Keys anyone who needs to verify the
authenticity of such signatures can use
the sender's public key to decrypt the
signature since the public and the
private keys are linked to each other
mathematically it's impossible to repeat
this verification with with duplicate
Keys document encryption has been made
very simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
similar
approach in blockchain architecture
asymmetry key cryptography is used to
authorize transactions and maintain the
system thanks to its two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain's peer-to-peer Network only
if it is approved from both ends along
with asymmetric key cryptography stamp
appro architecture its non- repudiation
characteristic also helps in keeping the
network stable
we can also use asymmetry key
cryptography combined with symmetry key
cryptography to monitor SSL or TLS
encrypted browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal up personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general it
plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption Keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure HTTP website
format security par parameters differ on
a session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to Modern data
security another great use of the
asymmetric key cryptography structure is
transmitting keys for symmetric key
cryptography with the most significant
difficulty in symmetric encryption being
key exchange asymmetric keys can help
clear the shortcoming the original
message is first encrypted using a
symmetry key the key used for encrypting
the data is then converted into the
cipher text using the receiver's public
key now we have two Cipher text to
transmit to the receiver on receiving
both of them the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt the Symmetry key
he can then use it to decrypt the
original information on getting the key
used to encrypt the data while this may
seem more complicated than just
asymmetric key cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions encrypting the key
using asymmetric algorithms will
definitely be more memory effic
efficient and
secure you might remember us discussing
why symmetric encryption was called
private key cryptography let us
understand why asymmetric falls under
the public key
cryptography we have two keys at our
disposal the encryption key is available
to everyone the decryption key is
supposed to be
private unlike symmetry key cryptography
there is no need to share anything
privately to have an encrypted messaging
system to put that into perspective
we share our email address with anyone
looking to communicate with us it is
supposed to be public by Design so that
our email login credentials are private
and they help in preventing any data
mishandling since there is nothing
hidden from the world if they want to
send us any encrypted information this
category is called the public key
cryptography there are quite a few
algorithms being used today that follow
the architecture of asymmetric
cryptography none more famous than the
RS encryption
RSA encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetry key approach
named after its Founders reest Shamir
and Adelman it uses block ciphers to
obscure the information if you are
unfamiliar with how block ciphers work
they are encryption algorithms that
divide the original data into blocks of
equal size the block size depends on the
exact Cipher being used once they are
broken down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later chained together
to form the final Cipher
text widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption albate
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat
applications with so many variables in
play there must be some advantages that
give asymmetrically cryptography and
Edge over the traditional symmetric
encryption methodologies let's go
through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recpt any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance we have much more extensive
key lens in RSA encryption and other
asymmetric algorithms like 248 bit key
and 96 bit Keys larger keys are much
harder to break into via brute force and
are much more
secure asymmetri key cryptography can
use as a proof of authenticity since
only the rightful owner of the keys can
generate the messages to be decrypted by
the private key the situation can also
be reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner it also
has a tamper protection feature where
the message cannot be intercepted and
changed without invalidating the private
key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot deip
the message and it is easy to realize
the information is not 100% legitimate
when and where the case
requires now that we have a proper
revision let's understand what digital
signatures are before moving on to the
algorithm the objective of digital
signatures is to authenticate and verify
documents and data this is necessary to
avoid tampering and digital modification
or forgery of any kind during the
transmission of official
documents they work on the public key
cryptography architecture with one
exception typically an asymmetri key
system encrypts using a public key and
decrypts with a private key for digital
signatures however the reverse is
true the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are ink
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document thereby
verifying the signatures Provence let's
go through each step to understand the
procedure
thoroughly in step one we have M which
is the original plain text message and
it is passed onto a hash function
denoted by H hash to create a
digest next it B bules the message
together with a hash digest and encrypts
it using the sender private
key it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender public
key once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function H
has to generate a similar
digest it compares the newly generated
hash with the bundled hash value
received along with the message if they
match it verifies data
Integrity in many instances they provide
a layer of validation and security to
messages through non-secured Channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender digital signatures are equivalent
to traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type digital
signature schemes in the sense used here
are cryptographically based and must be
implemented properly to be effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret further some
non-repudiation schemes offer a time
stamp for the digital signature so that
even if the private key is exposed the
signature is
valid to implement the concept of
digital signature in real world we have
two primary algorithms to follow the RSA
algorithm and the DSA algorithm but the
latter is a topic of learning today so
let's go ahead and see what the digital
signature algorithm is supposed to
do digital signature algorithm is a fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures it was proposed in 1991 and
globally standardized in 1994 by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also Al known as the nist it
functions on the framework of modular
exponation and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute
system unlike DSA most signature types
are generated by signing message digest
with the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data since just the message digest is
signed the signature is generally much
smaller compared to the data that was
signed as a result digital signatures
impose less load on processors at the
time of signing execution and they use
small volumes of bandwidth DSA on the
other hand does not encrypt message
digest using private key or decry
message digest using public key instead
it uses mathematical functions to create
a digital signature consisting of two
160 bit numbers which are originated
from the message digests and the private
key DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with RSA DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication Integrity
verification and non-
repudiation in the image we can see the
entire process of DSF validation a plain
text message is passed onto a hash
function where the digest is generated
which is passed onto a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g a
random variable k
and the private key of the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by S and
R on the receiver end we pass the plane
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message digest it is
passed onto verification function which
has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender Global variable
G and SNR received from the
sender the value generated by the
function is then compared to R if they
match then the verification process is
complete and data Integrity is verified
this was an overview of the way the DSA
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next
section we have we have three phases
here the first of which is key
generation to generate the keys we need
some
prerequisites we select a q which
becomes a prime divisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus 1 mod Q
equal to 0 we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the screen
right now once these values are selected
we can go ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by X and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of zero and the
value of Q the public key can be
calculated as y = to G ^ x mod P where y
stands for the public key the private
key can then be packaged as a bundle
which comprises of values of p q G and X
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p q G and Y
once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this
generation
repeat once the keys are generated we
can start generating the
signature the message is passed through
a hash function to generate the digest
Edge first we can choose any random
integer K which falls under the bracket
of 0 and Q to calculate the first 160
bit number of a signing function of r we
use the formula G ^ K mod P into mod Q
similarly to calculate the value of the
second output that is s we use the
following formula that is shown on the
screen the signature can then be
packaged as a bundle having R and
S this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver now with the third phase we
have to verify the signature we first
calculate the message digest received in
the bundle by passing it to the same
hash function we calculate the value of
w U1 and U2 using the formulas shown on
the screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of R being
sent by the sender this verification
component can be calculated using the
following formula once calculated this
can be compared with the value of R if
the values match then the signature
verification is successful and our
entire process is complete starting from
Key generation to the signature
Generation all the way up to the
verification of the
signature with so many steps to follow
we are bound to have a few advantages to
boot this and we would be right to think
so DSA is highly robust in the security
and stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the simpl it and the
flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other
suits the key generation is much faster
when compared to the RSA algorithm and
such while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of
Frameworks DSA requires Less storage
space to work its entire cycle in
contrast its direct correspondent that
is RS algorithm needs a certain amount
of computational and storage space to
function efficiently this is not the
case with DSA which has been optimized
to work with weaker hardware and lesser
resources the DSA is patented but nist
has made this patent available worldwide
royalty-free a draft version of the
speculation fips 1865 indicates that DSL
will no longer be approved for digital
signature generation but it may be used
to verify signatures generated prior to
the implementation date of that
standard the RSA algorithm is a publicy
signature algorithm developed by Ron
rivest ADI Shamir and Leonard Edelman
the paper was first published in 1977
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand brute force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment RSA can also encrypt and
decrypt general information
to securely exchange data along with
handling digital signature verification
let us understand how it achieve this we
take our plane text message M we pass it
through a hash function to generate the
digest H which is then encrypted using
the sender's private key this is
appended to the original plane text
message and sent over to the
receiver once the receiver receives the
bundle we can pass the plain text
message through the same hash function
to generate a digest and the cipher text
can can be decrypted using the public
key of the sender the remaining hashes
are compared if the values match then
the data Integrity is verified and the
sender is authenticated apart from
digital signatures the main case of RSA
is encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge this is
where the data encryption comes into
play when using RSA for encryption and
decryption of General data it reverses
the key set usage unlike signature
verification it it receives the
receiver's public key to encrypt the
data and uses the receiver's private key
in decrypting the data thus there is no
need to exchange any keys in this
scenario there are two broad components
when it comes to RSA cryptography one of
them is key generation key generation
employs a step of generating the private
and the public keys that are going to be
used for encrypting and decrypting the
data the second part is the encryption
and decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the cipher text you will
Now understand each of these steps in
our next
subtopic keeping the previous two
concepts in mind let us go ahead and see
how the entire process works starting
from creating the keeper to encrypting
and decrypting the
information you need to generate the
public and private Keys before running
the functions to generate Cipher text
and plain text they use certain
variables and parameters all of which
are explained we first use two large
prime numbers which can be denoted by P
and Q we can compute the value of n as
Nal P into q and compute the value of
Zed as P -1 into Q
-1 a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number D is also selected at random
following the formula Ed mod Z equal to
1 and it can be calculated with the
formula given
below the public ke is then packaged as
a abund with n and E and the private key
is packaged as a bundle using n and
D this sums of the key generation
process for the encryption and
decryption function we use the formula C
and M the cipher text can be calculated
as c = m^ e mod n and the pl text can be
calculated from the cipher text as C
power D modn when it comes to a data
encryption example let's take p and Q as
7 and 13
the value of n can be calculated as
91 if we select the value of e to be
five it satisfy all the criteria that we
need it to the value of D can be
calculated using the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91a 5 and the
private key can then be packaged as 91a
29 the pl text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m Cipher text can be
calculated to the formula c = m the^ e
mod n which gives us 82 if somebody
receives this Cipher text they can
calculate the plain text using the
formula C to the^ D mod n which gives us
the value of 10 as selected as our PL
text we can now look at the factors that
make the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus
its competitors in the advantageous
topics of this
lesson RSA encryption depends on using
the receiver's public key so that you
don't have to share any sec secret key
to receive the messages from others this
was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography
structure since the key pairs are
related to each other a receiver cannot
intercept the message since the didn't
have the correct private keys to decp
the information if a public key can decp
the information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private anymore
the encryption process is faster than
that of the DSA algorithm even if the
key generation is slower in RSA many
systems across the world tend to reuse
the same keys so that they can spend
less time in key generation and more
time on actual Cipher text
management data will be tamper proof in
transit since meddling with the data
will alter the usage of the keys the
private key won't be able to decp the
information hence alerting the receiver
of any kind of manipulation in between
the must be aware of any third party who
possesses the private key since they can
alter the data mid Transit the cases of
which are rather low imagine creating an
account on a new website you provide
your email address and set a password
that you are confident and you would not
forget what about the website owner how
securely are they going to store your
password for website administrators they
have three Alternatives they can either
store the passwords in a plain text
format they can encrypt the passwords
using an encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value let's have a look at each of
these when a password is stored in
cleant text format it is considered to
be the most unsafe option since anyone
in the company can read your passwords a
single hack and a data server breach
will expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra
efford to counter this owners can
encrypt the passwords and keep them in
the servers as a second alternative but
that would mean they also have to store
the decryption key somewhere on their
servers in the event of a data breach or
the server hack both the decryption key
and encrypted passwords will be leaked
thus making it a single point of
failure what if there was an option to
store the passwords after scrambling
them completely but with no way to
decrypt them this is where hashing comes
to play since only the hashed values are
stored in the server no encryption is
needed with no plain text passwords to
protect your credentials are safe from
the website administrators considering
all the pros hashed passwords are the
industry standard when it comes to
storing credentials
nowadays before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing
Works hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of information or
data beyond recognition we can achieve
this by using hash functions which are
essentially algorith MSS that perform
mathematical operations on the main
plain text the value generated after
passing the plain text information
through the hash function is called the
hash value digest or in general just the
hash of the original data while this may
sound similar to encryption the major
difference is hashes are meant to be
irreversible no decryption key can
convert a digest back to its original
value however a few hashing algorithms
have been broken due to the increase in
computational comp complexity of today's
new generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in use among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification
Etc like we discussed earlier websites
use hashing to store the users passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords when a user signs up to create
a new account the password is then run
through the hash function and the
resulting hash value is stored on the
servers
so the next time a user comes to log to
the account the password he enters is
passed to the same hash function and
compared to the hash stored on the main
server if the newly calculated hash is
the same as the one stored on the
website server the password must have
been correct because according to Hash
functions terminology same inputs will
always provide the same
outputs if the hashes do not match then
the password entered during login is not
the same as the password entered during
the sign up hence the login will be
denied this way no plain text passwords
get stored preventing both the owner
from snooping on user data and
protecting users privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack apart from password storage hashing
can also be used to perform Integrity
checks when a file is uploaded on the
internet the file's hash value is
generated and it is uploaded along with
the original information when a new user
downloads the file he can calculate the
digest of the downloaded file using the
same hash function when the hash values
are compared if they match then file
Integrity has been maintained and there
has been no data
corruption since so much important
information is being passed on the hash
function we need to understand how they
work a hash function is a set of
mathematical calculations operated on
two blocks of data the main input is
broken down into two blocks of similar
size the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being
used hash functions are designed to be
one way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised but more secure algorithms
are being used today like the sh F of
algorithms the digest size is also
dependent on the respective algorithm
being used md5 has a digest of 128 bits
while s 256 has a Digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not
reversible there are certain
requirements of a hash function that
need to be met before they are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
Security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively Fast Pace but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large amounts of data and not
make it ridiculously easy to Brute Force
by running through all the possible
combinations the hash function must be
depend on each bit of the input the
input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digest for every
password that is being store but what if
two different users are using the same
password since the hash function is the
same for all users both the digests will
be the same this is called called a hash
Collision you may think this must be a
rare occasion where two users have
exactly the same password but that is
not the case we have techniques like
salting that can be used to reduce these
hash collisions as we will discuss later
in this
video you would be shocked to see the
most used passwords of 2020 all of these
passwords are laughably insecure and
since many people use the same passwords
repeatedly on different websites hash
collisions risk are more common than one
would
expect let's say the hash functions find
two users having the same password how
can they store both the hashes without
messing up the original data this is
where salting and peppering come to
play salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
for each user on the system and it is
called the salt value or just the salt
so even if two passwords are exactly the
the same the salt value will differ and
so will the digest there is a small
problem with this process though since
the salt is unique for each user they
need to be stored in the database along
with the passwords and sometimes even in
plain text to speed up the process of
continuous verification if the server is
hacked then the hashes will need to be
brute forced which takes a lot of time
but if they receive the sols as well the
entire process becomes very fast this is
something that peppering aims to solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case the pepper isn't
stored on the servers it is mostly
hardcoded onto the website source code
since it's going to be the same for all
credentials this way even if the servers
get hacked they will not not have the
right pepper needed to crack into all
the passwords many websites use a
combination of salting and peppering to
solve the problem of hash collision and
bolster security since Brute Force takes
such a long time many hackers avoid
taking the effort the returns are mostly
not worth it and the possible
combinations of using both salting and
peppering is
humongous with the consensus aiming
towards an educated public on digital
privacy
it's no surprise to see an increasing
interest in encryption algorithms we
have already covered the major names
like the dees and the AES algorithm md5
algorithm was one of the first hashing
algorithms to take the global stage as a
successor to the md4 despite the
security vulnerabilities encountered in
the future md5 Still Remains a crucial
part of data infrastructure in a
multitude of
environments the md5 hash algorithm is a
one-way cryptographic functions that
accepts a message of any length as input
and it returns as output a fixed length
digest value to be used for
authenticating the original messages the
digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input the md5 hash
function was originally designed for use
as a secure cryptographic hash algorithm
to authenticate digital signatures md5
has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non-cryptographic check
some to verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data
corruption Ronald dest founder of RSA
data security and Institute professor at
MIT designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the
md4 as already iterated before the
process is straightforward we pass up
plain text message to the md5 hash
functions which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 28 bit
digest received from this is going to be
radically different from the pl text the
goal of any message digest function is
to produce digest that appear to be
random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value even a slight change in
the plane text should trigger a drastic
difference in the two digests this goes
a long way in preventing hash collisions
which take place when two different PL
Texs have the same
digest to achieve this level of
intricacy there are number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when we receive the
input string we have to make sure the
size is 64 bits short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters this
prepares a string to have a length of
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512 here and out we can proceed onto The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bits short of any
multiple of 512 now we add the length
bits in such a way that the total number
of bits in the message is perfectly a
multiple of
512 that means 64 bit length to be
precise are added to the message our
final string to be hashed is now a
definite multiple of 512
The Next Step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer the entire hashing
plane text is now broken down into
512-bit
blocks there are four buffers or
registers that are of 32 bits each named
a b c and
d these are the four words that are
going to store the values of each of
these
subblocks the first iteration to follow
these registers will have fixed hexad
decimal values as shown on the screen
below once these values are
initial of these 512 blocks we can
divide each of them into 16 further
subblocks of 32 bits each for each of
these subblocks we run four rounds of
operations having the four buffer
variables a b c and d these rounds
require the other constant variables as
well which defer with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a a random array of 64 elements since
each 32-bit subblock is run four times
16 such subblocks equal 64 constant
values needed for a single block
iteration the subblocks can be denoted
by the alphabet M and the constant
values are denoted by the alphabet
T coming to the actual round of
operation we see our four buffers which
already have pre-initialized values for
the first iteration at the very
beginning the values of buffers B C and
D are passed on to a nonlinear
logarithmic function the formula behind
this function changes by the particular
round being worked on as we shall see
later in this video Once the output is
calculated it is added to the raw value
stored in buffer a the output of this
addition is added to the particular
32bit subblock using which we are
running the four
operations the output of this requisite
function then needs to be added to a
constant value derived from the constant
AR k
since we have 64 different elements in
the array repeat since we have 64
different elements in the array we can
use a distinct element for each
iteration of a particular block The Next
Step involves a circular shift that
increases the complexity of the hash
algorithm and is necessary to create a
unique digest for each individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer B the
final output is now stored in the second
buffer of B of the output register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C value of C
gets stored in D and the value of D in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this subblock the values of a b c d
are moved on as input to the next
subblock Once all 16 subblocks are
completed the final Reg register value
is saved and the next 512-bit block
begins at the end of all these blocks we
get a final digest of the md5
algorithm regarding the nonlinear
process mentioned in the first step the
formula changes for each round it's
being run on this is done to maintain
the computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure the formula for each of
the four rounds uses the same parameters
that is b c and d to generate a single
output the formulas being used are shown
on the screen right
now algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digests they don't consume
a noticeable amount of dis storage and
are comparatively easier to remember and
reiterate passwords need not be stored
in plain text format making them
accessible for hackers and malicious
actors when using Digest the database
security also gets a boost since the
sizes of all the hash values will be the
same in the event of a hack or a breach
the malicious actor will only receive
the hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which would be
the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by Design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays a relatively low memory
footprint is necessary when it comes to
integrating multiple Services into the
same framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string this helps in creating a low
requirement for computational power and
is much easier to run on older Hardware
which is pretty common in server farms
around the
world we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
after Transit once the hash is match
file Integrity checks are valid and we
can avoid data
corruption hash functions will always
give the same output for the similar
input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the
message we use a Wi-Fi everyday for work
and we use the internet for
entertainment and communication the
dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades a big portion of this
belongs to ensuring secure channels of
communication and data
transmission the secure hash algorithm
are a family of cryptographic hash
functions that are published by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology along with the NSA it was
passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as FPS it
has four different families of hash
functions ssj 0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw sha1 is also a 160 bit
hash function which resembles the
earlier md5 algorithm this was designed
by the NSA to be a part of the digital
signature
algorithm S2 is a family of two similar
hash functions with different blocks
sizes known as the sh 256 and the Sha
512 they differ in the word size sh 256
uses 32 bit words where sha 512 uses 64
bit words sh3 is a hash function
properly known as kak it was chosen in
2012 after a public competition among
non NSA designers it supports the same
hash lens as H2 and its internal
structure differs significantly from the
rest of the sh family
as we have already iterated the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the sh hash function which in
turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 160 bit digest received
from this is going to be radically
different from the plain text the goal
of any hash function is to produce
digest that appear to be random to be
considered cryptographically secure the
hash function should meet two
requirements first the it is impossible
for an attacker to generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second it should be impossible for an
attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plane text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which takes
place when two different plane texts
have the same
digest the sh family functions have some
characteristics that they need to follow
while generating the the digest let's go
through a few of
them the length of the clear text should
be less than 2^ 64 bits in the case of
sh1 and
s256 this is essential to keep the plane
text compatible with the hash function
and the size needs to be in comparison
area to keep the digest as random as
possible the length of the hash digest
should be 256 bits in the s s 256
algorithm 512 bits in the Sha 512
algorithm and so on bigger digest
usually suggests significantly more
calculations at the cost of speed and
space we typically go for the longest
diges to bolster security but there must
be a definite balance between the speed
and security of a hash
function by Design all hash function of
the Sha 512 sh 256 are
irreversible you should neither get a
plain text when you have the digest
beforehand nor should the digest provide
the original value when you pass it
through the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance this is done to reduce
the chance of Brute Force
attacks to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when you receive the
input string you have to make sure the
size is 64bit short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the mids
you must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
character s this prepares our string to
have a length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of
512 here on out we can proceed to The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message was 64 bits short from becoming
a multiple of
512 now we add the length of bits in
such a way that the total number of bits
in the message is a perfect multiple of
that means 64 bits plus the length of
the original message becomes a multiple
of 512 this becomes a final string that
needs to be
hashed in the next step we have to
initialize this chaining
variables the entire plain text message
can now be broken down into blocks of
512 bits each unlike other hash
algorithms like md5 which use four
registers or buffers sha family use five
buffers of 32 bits each they are named a
b c d and e these registers go through
multiple rounds of operation where the
first iteration has fixed H decimal
values as can be seen in the
screen moving on we have to process each
of the 512-bit blocks by breaking each
of them into 16 subblocks of 32 bits
each each of them goes through four
rounds of operation that use the entire
register and have the 512-bit block
along with the constant array out of
those four rounds each round has 20
iterations so in general we have 80
rounds some
total the constant value of K is an
array of 80
elements of those 80 16 elements are
being used each round so that comes out
to 80 rounds for each of those
elements the value of T differs by the
number of rounds as can be seen in the
table
below a single formula is necessary AR
to calculate the output of each round
and iteration the formula can be AB B
CDE e registor is equal to e plus a
nonlinear process P along with a
circular shift of a plus WT + KT in this
formula ABCD is the register value of
the chaining variables as we discussed
before p is The Logical process which
has a different formula for each round
S5 is a circular shift by five bits and
WT is a 32bit string derived from the
existing subblock this can be calculated
depending on the iteration at
hand KT signifies a single element of
the 80 character element array which
changes depending on the particular
round at hand for the values of WT the
first 16 values are the same as that of
the subblocks so there is no extra
calculation needed for the next 64
elements the value of WT can be
calculated as shown in the formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
registor as the
output next we use a nonlinear process P
that changes depending on the round and
uses the values of b c and d as
input whatever output is generated from
the nonlinear process it is added with
the value of the E
register next the value of a is circular
shifted by five bits and is added with
the output generated in the previous
step the next step is adding the value
of WT and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
registor a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all all the
subblocks are joined together to form
the single Cipher text message we will
have our hash output regarding the
nonlinear process P that uses the values
of b c and d as input the formula
changes every round to maintain a
complexity of the program that can
withstand Brute Force attacks depending
on the round the values are passed
through a logical operation which is
then added with the values of WT KT and
so on now that we understand how to get
our hash digest from the plain text let
us learn about the advantages we obtain
when using the Sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text
format digital signatures follow
asymmetric encryption methodology to
verify the authenticity of a document or
a file hash algorithms like sh 256 and
the industry standard sha 512 go a long
way in ensuring the verification of
signatures passwords need not be stored
in a plain text format which makes them
accessible to hackers and other
malicious actors when using digest the
database security also gets a boost
since the size of all hash values will
be the same in the event of a hack or a
breach the malicious actor will only
receive the hash values with no way to
regenerate the plane text in this case
the plane text would be user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing part passwords
on the
servers the SSL handshake is a crucial
segment of the web browsing sessions and
it's done using sha functions it
consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection it relies on a
combination of symmetric and asymmetric
algorithms which ensure the
confidentiality of the data transmitted
between a web server and a web client
like the
browsers you can can monitor file
corruption by comparing hash values
before and after Transit once the hash
is match file Integrity checks are valid
and data corruption is avoided hash
functions will always give the same
output for the same input irrespective
of the iteration parameters it also
helps in ensuring that the data hasn't
been tampered with on route to the
receiver of the message passwords are by
far the most common type of user
authentication they are popular because
the theory makes perfect sense to
individuals and is reasonably simple to
implement for developers on the other
hand poorly constructed passwords can
pose security flaws a well-designed
password-based authentication process
does not save the user's actual password
this would make it far too simple for a
hacker or a malevolent Insider to access
all of the systems user accounts in this
video you will learn how to crack
passwords and simultaneously try to make
your passwords as Brute Force resistant
as possible let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today
we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for
hacking moving on we take a look at the
multiple tools that hackers can use to
generate these hashes and the
passwords finally we take a look at the
steps and the guidelines that users can
follow to prevent their passwords from
being cracked
let's start by giving a basic idea about
password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources malicious
actors can engage in various criminal
activities with the information obtained
through password tracking the procedure
might entail comparing a set of words to
guess credentials or using an algorithm
to guess the password repeatedly
password cracking can be done for
several reasons but the most malicious
reason is in order to gain unauthorized
access to a computer without the owner's
awareness this results in cyber crime
such as stealing passwords for the
purpose of accessing banking information
other non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
another example of Norm malicious
password cracking may take place if a
system administrator is conducting test
on password strength as a form of
security test this enables so that the
hacker cannot easily access protected
systems the best way that users can
protect their passwords from cracking is
to ensure that they choose strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and
symbols strong passwords should never be
actual words in addition strong
passwords are at least eight characters
long in many password protected
applications users are notified of the
strength of the password they've chosen
upon entering it the user can then
modify it and strengthen the password
based on the indications of its strength
now that we understand the basics of
password cracking let's go to the basic
techniques hackers use to retrieve
passwords from General
victims asking the customer for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwar reader
to a counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset
that page then captures their password
which the hacker can subsequently
exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vital credentials and
information through social engineering
the employee tried and through tactics
to exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means means to breach secure and
Advanced Technologies it has been
demonstrated that many firms either lack
adequate security or are overly friendly
and trustworthy when they should not be
they allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the correct password in
the case of a dictionary attack password
dictionaries cover many themes and of
mixture of topics such as politics
movies and music groups users failure to
create a strong password is why this
approach efficiently cracks passwords
till today simply said this assault
employs the same terms that many
individuals use as passwords a hacker
can compare the password hash obtained
to hashes of the password dictionaries
to find the correct plain text
password now that the passwords have
been hashed the hackers attempt to
achieve authentication by breaking the
password hash they accomplish this by
employing a rainbow table which is a set
of pre-computed hashes of port portable
password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting in
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves the password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necessitate
the discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches in a Brute Force assault the
attacker attempts multiple password
combinations until the correct one is
identified the attacker uses software to
automate this process and run exhaustive
password combination in a substantially
shorter length of time with the growth
of hardware and technology in recent
years such programs have been
invigorated it won't be quick if your
password is more than a few characters
lengthy but it will eventually reveal
your password boot force assults can be
sped up by throwing more processing
resources at
them with so many different techniques
coming together to correct passwords
none of them are useful without the
right tools there are a prora of scripts
and Snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest let's go through
some of these
tools can and able is a password
recovery tool for Microsoft operating
systems it allows easy recovery of
various kinds of passwords by sniffing
the network cracking encrypted passwords
using dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording Vibe
conversations decoding scrambled
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc are some of the other features
of G enable
the latest version is faster and
contains a lot of new features like ARP
poison routing which enables sniffing on
Switched L and man inth middle attacks
the sniffer in this version can also
analyze encrypted protocols such as ssh1
and https while containing filters to
capture credentials from a wide range of
authentication
mechanisms it also ships routing
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
common hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the Ripper is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for unix-based
computers it was created to evaluate
password strength Brute Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks it can use dictionary
attacks rainbow tables and other attacks
depending on the target type
Rainbow Crack is a password cracking
application that uses time memory
trade-off algorithm to crack password
hashes with rainbow tables rainbow
tables make password cracking more
easier and faster than traditional Brute
Force attacks it is like a dictionary
containing nearly every possible
password and the pre-calculated hashes
creating this kind of dictionary takes
much more time than cracking a single
hash but after that you can use the same
dictionary over and over again this
procedure might take a long time however
once the table is ready it can break
passwords far quicker than Brute Force
methods with so many tools ready to NAB
our passwords there are certain set of
rules users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
making the Brute Force mechanism tougher
to implement longer passwords and pass
phrases have been demonstrated to boost
security significantly however it is
still critical to avoid lenier passwords
that have previously been hacked or that
feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal information
as previously said most users create
passwords utilizing personal information
such as Hobbies nicknames pet or family
member names Etc if a hacker has access
to personal information about a specific
user for example via social media the
will test password combination based on
that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience users should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users including those who work
in the same department or use the same
equipment should be avoided a single
breached password doesn't affect your
other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word
while pass phrases serve the same
objective the length make them more
difficult to break in addition to
letters a good pass should include
numbers and symbols passwords may be
easier for users to remember than pass
phrases however the latter is much more
breach
resistant two- Factor authentication or
2fa can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone TFA does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
ident identification PIN and a code
texted to the user smartphone or a
fingerprint before accessing whatever is
secured this helps discourage
unauthorized entries to an account
without the original owner's permission
at this point you may wonder why you
need a strong password in the first
place even if most websites are safe
there is still a danger that someone
will try to access or exploit your
information a strong password is among
the most effective ways to protect your
accounts and personal information from
hackers you should follow certain rules
RS and guidelines while creating a
strong password password managers are
also recommended to help remember the
created passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering
today we start by learning about the
state of password cracking in today's
world and why creating strong passwords
is an absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faes have grown in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal
information let's start by learning
about why strong passwords have become
an absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing password
simple and commonly used passwords
enable Intruders to easily gain access
and control a Computing device
conversely a password that is difficult
to guess makes it prohibitively
difficult for common hackers to break
into a machine and will force them to
look for another Target the more
difficult the password the lower the
likelihood that one's computer will fall
victim to an unwanted intrusion many
individuals opt to tie their websites to
something they can readily recall to
generally easy memorable combos however
however this does not make the password
unique in fact it's the reverse
passwords are handled by 53% of
individuals using their Recollections
and memory with modern computational
standards simple passwords take seconds
and a couple of minutes at worst to be
completely brute forc according to
Global surveys more than 60% of people
use the same passwords for their
personal and job applications while this
may allow the user never to forget the
password it makes a single point of
failure the only pin to drop if one of
the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked to further elaborate on how you
can create strong passwords let's go
through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
don'ts to understand how to create new
passwords for our accounts it is
recommended to keep the password length
at least 12 characters to ensure brute
forcing to be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an Absol absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more Brute
Force resistant than any number of
alphabets or letters can make moving
over to the Don
section it's absolutely not recommended
to keep Simple dictionary terms such as
computer or even the word password as
your credential because those are very
easy to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack
wordless similarly changing a single
alphabet or a single character in a
dictionary word does not make it Brute
Force instant considering there are
already algorithms present that can
counter this
tactic using the same character multiple
times in a password also reduces the
strength and makes it easier to crack
for hacker
ERS apart from using single characters
multiple times following patterns that
are present on the traditional English
keyboard such as e w t y or the line
below the main alphabet such as the ZX c
vbn m Etc make it easier to guess since
these are once again common combinations
that are present in word list
already finally the most important part
being not using personal information
such as birthdays addresses
and other important information in the
passwords more often than not if a
hacker is trying to break into your
account there has been some amount of
research done be via social media or any
other medium if they have already this
information present with them breaking
into your account becomes all the more
easier now that you understand how to
create strong password look at how past
freezes have become prevalent as a
replacement for plain text
passwords
a passphrase is a sentence like string
of words used for authentication that is
longer than a traditional password easy
to remember and difficult to crack
typical passwords range on an average
from 8 to 16 characters while pass
phrases can reach up to 100 characters
or more using a long fast phrase instead
of a short password to create a digital
signature is one of the many ways that
users can strengthen the security of
their data devices and accounts the
longer a passphrase is the more likely
user is to incorporate bits of entropy
or factors that make it less predictable
to potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements aosr is a
fast and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages that pass faes have over
common
passwords past phases are simpler to
remember than just a random assortment
of symbols and characters it's easier
easier to comprehend a line from your
favorite song or a quotation than a
short but difficult password passwords
are reasonably easy for humans and
robots to guess or crack online thieves
have also Advanced and created Cutting
Edge hacking tools to crack even the
most complex
passwords pass phrases are nearly hard
to crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 characters as a result even the most
sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess Brute Force ore compute
these passwords complies with password
setting rules with E passphrases the
usage of punctuation and upper and
lowercase password satisfy the password
complexity criteria most operating
systems and apps support pass
phrases freezes of up to 127 characters
are permitted on all major operating
systems including Windows Linux and Mac
as a result for optimal protection you
can use lengthier pass
phrases but when creating a strong
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass phrases this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password managers
generate new strong passwords and they
keep all of them in one place protected
by a single strong master password if
you maintain your master password the
manager will retain everything else
including your username and pass phrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign onto a website or app on your
computer or phone there is no good
memory needed for this this implies that
everyone may use the most recent
suggestions for strong passwords such as
extended phrases symbols grammar and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players in
password managers services like bit
Warden keas and Ashlan have been running
for years now and are very worthy
recommendations if you want to get
started with password management now
that we understand what is hacking let's
take a look at some points to know
whether our system is already haed or
not the first point regarding how to
check whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is Switched Off by unknown means and it
is not visible to the user this is one
of the most primary checkpoint to know
if our system is hacked or
not next point to check whether a system
is hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts performed by a professional
hacker or a cyber
criminal then we also face problems
regarding systems reaction speed which
is affected due to the execution of
unknown applications in the background
of the
system which also affects the hardware
resources in the device
next we also face problems regarding
passwords which are no longer working or
are changed without the user's
Intervention which might indicate that
there was some unknown hacking activity
that took place in our
account let's take a look at some more
points regarding the
topic there are often cases when the
system's cursor move on its own and
perform task indicating that the system
is being used by someone else using an
illegal hacking method there are also
cases when we often see files and
folders being created in the storage
disk on the system which is unknown to
us to better understand the points
regarding how to identify whether our
system is hacked or not let's take a
look then let's start with the first
point
if we want to check whether our system
is haed or not the first point would be
to choose the settings
option and using privacy and security
and moving on to the Windows security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the
system if we see any problem regarding
any one of them for example opon browser
control in my system it says there's a
problem with it which might be due to
hacking attempts that was done on my
system now let's take a look at the
other option how we can check whether
our system is hacked or not that would
be checking the antivirus software that
is installed in our
system if you face problems regarding
that this might be the issue according
to my antivirus software it says my
computer is at risk this might be due to
the interference from a cyber criminal
or a hacker while using different
illegal softwares during its hacking
attempt then there are also
cases where we see there are unknown
programs being executed in the
background of our system which we can
take a look using the task manager
software using the task manager we can
take a look at each and every
application that that is being executed
in the system and see the
origin if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking
attempt moving on if we want to check
further whether our system is hacked or
not we can check for files or folders
that are being created unknown to us for
example this unknown
folder which contains some sec details
that are unknown to
me this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or
cybercriminal then there are also cases
when the system's cursor move on its own
and perform task that are not initiated
by us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is due to a hacking attempt that
was done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of of a
system then there are also cases
regarding login issues or password
problem for
example if I want to access into my
account and there's a problem with the
password it might be due
to the attempt of hacking into my
account by a professional
hacker
seems like there's a problem with the
username which means there was a hacking
attempt by a professional
hacker we can further check hacking
attempts by accessing our web browser
and checking whether there's some extra
add-ons or unknown add-ons that wasn't
installed by us this might also indicate
a hacking attempt on the system now that
we are clear about how to check whether
a system is hacked or not let's take a
look at some of the counter measure
against hacking let's
begin the first point regarding how to
avoid hacking is do regular manual
Security checks and keep the system
security updated using certified
antivirus softwares is a basic counter
measure against hacking
attempts and if possible visit only
secure websites for surfing on the
Internet or use VPN or other Internet
Security applications to mask your
systems Network to avoid any hacking
attempts for the
device then we have avoid clicking on
random web popups and ads to avoid
Hackers from getting into a system and
accessing a device
data and lastly use strong passwords or
complex passwords for your login
details applying these counter measures
we can avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time since then instant messaging has
evolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain old
messaging among these apps WhatsApp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms like
everyone associated with the internet a
matter of security is never far away
considering the huge user base of this
messaging app hackers are always on the
lookout for compromised accounts to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our WhatsApp account
from falling into malicious
hands we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general
next we cover some of the most important
steps that should be followed in order
to protect our WhatsApp accounts from
hackers finally we learn what we should
do when a WhatsApp account gets
compromised let's start by learning why
we need to focus on the safety of
WhatsApp in the year of 2020 the big
news was about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos and
his phone being haed by Saudi Arabia a
report coming from the guardian
suggested that bezos's phone was hacked
via a video file sent on WhatsApp the
report said that bezos's mobile phone
was hacked by Saudi Arabian prince in
the year 2018 and gigabytes worth of
data was stolen from the device while
there are some issues being raised about
the report which states with the medium
to high confidence that Jeff piz's phone
was hacked it does raise a security fear
for regular users after all if the phone
of one of the world's most powerful men
can be hacked the same can happen to any
one of us as
well when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics the
information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging
habits WhatsApp uses endtoend encryption
to protect all communication on its
platform these encryption keys not only
make it impossible to decrypt messages
but they also prevent third parties and
even WhatsApp from accessing messages or
calls but not entirely although end to
end encryption makes WhatsApp more
secure than other communication apps no
app is 100% safe to use like any
application or digital device WhatsApp
is often targeted by Bad actors it also
has access to your contacts and tracks
where and how long you use it putting
your privacy and personal information at
risk we we all have access to our cell
phones so it's no surprise that sms2
factor authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tied to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multiactor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your
organization to a host of risk hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
network be it via spoofed SIM cards or
message hijacking WhatsApp tofa using
SMS isn't a foolproof
solution now that we understand the
variety of reasons why whatsap needs
extra security let's go through some of
the ways we can achieve
this it is more than probable that one
fine day you might receive a WhatsApp
message or even an SMS that reads that
your order is delayed please check its
data here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here
some of them may sound intimidating and
some of them may be lucrative but they
all have one purpose to trick you into
clicking that link and once you do that
it's already over it will install
malware on your phone and you won't have
a clue about it only when you start
noticing that your phone bills are
abnormally high or your bank account has
been used without your permission the
realization will Dawn upon you that
something is wrong with your phone but
by then it may be too
late WhatsApp in itself provides various
privacy options to users the messaging
platform provides users with option to
choose who they want to share with their
profile photo status and other details
with it's a good idea to change the
settings to contacts only this means
only phone numbers that are saved on
your smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
autod delete status as
well make sure you enable the option to
log the screen every time WhatsApp is
closed this will ensure no one else but
you can open your WhatsApp account just
head to the settings menu privacy and
select the screen lock option you will
then need to register your fingerprint
after the process is completed you will
have to scan your fingerprint every time
you open the WhatsApp app this adds an
extra layer of
security the two-step verification works
as an extra layer of security and helps
WhatsApp users to protect their otps and
documents shared through WhatsApp it's
very easy to set up a PIN to activate a
two-step verification users have to
enter it periodically once it is
activated WhatsApp will sometimes keep
asking users to enter the six-digit
passcode users cannot disable this
without disabling the two-step
verification feature
altogether in case users do not provide
WhatsApp with an email ID and want to
disable two-step verification then the
number will be permitted to rify on
WhatsApp without the passcode after 7
Days however the users will lose all
pending messages up on reverifying
we often have the tendency to log into
WhatsApp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
this habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp web before
leaving the office it just takes a few
seconds to log in again by just scanning
the code and you're
done all WhatsApp users should ensure
that the chats are end to end encrypted
to verify that a chat is end to endend
encrypted open the chat tap on the name
of the contact to open the contact Ino
screen and then tap encryption to view
the QR code and a 60 digigit number
WhatsApp end2end encryption ensures that
only you and your contact can read the
messages that are being exchanged and
nobody in between not even
WhatsApp with the necessary guidelines
out of the way let us go to the
recommended course of action should our
WhatsApp accounts be compromised
the first and most important thing that
you need to do is report the issue to
the WhatsApp support team for assistance
make sure that you reach out to the
support team through its help desk and
Report the hacking attempt WhatsApp help
center will take the shortest time to
resolve your issue via email or within
the app itself this will help you to
take prompt legal action against the
hackers if you can't access your email
call the support team in some cases the
support will deactivate your WhatsApp
account and request you to reactivate
within 30 days if you don't want it to
be deleted
completely when someone compromises your
WhatsApp account they can now send
messages to your contact stating that
the company sent your verification code
and gain access to the account that's
why one of the first things you'll want
to do is send a message to your friends
and family letting them know that you've
lost access to your account this action
preves further exploitation of your
account and others another reason you'll
want to let your contracts know you have
no access to to your WhatsApp account is
that they may fish for personal
information from your banking number to
your email address hackers will cleverly
attempt to gain as much access to your
personal information as
possible WhatsApp web is an extension of
WhatsApp messenger over the web that
facilitates easy synchronization of our
smartphone and personal computer this is
the biggest security threat that hackers
can easily exploit to get into your
personal data over WhatsApp therefore it
is highly recommended that you use this
WhatsApp feature carefully once you
notice that your whatpp messenger has
been hacked go to your WhatsApp web and
tap or click on the log out from all
computers option this will deactivate
all the web extensions of your
account under the unfortunate
circumstances where the account recovery
doesn't seem likely you can always ask
WhatsApp support to delete your account
permanently while far from the ideal
solution it can act as a fail safe
option if you want to protect your
personal data at any cost possible you
can always open a new account account
later with the security issues mitigated
and before we begin if you're someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply lar postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schi College of computing the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered it's no secret that the majority
of our internet usage is at the risk of
being hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment K Linux is an
operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution that is
made specifically for penetration
testers K Linux has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson let's take a look at the topics
to be covered in this
video we start by learning about K Linux
and a basic explanation of its purpose
we take a look at the history of K Linux
from the story of its origin to its
current day
exploits next we learn a few distinct
features of Khali that make it an
attractive choice for penetration
testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start a journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general Kali Linux which is formerly
known as backtrack Linux is an
open-source Linux distribution aimed at
Advanced penetration testing and
security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools that are targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering color Linux is a multiple
platform solution accessible and freely
available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users we did not get K Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its
history k Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called wopex which stands for white hat
noex as can be inferred from the name it
was based on the noix operating system
as its underlying OS opix had releases
ranging from version 2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as VX or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name change
was because the base OS was changed from
KNIX to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from warix there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being shorted to just auditor
which was once again using
noix its efforts were combined with wax
to produce backtrack backtrack was based
on slackware from version one to version
three but switched to uban to later on
with version 4 to version 5 using the
experience gained from all of this K
Linux came after backtrack in 2013 khi
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Ki Linux became a
rolling operating
system now that we understand the
history and the purpose of K Linux let
us learn a little more about its
distinct
features the latest version of Khali
comes with more than 600 penetration
tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work or which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality the Kali Linux team is
made up of a small group of individuals
who are the only ones trusted to commit
packages and interact with the
repositories all of which is done using
multiple secure protocols restricting
access of critical code bases to
external asset greatly reduces the risk
of source contamination which can cause
K Linux users worldwide a great deal of
damage as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that Khali's armm support would need to
be as robust as they could manage with
fully working
installations kalii Linux is available
on a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
mainline distributions so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if K
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
the penetration testing Journey the
first way to use scal Linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the K Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the cavar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USBS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations but what if the user want
wants to store data permanently in the
installed OS the best and the most
reliable way to ensure this is the
full-fledged hard disk installation this
will ensure the complete usage of the
system's Hardware capabilities and will
take into account the updates and the
configurations being made to the OS this
method is supposed to override any
pre-existing operating system installed
on the computer be it windows or any
other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtual box the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and K Linux can
be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the alloted
ram to the virtual hard disk
capacity the usage of both a host and
guest operating system like K Linux
allows users a safe environment to learn
while not putting the systems at risk if
you want to learn more about how one can
go forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where K Linux is being
installed on VMware while running on a
Windows 10 operating system you can find
the link in the description box to get
started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install K Linux
is by using a dual boot system to put it
in simple words the K Linux OS will not
be overrating any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boot up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and K Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system now for the convenience
of explanation we're going to install K
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware VMware is able
to run multiple operating systems on a
single host machine which in our case is
a Windows 10
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file you go to get Kali and as you can
see there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended Ed by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems
yet after clicking on the download
button we can see we have a wi archive
which will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already presented with
thing so we can start working on the
VMware side of things once the ISO file
is downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more advanced and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well versed with
virtualization software but for 90% of
the cases typical setup will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later in some operating
systems we can use the ISO file here
directly and VMR will install it for us
but right now in the case of K Linux the
third option is always the
safest K Linux is a Linux distribution
so we can select Linux over here and and
the version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels every distribution has of a
parent distribution for example K Linux
has Debian and there are other
distributions which are based or forked
from some parent distribution kinx is
based of Debian so we can go with the
highest version of Debian which is the
Debian 10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux
so that it'll be easier to recognize the
virtual machine among this list of
virtual machine instances the location
can be any location you decide to put by
default it should be the documents
folder but anywhere you put it will hold
up all the information of the operating
system all the files you download all
the configurations you store everything
will be stored in this particular
location that you
provide when we go next we are asked
about the dis capacity this disc
capacity will be all the storage that
will be provided to your virtual machine
of K Linux think of your Windows device
if you have a 1 TB of hard drive you
have the entirety of the hard disk to
store data on how much data you give
here you can only store up to that
amount of data not to mention some
amount of capacity will be taken up by
the operating system itself to store its
programs and applications for now we can
give around let's say 15 GB of
information or if it's recommended size
for Dean is 20 you can just go ahead at
20 it depends all on the user case if
you're going to use it extensively you
can even go as high as 50 or 60 GB if
you have plans to download many more
applications and perform multiple
different tests another option we get
over here is storing virtual diss as a
single file or storing them into
multiple
files as we already know this virtual
machine run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either system to
system or software to software let's say
if you want to switch from VMware to
Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual L as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine even if you do it's
not a complete stop that it cannot be
ported it's just easier when using
multiple files but in order to get the
best performance out with the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the ISO file yet which
is the installation file for the C Linux
that we downloaded from this
website as of right now we have only
configured the settings of the virtual
machine so we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now to make the changes further we press
on edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine so
devices with ram of 8 GB or below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance issues and the host system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2 GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6gb it'll be
much more difficult for the host system
to run everything properly so for this
instance we can keep it as 2 GB of
memory for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as
well hard disk is preset up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this we're going to select
use ISO image file we're going to click
on
browse going go to downloads and select
the IMO file over
here select
open and you can see it is already
loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine in this screen we can choose how
we want to proceed with the
installation we have a start installer
option over here so we're going to press
enter on
that
you're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system for this we can go
with English as
standard this is a location this will be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings which depend
entirely on the location of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's all
always recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always preferred to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is NE required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the .
ISO file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so
it has a lot of components that need to
be put into the virtual machine which
can also be used to detect
Hardware once the hardware and the
network configuration is done by the ISO
file we want to write a host name for
the system this host name can be
anything which is used to recognize this
device on a local network or a land
cable let's say if we use the name
Kali domain name you we can skip it for
now it's not necessary as such for the
installation this is the full name for
the
user let's say we can provide the name
as simply learn as a full
name next we're going to set up a
username this username is going to be
necessary to identify the user from its
root accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one
123 now we have to choose a password for
the user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator we can use whichever
password we like over
here and use the same password below and
press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here there are multiple
options like the use entire disk use
entire dis and set up lvm this entire
disc can set up encrypted lvm for
newcomers it is recommended to just use
the first one since lvm encryption is
something that you can learn afterwards
when you're much more Hands-On with the
Linux operating system for now we're
going to use use the use entire disg
guided installation and press on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on vmw we had set up a dis
capacity that we gave up prose 20gb that
is the hard disk which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual dis on vmy it acts as a normal
hard disk on which an operating system
can be installed so we select this one
and press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system all the operating
systems that are installed have
different components one is used for the
a keeping of the applications one for
the files other for the RAM management
and other things for newcomers it is
always recommended to keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on
continue this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1 G GB
used for swap memory now these kind of
naming can be confusing for people who
are not well versed with Linux operating
systems or in general virtualization but
for now you can go ahead and press on
continue as this will be fine we can
press on finish partitioning and write
changes to disk and
continue it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it's so that scsi3 is our
virtual hard disk of 20gp dis
capacity write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine machine with only 2GB of
RAM we're going to speed up this part of
the video so we don't have to waste any
more time just watching the progress
bar now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager
the work of a package manager on Linux
operating system is similar to the
Google Play Store on Android mobile
devices and on the app store for the
Apple
devices it's an interface to install
external applications which are not
installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the
internet at this point of time it's ask
us to select a network mirror we're
going to select as yes and move forward
with this next it's going to ask us for
an http proxy which we can leave it as
blank and press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the Kali Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest
version now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the graub boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press
continue remember the installation was
conducted on dev
SDA so we're going to select
installation of the gr loader on the
same hard disk that we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the graub boot loader is
being installed install the graub is
highly essential because it it shows the
motherboard where to start the operating
system from even if the operating system
is installed correctly and all the files
are in correct order the absence of a
boot loader will not be able to launch
the OS
properly as you can see the installation
is finally complete so now we can press
on
continue and it's going to finalize the
Chang
this now you can see K Linux being
booted up straight away it doesn't check
for the ISO file anymore since the
operating system is now installed onto
the virtual hard disk storage that we
had configured
before here we're going to enter our
username and password that we had set up
before
and we have the coloro system booted
up and this is your homepage we can see
the installed applications over here
which are being used for penetration
testing by multiple security analysts
worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with K
Linux and others can be installed using
the AP package manager that we had
configured you can see a full name over
here and with this our installation of
the K Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of getting
hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration test
testing has become the norm when it
comes to vulnerability assessment par
security OS is an operating system that
has become a welln weapon in this fight
against hackers a l distribution more
cater towards penetration testers
specifically parent security has layers
of features that we will be covering in
today's lesson let's take a look at the
topics for this
video we start by learning about what
par security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to K Linux for penetration
testers next we take a look at the
minimum system requirements necessary to
obtain Optimum performance from an
installation of parot security moving on
we learn about some unique features that
make parot Stand Out Among the multiple
ethical hacking operating systems
available on the market and finally we
look at the multiple ways that par
security OS can be installed be it on a
single system or for portable
media so let's start out by learning
what parro security
is paratos is a deban based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux kernel while
being founded in
2013 par security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbies it features a distinct forens
six mode that does not Mount any of the
system hard diss or partitions and has
no influence in the host system making
it more stealy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures in software development a
rolling release is a paradig time in
which software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions this ensures that the software
is constantly up to date rolling release
distribution such as parro security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market the basic introduction to the
operating system out of the way let us
have a look at the bare minimum system
requirements necessary to be able to run
this operating
system for first up we got a CPU
requirement which states that a 1 GHz
dual core CPU is the absolute minimum in
order to use bar OS while multiple core
systems will provide more Optimum
performance a small beginner has been
included a very distinct thing to be
noted is that the operating system can
be installed on all variants of chipsets
be 32-bit 64-bit and the newly popular
armm portfolio of
devices unlike K Linux which requires
some amount of graphical acceleration
needed to display the operating system
correctly paratos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of
machines taking into account the ram
issue a minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free
Ram provides the optimum usage
scenarios even when the OS is installed
on a hard drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB of
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box when it comes to booting
options we have the option of going with
the Legacy BIOS settings or with the
more modern ufi settings these are just
some of the requirements for the
installation of parro security OS to
understand this process more vividly and
to learn how visualization can help
install an OS in our existing computer
please follow the link to a parot
security installation video linked right
above let's understand what some of the
things that make parot security unique
among all the other penetration testing
operating
systems along with all the giant catalog
of scripts par security has its own
custom hardened Linux Cal which has been
modified explicitly to provide as much
security and resistance to hackers as
possible as a first line of defense the
configurations in the operating system
act as a second Gateway taking care of
malitia requests and dropping them off
this is particularly beneficial since
should there be a scenario where the
latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the paratto development
team will most likely iren it out first
before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardened kernel
wasn't reasoning enough parid security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Gali Linux
users all the tools you found in Gali
are present in parto and then a few
extra ones for good measure this has
been achieved while keeping roughly the
same size of the installation file
between both operating systems
systems however it's not all
productivity points for parro OS they
provide a choice between two different
desktop environments the M desktop which
comes pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system being highly modular in nature
one can use K Linux or parat Os while
adding another text of environment which
they find appealing while Kali has only
a single option parat has managed to
provide two optimized Wills with made
desktop and KD desktop ready made on the
website one of the primary advantages of
parro os over Kali is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes frequently less dis space and
computing power to function properly
with as little as 320 MB of ram required
in reality parat OS is also designed to
operate successfully off a USB stick but
Kali leux does not work well from a USB
stick and is generally installed in a
virtual machine parat can be seen as
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than K
Linux there are multiple ways to go
about with this
installation many people prefer to
install it directly onto a hard disk
where the parad security OS will
override whichever data the hard disk
already has now this is beneficial if
you want to preserve your data for the
long term but this might pause some
trouble to people who do not have a
spare hard disk or do not want to lose
their current installation of Windows
operating system another way to use par
security is by using the live boot but
whatever changes you make to the live
boot operating system those changes are
removed the moment we restart or shut
down the
system a very good Common Ground between
both these installations is
virtualization using virtualization
software like VMware or virtual box we
can install parad security on our
systems while simultaneously saving our
data and having the convenience of a
host machine such as a Windows operating
system in case things go
wrong to start the installation we first
need to get a ISO file for the par
security operating system this can be
found on the current
website parats sec.org
once we enter the website move into the
download
section and select the get security
addition over
here par security OS has multip desktop
environments to you to choose from these
desktop environments serves as a
different user interface for the user
for example right now we have the M
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to
them for our example let's go with the m
desktop we have two options either we
can go with the direct download or we
can get the torrent file for this
example if you press on the download
button
and our download will start I have
already downloaded this file but the ISO
file provided over here will serve as an
installation it will have around 4 and2
GB of space it will be used to install
this operating system in
VMware once the file is downloaded we
can close this and open VMware
Workstation VMware can also be used as a
player version or the Workstation
version if you have much more
familiarity with using virtual box for
virtualization ation application we can
use that as
well once the VMware is open we click on
file and select a new virtual
machine for the first time installation
we're going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine oses going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with the
typical option
moving on it'll ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from since we're going to use a live ISO
first we're going to select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later and press
next as we already know parent security
is a deban derivative so When selecting
the guest operating system type we're
going to go with Linux and the selection
we're going to choose whichever the
highest version of Debian is along with
the 64bit
OS we're going to click on next we're
going to name our virtual machine let's
say par security
OS we're going to select the location
where we want to save the virtual
machine this will have all the hard dis
of the operating system
installation we're going to click on
next for the dis size we're going to
specify how much of the current memory
are we going to allocate this is the
hard disk memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage you
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20gb as
written when given the choice of storing
the virtual dis as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable
people change systems and sometimes they
want to swap their instances between the
work and their personal computer if
there is no portability in mind storing
the virtual dis as a single file gives
the best performance and should be the
recommended go-to when installing for
the first time we click on next here and
it's going to give us a summary of the
settings we have already settled till
now going to press on
finish and there we go we have our
install ation First Step
completed here on out we're going to
click on edit virtual machine
settings here we're going to have a look
at some of the requirements that the
parot security OS will need it is known
to be a memory lightweight operating
system but just to have the most Optimum
performance we're going to provide
around 2 GB of RAM from our host system
which is a Windows 10
machine when it comes to the processors
I'm going to increase it to two and the
number of codes to two as as well so
giving out a total four processor CES to
the operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at
hand hardest size has already been set
at 20gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on one thing that
we need to make sure is selecting the CD
DVD IDE here we have to use a ISO image
file over here previously it should be
used physical drive and at Auto detect
we're going to use a use ISO image file
over here we're going to click on
browse we're going to go to where we
have downloaded the ISO file which is
over here and select
it press okay
here and we can now power on this
virtual
machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode to get a better user
experience we're going to go with the
try install mode specifically press
enter and it's going to start the live
boot ISO meanwhile vmw has an prompt
over here where it will try to install
some VMware tools on it while this is
not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we're going to close this
prompt as you can see this is the live
boot ISO of the parat security operating
system currently it's running the mat
desktop as we have downloaded in the
website the live boot ISO is necessary
to get a good feel of the operating
system there are many good Linux dros
that have this live boot option so that
you can give a try of the operating
system before installing
permanently once you into the live board
we can start up with the installation
using the shortcut as you can see
install parot
going to double click
it and this is a calaris installer
choose your language as American
English and press
next you can select your time zone
according to your
location C and we can go
next at this point of time you have to
choose the correct keyboard now what
many people go get confused is choosing
their own language keyboard but people
must keep in mind is what keyboard the
laptop
provides most of the systems that come
pre-build provide the English US
keyboard so whatever keyboard you choose
make sure to type here and test that all
the buttons including the superscript
and the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this
step once you settled on the key
keyboard that you need to install can go
ahead here it will ask you to select
storage device and the only option you
are going to get is the amount of hard
disk storage you have given in the
virtual machine settings we have already
provided 20gb of storage we're going to
choose that and we're going to erase
this
disk manual partitioning can be useful
when you're going to install parad
security on an operating system or on a
hard disk where it is already including
a Windows OS for now we're going to
select erase disk and press next we're
going to give our full name Let It Be
simply
learn you can give the name of the
computer and this is the username which
we will use to log
in this is your root password that we
going to give over here the root
password of this C Linux will act as the
administrative access and it will be
necessary for making changes to the
system or install installing and
updating
software enter the password and repeat
it over
here you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this
disabled click on next this is another
summary of the installation that we
going to move forward with have a look
that whatever changes we have made is
according to your requirements and once
everything is checked you can press on
install click on install
now and we're going to let it complete
the
work as you can see the installation of
parro security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here
disabled I'm going to click on
done we're going to shut down this live
boot
ISO going to click on
menu turn off the
device and shut
down we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO
file please remove the live medium and
press enter to continue we can just
press enter to
continue and it's going to shut down now
to move on we're going to click on edit
virtual machine
settings going to CD DVD and we're going
to use physical drive now we're going to
remove it from the ISA image file
because the installation has already
been completed and we don't want to use
the same ISO file again and again by
using physical Drive over here it's
going to detect the 20 GB hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it going to
press
okay and we're going to power on this
virtual machine for
testing make sure this you click s over
here this is the grub menu at this we
get different choices for example which
NVIDIA drivers off or with some other
Advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press
enter if you remember clearly we did not
get the option of try install or a
terminal run just like we did in the
live boot ISO since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the OS
directly now with the login screen you
can see our username over here as we
provided in the
installation we're going to enter our
root
password and press
Center and this is a currently working
desktop of the par security operating
system we can open the terminal over
here and we're going to try a root
password and
installation to install any software
we're going to use the keyword suit
APD install and Neo
fetch we're going to use the root
password that we used to log
in going to press y for
yes this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had
provided
now that we have installed neof fetch we
can write the command new
Fetch and this is going to give us some
information about our
installation you can see the OS name as
parro OS 4.11 is running on a VMware
host the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once and some other things
you can see the memory is supposed to be
1951 MB which is supposed to equal
around 2 GB of RAM usage that we had
provided K Linux and parat Os are two
popular penetration testing
distributions while these operating
systems each have unique offerings the
overall Choice can differ between
Personnel thanks to the various tools
and Hardware specifications today we
will look at both these distributions
and settle on the perfect choice for
each type of user let's go through the
agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pirot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers next we know
about some features of these operating
systems that stand out of their
package finally we directly compare k
and parro security OS thereby making a
clear-cut conclusion on which OS is
perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open- Source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiplatform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and a
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the K Linux desktop
while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at parent
security operating
system paret security OS is a Dean based
Linux distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on the demian's testing branch and
uses a custom hardened Linux
Kernel parot Security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer
forensics reverse engineering and
security research it is seen as a
generally lightweight distri
distribution that can work under
rigorous hardware and software
specifications it features a distinct
forensic mode that does not Mount any of
the systems hard diss or partitions and
has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to execute forensic
procedures a rolling release is a
paradigm in which software upgrades are
rolled out constantly rather than in
batches of versions and software
development this this ensures that the
software is constantly up to date a
rolling release distribution such as
parate security OS follows the same
concept it provides the most recent
Linux kernel and software versions as
soon as they become
available with the basic introduction to
the operating systems out of the way let
us take a look at the unique features of
both K Linux and parat security
OS the latest version of K Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar
functionality the K Linux team comprises
a small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure prot
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external assets
dramatically reduces the risk of source
contamination which can cause C Linux
users worldwide a great deal of damage
as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Kali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a Str
strong hold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that Khali's
armm support would need to be as robust
as they could manage with fully working
installations Kali Linux is available on
a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
mainline distribution so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts parad security OS has its own
hardened Linux kernel modified
explicitly to provide as much security
and resistance to hackers as possible in
the first line of defense the
configurations in the operating system
Act is the second Gateway taking care of
malicious requests and dropping them off
this is particularly beneficial since
should there be a scenario where the
latex Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the paratos development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardal kernel
wasn't reason enough paret security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and Scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure and this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
operating system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a
choice between two different desktop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a
distribution being highly modular in
nature one can use par security OS while
adding another desktop environment that
they find appealing while K Linux has
only a single option par security has
provided two optimized bills with made
desktop and KD
desktop one of the primary advantages of
parro os over K Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less disk space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality paratto is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB drive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine parat is
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than K
Linux features are great but what about
performance real world metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and
usability in the end we can decide on
what distribution is fit for each type
of
user for our first point of comparison
let's take a look at the ram required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature RAM usage is a very
important facet while khux demands at
least 1 GB of RAM par security can
operate optimally with a minimum of 320
MB of
RAM for correctly displaying graphical
elements K Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parro security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the users
side once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos they take up a minimum amount of
hard disk storage both of these
operating systems have a recommended dis
storage of minimum of 20gb in K Linux
and a minimum of 15 GB in parro security
so they can install all the tools
necessary in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has
always always been the first in securing
every single tool available for hackers
in the penetration testing industry par
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless pen
testing par security makes it a point
that all the tools that K Linux provides
has been included in the iso while
simultaneously adding some extra tools
that many users will have to install
from third party sources in K
Linux
being a decade old penetration testing
distribution K Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature par Security on the other hand
is still growing and it is garnering
much more interest among veteran
penetration testers and ethical
hackers a primary drawback of K Linux is
the extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than par security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hard dis Storage parro
security on the other hand was initially
designed to run off a USB drive directly
thereby requiring very minimal
requirements from a hardware perspective
like just 320 MB of RAM and no graphical
acceleration needed this means parro
security is much more feasible for
people who are not able to devort
massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk
directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with
parot security if they want to go with a
very lightweight and lean distribution
that can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on G
Linux it is much more suitable for
underpowered DS where users do not have
a lot of Hardware resources to provide
to the operating system and thereby it
is much more feasible for people with
underpowered laptops or no graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux par
Securities desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking par
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and to the various toools without having
to dump them into the entire intricacies
with ethical hacking and penetration
testing becoming mainstream and
corporate environments train personnel
and relevant equipment are in high
demand the right software framework can
be the Tipping Point in a hacking
Campaign which deals with intricate
Hardware one such tool that has become a
main stay for decades is nmap when it
comes to scanning machines for open
ports and services nmap has always been
the first choice for hackers being
lightweight and open source nmap has
strong Community backing and receives
regular
updates let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about the different
phases in ethical hacking and where nmap
is most valuable to ethical hackers we
learn the basics of nmap and its purpose
during a penetration testing
campaign next we take a look at the top
level approach of nmap as a scanning
tool and how it conducts these scans on
host
machines moving
on we cover the multiple modes and types
of scans that can be performed using
nmap on unsuspecting
users we also look at some Alternatives
that users can prefer if nmap is not
something they are comfortable with
while a live demonstration of the powers
of nmap will help in shedding light on
the topics being taught
today let us first understand where and
why and map is
essential there are essentially five
phases in ethical hacking the
reconnaissance phase is the first phase
of the penetration test here the
security researcher collects information
about the target it can be done actively
or pass ly or both it helps security
firms gather information about the
target system Network components active
machines Etc this activity can be
performed by using the information
publicly available and by using
different
tools the scanning phase is more tool
oriented rather than being performed
manually the tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the Target by using various
scanners such as war dialers port
scanners Network mappers and
vulnerability scanners the pentry iion
tester collects as many vulnerabilities
which help in turn to attack a Target in
a more sophisticated
manner in the gaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to establish a
connection with the Target and exploit
the vulnerabilities found in the
previous phase the exploitation may be a
buffer overflow attack denial of service
attack session hijacking and many more
basically the penetration tester
extracts information and sensitive data
from the servers by gaining access with
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
back door for himself it helps him to
identify hidden vulnerabilities in the
system while allowing him to come back
to the system to retrieve more data
further
on in the clearing tracks phase the
tester tries to remove all logs and
Footprints which might help the
administrator identify his presence this
helps a tester to think like a hacker
and perform corrective actions to
mitigate those
activities nmap is most beneficial in
the early stages of ethical hacking
where a hacker must figure the possible
entry point to a system it is necessary
to know this before running the
necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage any insecure
openings and breach the device so the
reconnaissance and the scanning phase
are the points where nmap finds the most
use let us now understand what nmap is
from a Layman's
perspective nmap which stands for
network mapper is a free and open source
utility for network discovery and
security auditing many systems and
network administrators also find it
useful for tasks such as Network
inventory managing service upgrade
schedules and monitoring host and
service uptime the program is most
commonly used via a command line
interface and is available for many
different operating systems such as
Linux free PSD and
gentu it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits nmap was developed for
Enterprise scale networks and can scan
through thousands of connected devices
however in recent years nmap is being
increasingly used by smaller companies
as well nmap uses raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what host are
available on the network what services
these host are offering what operating
systems they are running what type of
packet filters and firewalls are in use
and dozens of other
characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fine against single hor as well the rise
of the iot in particular now means that
networks used by these companies have
become more complex and therefore harder
to secure since every application that
connects to a network needs to do so via
a port the wrong port or server
configuration can open a can of forms
that leads to a thorough breach of the
system the recent emergence of iot Bot
Nets like meai has also simulated
interest in N map not least because of
its ability to interrogate devices
connected via the UPnP protocol but also
to highlight any devices that may be
malicious now that we understand what
nmap is let us take a look at the
workflow of how an ethical hacker uses
this tool in penetration
testing at a practical level nmap is
used to provide detailed real-time
information on your networks and other
devices connected to them we have the
hacker running nmap on a system with a
victim machine running a standard
installation of the operating system be
it Windows Mac OS or
Linux the map interface will send
specially crafted package to generate
some reply from the victim machine the
victim machine in return will send some
information back to the nmap host with
replying some of the services and host
that are being run on the computers nmap
allows the network admins to find which
devices are running discover some open
ports and other services this in turn
help discover the vulnerabilities and
the possible entry points for hackers to
breach
into we are now aware of how and Map
works on a basic level but there are
many varieties of cans that users can
run on local
machines let's take a look at some of
them the Ping sweep is a simple type of
nmap scan where it pings to all the
available IP addresses to check which
IPS respond to icmp protocol if the
users need to know only the number of IP
addresses and not many details the Ping
sweep is very useful it's fast and hence
the results to be known are fetched very
easily
the SN scan is the most useful type of
end map scan which does work very
quietly it sends an SN packet via the
TCP protocol or the transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgement pack is received to the
system it is sure that a port is opened
there no response means that the port is
either closed or not available here the
acknowledgement pack is not sent back to
the system assuming that the connection
is not valid the scan is not shown in
most of the scan law L and hence it is
safe to use SN scan to identify the open
ports the TCP connect scan is similar to
SN scan in many aspects as it uses the
TCP layer to send packets and is passed
to all the ports here the difference is
that the full connection is done by
setting the acknowledgement back at back
the logs can easily find the TCP scan
and need more power from the machines to
do the work but it is more
accurate if all the accesses related to
the OS are available to the user it is
better to do a TCP scan than an S scan
as all the lowlevel and high level
accesses are required for the scan the
network is also loaded more and hence
users must be careful about overloading
the system and the
networks the idle scan is really used to
check whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular
Network users need not control the
external host but an IP address and a
port should be given to the same all
other requirements are taken from the
scanner itself
the RPC scans or remote procedure calls
are done by hackers to make the system
vulnerable to virus attacks it is thus
necessary to know whether our systems
answer such calls and make our system
open to
malware RPC scan is done to check this
by finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by
RPC the windows scan is a simple scan
where the application scans the
acknowledgement packets received from
the polls once the SN packets are sent
if there are any abnormalities in the AK
packets received the scan reports the
same and helps in recognizing which
ports are functioning in a different
manner the bound scan is used to check
the security in the file transfer
protocol layer FTP layers mostly do not
accept any packets and once it is
rejected from the FTP layers there are
chances that it might be sent to an
internal layer so that it can access the
internal machines bounce can check this
loophole by doing exactly the same
process and identifies whether our FTP
layer is open to vulnerability or
not the the F scan is similar to SN scan
where the system that sends the packets
receives the response back and it will
be mostly be a TCP F packet if the
system sends an RSD packet it is a false
alarm and users need not be worried
about the
same the null scan is useful for other
systems than Windows where the systems
can easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either TCP packets are null responses
null scans are not useful for Windows as
they may not always produce the design
results when it comes to looking at
Alternatives there's a wide range of
free network monitoring utilities as
well as free open source vulnerability
scanners available to network
administrators and security
Auditors what makes nmap stand out as
the tool it and network security
managers need to know is its flexibility
and
power there are some alternatives to
nmap but most of them are focused on
providing specific Niche functionality
than the average system administrator
does need frequently
M scan for instance is much faster than
nmap but provides less detail in reality
however nmap provides all the
functionality and speed that the average
user requires especially when used along
with other similar tools like netc cap
which can be used to manage and control
Network traffic and zenmap which
provides a graphical user interface for
nmap but as an allrounder solution to
network scanning nobody can go wrong
with nmap as their tool of
choice let's now take a tour of nmap
based on all the things we have covered
today in this live demonstration we
start by learning on how to install nmap
on a fresh operating system that doesn't
come pre-installed with the tool we also
cover the different types of scans that
can be run on local machines along with
checking multiple inferences an ethical
hacker can gather based on the scan
output of an nmap screen finally we run
scans on vulnerable machines to get an
idea of how to proceed with the outputs
We Gather using this too if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more the
first step in our demonstration is
installing n map now it depends heavily
on what Linux distribution you're going
to use to perform ethical hacking right
now I'm using parot security operating
system if you're not aware of what parot
security is or even what K Linux is we
highly suggest that you check out the
videos of those two operating systems on
our YouTube channel so that you can get
a fair idea of what they serve now if
you are using any of these two operating
systems nmap should come pre-installed
by default to check if nmap is
pre-installed or not you can just press
on applications over here go to the pen
testing
section go to this information gathering
Tab and you should be able to see nmap
right here now let's say you do not have
nmap pre-installed maybe you're using a
Linux distribution like Ubuntu or Linux
Min or something that is based on depn
operating systems one thing you have to
make sure that nmap should be in the
distribution repository once you check
that or even if you do not know if it is
present you can just this command should
be Pudo which is to give root
permissions for installation a AP is the
package manager of all Linux
distributions that are based on Debian
that goes for Deb and stable ubu Linux
Min K Linux par security and anything of
that
nature AP is the package manager which
handles the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems once you're here just write
install and end map press enter and it's
going to ask you for the root password
that you said when you install the
operating system in the first place
enter your root password and press enter
again again as you can see it's saying
that nmap is already installed the
newest version since I'm running parro
security operating system now should you
be running this operating system or even
K Linux you should receive a similar
message and the installation is already
done if you are using some other
distribution let's say even black o Arch
Linux or Manjaro anything like that the
installation steps will be slightly
different this pseudo AP install nmap
command is for distrib tions that are
derived from Debian and abantu if you
want to install in Arch Linux based
distributions you have to use their
package manager which is known as
pamac but that is for a different step
and if you want to get an ethical
hacking the best way to start is by
learning either K Linux or par security
now that the installation is done we're
going to learn how to use nmap one of
the most basic functions of nmap is to
identif Iden ify active hosts on the
network we can do this by using a ping
scan the ping scan identifies all of the
IP addresses that are currently online
without sending any packets to these
hosts now to run the ping scan we're
going to write end map the flag we're
going to mention over here is sp now
these flags are the
different traits of the nmap scan
depending on what flag we use we can
send different kinds of requests to the
host that we are scanning
now before moving forward with this let
me open another terminal over here and
check the IP
address we're going to write the command
if config and find the Subnet in which
this system is present as you can see
the IP address is
192.168
72131 now this operating system is being
run on a virtual machine software known
as VMware the VMware in itself is
running on a Windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network this IP address is of par
security and the Windows operating
system which is the host system in my
scenario will fall in this particular
subnet so to run our
scan we're going to Target 19
192.168 and
72.1
24 this command then Returns the list of
hosts on your network and the total
number of assigned IP
addresses this is going to be capital P
yeah if you spot any host or IP
addresses on that list that you cannot
account for you can then run further
commands to investigate them further as
of right now you can see the machine
that is the parot security this IP
address can be detected in the subnet
the
192.168 72.1 is my local Windows machine
that is running VMware software and
ultimately this virtual machine the 72.2
is the DHCP server that hosts the
internet connection of the par security
this we can ignore for now now the
Windows machine that we have over here
let's run some tests on that going to
clear our
terminal and we can close this actually
when scanning hosts nmap commands can
use server names ipv4 addresses or IPv6
addresses a basic nmap
command will produce information about
the given host to run a basic port scan
we can just use n map along with the IP
now as you remember the IP is
192.168 72.1 this is the IP of my local
Windows 10
machine
as you can see it shows the ports that
are open and the particular servers that
these ports are
running now you can also have a
detection of the operating system now
mind you this is not 100% correct and
the reliability depends on the
installation and what kind of
fingerprinting measures are available
now since this does TCP IP
fingerprinting it needs some extra
permissions the flag that we going to
use is n map minus o along with the same
IP
address like I said since this a TCP I
finger printing it requires root
privileges now to provide root
privileges we're just going to add the N
map and pseudo
keyword going to repeat the same command
that we wrote
above as you can see it has successfully
detected that I am running Microsoft
Windows
10 with this Mac
address it has also shown the correct
build number of the Windows 10 system
that I am
using this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated now to get the necessary
information about these services for
example what versions they are using we
have a command known as SV which stand
for service version we use the same IP
address and press
center now as you can see the scan is
complete and if you can check the
results of the scan above here we don't
see any version number for the
services here
we can actually check what version they
are running now this becomes helpful
when we are trying to find specific
versions to exploit for example if VM
workstation 16. 1.2 had some particular
vulnerability we can exploit it by
checking this
command apart from the host scanning
Port scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are few ways that this
command can be customized as well for
example I've already checked that the
443 command is open but I have found out
after running this lengthy scan let's
say I only want to check if command if
the port 443 is open and map I'm going
to use
the flag of minus P which stands for
port and give 443 as an argument
here using the same IP
address and you can see it says it's
open
but we already knew it is open let's say
there was something else uh if let's say
we're going to scan if the Apache web
server port is open which usually runs
on
80 obviously since I'm not running an
Apache web server it says it's
closed now we can combine these two
commands by running both Port
simultaneously to do that we can just
put a
comma and complete the rest
similarly expected 80 is closed and 443
is open another feature of end map for
Port scanning is showing of ranges now
ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example n map minus P we're going to
check what ports are open between 1 100
to let's say
2,000 this acts as a
range everything else is the
same and it checks all ports in the
range of 100 to
2,000 whatever ports is open in between
that range it can be mentioned over
here we're going to clear the scen now
another flag that can be used with n map
is the SS command this runs a stealth
scan which is a little harder to detect
if you're the it admin of the system
that is being
scanned the results will more or less be
the same although this will need
elevated root
privileges
2.1 as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan just adds an
extra mac address as well for good
measure but like I said it's more about
the stealth the normal scans usually are
easier to detect when the logs are being
checked sty scans are relatively tougher
to check on much more intricate systems
this takes longer as
well now that we're done with both
scanning let's look at a vulnerable
machine the system that is scanning
right now is this my own personal system
with everything is pretty locked down as
much as it can
be there is an attack box
running in the cloud the IP address of
which is over here now to be able to get
into this network we need to connect to
their personal network using a VPN so
what I'm going to do is switch to a
different workspace over here I'm going
to open our
terminal and if you can see over here
there is a hack test. ovpn file I'm
going to connect to their VPN network
using this ovpn
file
and once we get the initialization
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been
established like we discussed this is
the vulnerable device IP we're going to
copy
this and we're going to try to Ping this
let's open a new terminal we're going to
try to Ping this and check if we are
able to reach this
machine and as you can see we're getting
a reply back which means we are now part
of the local network where the
vulnerable machine is
present let's run a service scan map
with the respective
versions We ran the similar scan on my
local machine but we were able to detect
what version each service was
running what we're going to do over here
is by checking what kind of services are
open on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we're going to see if in
map alone can point us to a Direction
Where We can gain access to the
machine as you can see the scan is now
completed and we have some of the ports
that are being opened over here and what
kind of service they are
running now like we discussed this is
the first stage or sometimes even the
second stage of ethical
hacking what we can infer from here is
what are the services that are being run
now these two ports 139 and 445 are
actually Windows SMB server ports which
are above the windows Samba server now
every service has a particular put
attached to it that will be consistent
whichever machine you may use Apache
server will always run on Port 80 SM SMB
servers will function on these two
ports now SMB servers have had a
vulnerability known as the Eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known as
of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not but
since it has the SMB server open it's
worth a shot that pre try that exploit
on this
machine now to start the exploit on this
we're going to open another terminal
over
here and we're going to use Metasploit
for trying the exploit there we're going
to write pseudo msf
console msf console is the keyword first
launching the Metasploit
console enter the root password and wait
for met plit to Launch
other than the ports we can also see
that it has checked the host name of the
system and the operating system as
well now that the metas spit is
open we're going to launch the exploit
now before launching we're going to have
to check what exploits are there for the
Eternal blue
vulnerability you're going to write use
exploit blue and we're going to check
what kind of results we are getting over
here as you can
see serial number n exploit Windows SMB
ms710 Eternal blue it was first
disclosed in
2017 and SMB remote kernel pool
corruption let's say we're going to use
this particular exploit now all of this
may be confusing if you're not aware of
Metasploit but remember this is the next
stage of ethical hacking which comes
into the gaining access part we're going
to use exploit number nine as we found
above to use exploit number
nine we're going to set a p
load which is our malicious code that
will run on the victim
machine now we're going to
check some options as you can see it has
by default pointed it to the 445 Port
since that is the port where SMB server
can be accessed
from the parameter that's missing over
here is our host the r host is the IP
address of the vulnerable machine
basically the machine in which we want
to attack now I'm going to use the set
command to set the IP
address now if we
check we now
have a vicm IP address
set another parameter that we can change
is the lhost this is basically the IP
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access now if you have
remember we had connected using a VPN so
we're going to be assigned a new IP
according to the VPN so if you write if
config and check this one T10 is the VPN
adapter this is our IP address that we
have been assigned in the server in the
network where the vulnerable machine is
present so we're going to copy this IP
address we to move over this
workspace and we're going to set
lhost with that IP
address with that our options are set
now we're going to run
exploit and it's going to check if samb
server vulnerability is
present as you can see it has written
that the target is vulnerable to this
particular exploit it's going to send
the malicious code and the malicious
code is set in the payload that you sent
above
and we now have the shell command of the
Windows
machine as you can see see Windows
system
32 to be sure that this is in fact this
Windows machine that is being used we're
going to write ip config which is a
Windows only shell
command as you can see this is the IP
address that was assigned to the victim
victim machine
now while the major part of this process
was done on
Metasploit we would not have reach the
stage had we not found out that the 139
and 445 ports are open which basically
pointed us that we can try the Eternal
blue exploit of the windows Samba
servers similarly all the scans that we
run serve as a preface to the actual
stages or the actual hacking stages of
the campaigns
this SV command was necessary because we
could check what are the exact services
that are being running in some cases if
if it Apache server is being run there
are particular versions which have
particular exploits those exploits will
not work on other versions so we're
going to have to check what particular
version is being run and accordingly
apply the exploit that can be done in
the Met exploit or you can run some
other tool but what exact exploit we
have have to run and which vulnerability
we have to Target that is where nmap
comes to help with the world moving
towards the next generation of computer
hardware the software side of things
still has a lot left to be discovered
with the majority of laptops coming with
Windows pre-installed many users are
devoid of the Linux operating system
experience which is more resource
friendly than the mainstream operating
systems it can be attributed to the
difficulty people used to face when
installing a new operating system like
Linux in the old days
however a lot of these issues are fixed
nowadays thanks to the big names like
Debian and Ubuntu who have been
instrumental in making Linux based
operating systems as userfriendly as
possible but which one of them is better
for you let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today as we answer this
question for
you we start by learning about the
operating systems from a Layman's
perspective and uncovering the basic
offerings of both
entities next we cover the unique
features fees of both Ubuntu and Debian
and how they stack up against each other
and other industry
counterparts moving on we take a look at
some pointers before installing each of
these operating systems and the
respective download
links finally We compare the contrasting
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
infer the kind of users each OS skaters
to so let's start by learning about
Ubuntu and Debian in
general
Ubuntu is an open- Source free Linux
distribution it is an operating system
for cloud computing in accordance with
support with open stack Ubunto is
developed by the canonical community and
it is freely available also canonica
limited is responsible for the funding
of Ubuntu basically uban is released
every 6 months free support is available
for 9 months after every release and
long-term support which are the LTS is
released every 2 years the first release
of obun was in October
2004 you must have heard about uban 2 no
matter what it is the most popular Linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for Linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start of course Ubuntu
managed to simplify the Linux experience
years back and that is the reason why it
is still so popular even with several
impressive Linux distributions available
right now every new release is more
polished and comes loaded with new
features and
improvements thanks to its huge user
base a number of software vendors have
made the applications compatible with
one2 while the catalog may not be as
extensive as Windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
advantage of Linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open-source alternatives to Major
proprietary software by lacking some
Polish and overall featur set most
alternatives are enough to get the job
done for majority of the users the
never-ending Community Support also
helps in troubleshooting should things
go wrong at any point in
time the default desktop environment in
ubo is gome or a Unity the unity is a
modern desktop environment with a
powerful Search tool for finding all
your applications and documents with its
base setup as noome it integrates well
with common applications such as audio
players video players and social media
there are a few other desktop
environments for open to as well with
unity as its Flagship
environment Debian on the other hand is
a free operating system for your
computer which started in 1996 and is
maintained by global
contributors if the operating system a
set of basic programs and utilities that
make your computer run its core is the
kernel the kernel is the most
fundamental program on the computer
Debian uses the Linux kernel a complete
completely free piece of software which
was started by Linus stals and supported
by thousands of programmers worldwide a
large part of the basic tools that fill
out the operating system come from the
gnu project and those rules are free as
well Debian is the mother of reux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good-looking drro is so
popular inside the Linux developers
Community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful UI later
on they found out the power of after
using a bunch of distributions from
other developers you'll be surprised to
know that almost all other popular
consumer level dros are based on Debian
even U it is so stable and featur Rich
that the developers find it easy to
build their Dr based on Debian rather
than building it from
scratch Debian is run and maintained on
its GitHub repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
CommunityWide feedback and holistic
approach to open source development of
the Debian operating system thanks to
this variety of personnel the source
code of Debian comprises around 70
different programming and scripting
languages Debian supports all kinds of
graphical environments ranging from full
feature desktop environments to lighter
Alternatives and even minimalist window
managers ubo ships with unity desktop by
default where the package manager can
install the gome environment if needed
while also including cinnamon lxd xfc
KDE and mate on the other hand Debian
gives you the choice of choosing which
desktop environment you want from the
getg go by providing ISO files for each
desktop environment
individually now that we understand
where both these operating systems stand
let us take a look at some of the best
features offered by each of these
distributions UB 2 is the closest this
thing to a household name among desktop
Linux distributions it is a great
distribution to start with and it's even
a great distribution to keep using after
you're more experienced if you're happy
with it it is user friendly in a lot of
ways it provides a simple desktop has an
easy installer and provides a checkbox
during the installation process that
will automatically install Flash plugins
and various codecs that you will need
for multimedia support there's an
additional drivers tool that will detect
closed Source or propriety drivers that
might be necessary to get all your
Hardware work working and easily install
them for
you one2 is produced by canonical and
their friends it is run as an open
project to enable others with diverse
ideas to benefit from all the work the
developers do to deliver the world's
best open platform still canonical is
responsible for delivering six monthly
Milestone releases and regular LTS
releases from Enterprise production news
Enterprises can count on canonical to
support secure and manage uban
infrastructure and devices with more
than 500 employees in over 39 countries
the company underpins the critical
infrastructure for thousands of
businesses and millions of obun users
around the
world Unity desktop was originally
developed by canonical and introduced
earlier for Netbook computers with uban
2 10.10 then it went on to be the
default desktop environment for uban 2
eventually it has been Dro by canonical
and replaced by gnome however it has
made a come back after uban to
18.04 while being completely stable the
HUD and Global menu hold up just fine
with major applications such as lib
office Thunderbird and other web
browsers that means that the unity
desktop works as it is supposed to while
making you more productive when some
desktop environments have a steep
learning curve Unity is very intuitive
for new users in spite of deviating from
the traditional start menu format that
the windows users are generally
accustomed
to
the calamaras installer is a framework
by design it is very customizable in
order to satisfy a wide variety of needs
and use cases calamaras aims to be easy
usable beautiful pragmatic and more
importantly distribution agnostic
calamaras includes an advanced
partitioning feature as well which
supports for both manual and automated
partitioning operations it is the first
installer with an automated replace
partition option which makes it easy to
reuse a part over and over for
distribution
testing coming to Debian it is a
community distribution through and
through it's governed by a board of
elected developers it has its own
internal structure and laws and just
about everyone working on it is a
volunteer making it completely Community
Driven it is maintained and developed by
programmers and developers all around
the world this form of development
ensures continuity if one of the
developers decides to stop working on
the project another developer might come
come in and take place and keep the
project going on it is completely free
of centralized control and this is also
one of the reasons for an undecided
stable release cycle Debian Sid is the
permanently unstable development version
of Debian it is where the latest
versions of programs are being
considered for inclusion in the Debian
release cycle are uploaded and tested
because it has no official installed
media and the few net boot images that
are built often don't work even people
who are willing to risk using a
development version may have trouble
installing it however it Still Remains
the best place to test new features that
have not yet made their way onto the
stable
Branch Debian has only free and open-
Source software in its repositories this
is mostly ample for our users except for
users who use Hardware that only has
proprietary drivers these repositories
work well in most cases it is possible
to add other repos as well that have
propriety software if that is the
requirement Debian Standard Version is
very stable as software and libraries in
it go through rigorous testing the
stability makes Debian a perfect server
OS and it's also the same reason why
average user shy away from using Debian
as their primary OS on
desktop this is also one of the reasons
why many developers use Dean as a base
for the derivative one of which is also
Ubuntu now that we are aware of each
distribution's unique features let's
take a look at how we can go ahead and
install these operating systems and
where we can get the downloadable
images when it comes to ubu ubu has
dropped the support for 32-bit systems
currently it supports only 64-bit
devices and armm devices installation is
easy with the calaris framework coming
into ioso pred default and the latest
ISO can be downloaded from the link
being shown on the screen right now in
the case of dbn the support for multiple
range of devices is still present that
can also include 32-bit systems and
other smaller devices which are not
modern even though it does not use the
calaris installer even downloading the
ISO file can be a bit hectic for newer
users considering this is a distribution
aimed at developers and intermediate
users finding the right link can be
difficult because of which I we have
mentioned the link on the screen below
where you can get the latest ISO
depending on which desktop environment
you ch to go
with with the installation out of the
way let's take a direct comparison of
the features between both ubu and
Debian Debian is a community-driven open
source Linux distribution and is
primarily aimed to be robust capable and
most importantly free on the other hand
ubu is also and free and open source
like Debian but it's backed up and
developed by a canonical which is a
corporate company
Debian and uban 2 are both fundamentally
fast regarding performance as Debian
comes bare minimum and is not bundled of
prepacked with additional software and
features it makes it super fast and
lightweight at least when compared with
uban 2
directly both Ubuntu and Debian use the
same AP software packaging management
system but provide a different software
repository Debian is more like promoting
freedom of choosing free software thus
it does not include any proprietary
software by default
you can always install the paid versions
but you have to enable it manually ubun
to focuses on usability including all
the software including free paid open
source closed Source Etc Ubunto also
introduced a universal package
management system called Snap it will be
used across dros and thus prevent more
drro based software
fragmentations as the Debian drro does
not contain any proprietary blobs there
might be some problems with drivers and
firmware that means Debian lacks some of
the essential proprietary firmware by
default but the users can enable the
repository and install it manually like
other paid software on the other hand UB
2 does not care how much whether it's
paid free open source or clone source so
it includes as many drivers and firmware
as possible UB to also let you install
and configure the necessary drivers and
firmware automatically during
installation or
afterward if you are a gamer then you
will probably be concerned with the
latest software drivers and Hardware
support while Debian can potentially
provide that it is likely that you might
end up breaking your installation as
mentioned before uban to supports
certain priety packages as well which
often consist of graphic drivers which
are essential to gaming Debian focuses
on the open source aspect of the
software hence it can be a well-known
fact that with Gamers Ubunto and some
other distributions like poos have been
working much better regarding both
software and Hardware support regarding
the audience they cater to both Ubuntu
and Dean have their pros and cons Ubuntu
is a very good distribution for amateure
users with little to know experience and
if they want to have the latest versions
of packages and applications at all
times on their
systems it is also for users who do not
want a lot of customizability in spite
of unity being very customized a desktop
environment it is also perfect for users
with newer Hardware since it comes
updated with all the latest graphic
devices and their respective
drivers Debian on the other hand is
Catered towards a little bit of
experienced users who can fix some minor
bugs on their own or with minimal
Community Support it also is for users
who want to support an open- Source
approach rather than an operating system
which is devoid of any contribution from
other end and is primarily backed by a
corporation it also doesn't favor gaming
since it does not guarantee
compatibility with all the newest
graphic cards or even wi- Wi-Fi cards in
some
cases however due to the low memory
overhead Dean is very useful for people
who are looking to run home servers or
even corporate environments where
running servers on deban will provide
much more use data protection is of
Paramount importance in today's world
the vast amount of data flow between
corporations and consumer needs to be
secured considering that they usted with
a lot of belief a company can spend
millions of dollars on the most secure
servers but it takes a single hacker to
ruin all the between the organizations
to prevent these malicious attacks many
automated security systems have been
developed but none of them have been as
used as idas platforms which are also
known as intrusion detection systems
welcome to this introductory lesson on
intrusion detection systems so let's go
through the topics that we are going to
cover today we start with a basic
definition of ideas from a Layman's
perspective then moving on we cover the
multiple types of intruders that seek to
access confidential information without
any
authorization next we cover the basic
ways to detect intrusion signatures from
the perspective of a network
administrator we then take a look at the
different types of ideas systems that
can be used in corporate environments
today a small explanation of the two
types of protection is Then followed by
an introduction to some of the most
well-known idas tools on the market so
let's get started with what is an
IDs an intrusion detection system is an
app or device that monitors inbound and
outward Network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes and
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior an
administrator then reviews alarms and
take action to remove the threat for
example an IDs might inspect the data
carried by Network traffic to see if it
contains node malware or other malicious
content if it detects this type of
threat it sends an alert to your
security team so they can investigate
and remediated once your team receives
the alert they must act quickly to
prevent an attack from taking over the
system to ensure that the IDS doesn't
slow down Network performance the
solutions often use a switched Port
analyzer or a text access port to
analyze a copy of the inline data
traffic so that they do not meddle with
the actual
traffic however they do not block threat
once they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do regardless of
whether you set up a physical device or
an IDs program the system can recognize
attack patterns with network packets
monitor user Behavior identify abnormal
network activity or ensure user and
system activity do not go against
security
policies the main goal of an ideas is to
detect the anomalies before the hackers
complete the objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any ideas fit its own unique needs
expert advised what this means is that
an idas cannot be a one siiz fits-all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively and this requires a Savvy
ideas analyst to tailor the ideas for
the interest and needs of a given site
and knowledgeable train system analyst
are cash the trick with ideas is that
you have to know what the attack is to
be able to identify it the ideas has
always had the patient zero problem you
have to have found someone who got sick
and died before you can identify it it
can usually go for two types of
protection active protection and passive
in a passive system the idas detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
idas responds to the suspicious activity
by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious
source so now that we understand what an
ideas is let us go through the different
different types of intruders IDs
platforms must be aware of to understand
the type of intruders let us go through
a scenario we have the servers which are
protected by the ideas Platforms in
place so let's say a hacker tries to
breach the system from outside the
organization this can be done using
multiple attacks like dos attacks
injection attacks Etc the category of
individuals that are not authorized to
use a system but still exploit users
privacy and confidential information
using different techniques are known as
masqueraders a masquerader is an
intruder that is an outsider who does
not have direct access to the system and
aims to attack unethically by stealing
data or
information however there is another
Intruder who is theoretically harder to
detect and approved than a masquerader
these are the people within the
organization who want to weaken the
security defenses be it for corporate
Espionage or to Aid other
masqueraders the category of individuals
that are authorized to use a system but
misuse the the granted access and
privilege these are individuals that
take undue advantage of the permissions
and give access to them and this
category of intruders are known as misia
misers are people that are insiders and
have direct access to the system which
they aim to attack unethically by
stealing data or
information let us now go through some
of the ways the idas platforms can
detect intrusion before it is too late
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature
page in inion and the anomaly based
intrusion signature based intrusion
detection is designed to detect possible
threats by comparing the given Network
traffic and log data to existing attack
patterns these patterns are called
sequences and could include bite
sequence which is also known as
malicious instruction sequences
signature based detection enables you to
accurately detect and identify possible
L attacks anomally based intrusion
detection is the opposite it's designed
to pinpoint unknown attacks such as new
malware and adapt to them on the Fly
using machine learning machine learning
techniques enable an intrusion detection
system to create baselines of
trustworthy activity which is known as a
trust model then compare new behaviors
to verify trust models false alarms can
occur when using an anomaly based idea
since previously unknown yet legitimate
Network traffic could be falsely
identified as malicious activity now if
you combine both of those you have the
hybrid intrusion detection they use
signature based and anomal based
intrusion detection to increase the
scope of your ideas this enables you to
identify as many threats as possible a
comprehensive intrusion detection system
can understand the evasion technique
cyber criminals use to trick and ideas
to thinking there isn't an attack taking
place these techniques could include
fragmentation low bandwidth attack
pattern change evasion and many
more we can now take a look at the type
of protection offered by IDs
platforms there are a couple of ways
that can be set up so let's go through
each
method the first is a network based idas
the sensors are deployed at strategic
points within the network such as within
the DMZ or at the Network's parameter
the sensor can monitor individual
packets of inbound and outbound traffic
to and from all devices on the network
it analyzes them for malicious activity
and depending on the network
architecture and amount of traffic
involved multiple instances of network
based ideas may be necessary the second
Cate
is host based intrusion detection
systems or
HIDs an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal Network intrusions
identified by analyzing operating
specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or Access Control lists and the
monitoring system application logs as
well they augment network based idea
systems by detecting animalus traffic
which originate within the organiz
ganization or from the host that is
being monitored for example a host
infected with malware that is attempting
to spread it to other internal host is
an issue that a network based idas could
potentially fail to detect the third
variant is a cloud-based intrusion
detection
system because of the internet facing
nature of the cloud on premises ID
Solutions are not necessarily optimized
from
monitoring for example network-based
sensors need to be deployed within the
cloud at an environment's Network
parameter and yet a cloud service
provider may or may not have a way to
facilitate this cloud-based servers use
purpose built Cloud sensors that use
cloud service provider application
programming interface or cloud service
provider apis to get as much visibility
as possible into your Cloud
environment now that we understand the
different types of idas deployment
tactics let us go through some tools
that excel in this field offering
top-of-the-line implementations in a
corporate and consumer environment
the first tool being covered is the
solar wind security event
manager the solar wind security event
manager is designed to integrate
realtime log data from across your
infrastructure enabling it to act both
as a network based idea system and a
host based idea system the solution can
let you discover all kinds of malicious
attacks and help you protect your
network from harm it is also designed to
enact both signature based and anamaly
based intrusion detection by comparing
sequences of of network traffic against
a set of customizable
rules next we have the macafee life Safe
macafe Life safe is an intrusion
detection system designed to bring a
realtime threat awareness to your
physical and virtual networks it uses
signature-based intrusion prevention and
anomaly based intrusion detection along
with emultion techniques to spot and
identify malicious activity maafe is
also buil to correlate threat activity
with application usage which can further
prevent network issues stemming from
cyber
attacks next we have bluma bluma is a
security information and event
management platform built to enact
thread detection and responses across
your cloud and on premises environments
it is designed to continuously monitor
your it infrastructure for suspicious
activity and misconfigurations both of
which could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches it enables you to
respond to an attack in progress and
stop malicious actors in their tracks
monitoring usage of corporate data and
access to privilege information had been
a daunting task before the Advent of I
am encompassing numerous apis single
sign on Frameworks and data handling
policies imem has established itself as
a key component of every it department
but how does it enforce these rules and
who are the key benefactors of these
policies what about the advantages of
these Frameworks and the workflow of
these systems we are here today to
answer these questions let's take a look
at some of the topics to be covered
today
we start by learning about IM am that is
identity and access management from a
surface level so as to put a clear idea
of what it is next we cover the general
workflow and process of how IM am Works
moving on we cover some of the tools
that find their place in an IM am
framework and are crucial
components finally we go through some of
the advantages of the IM am learning
what makes them a lucrative deal for
organiz
ations so let's get started by learning
about IM am from a surface level
perspective identity and access
management or IM am is a set of
processes policies and tools for
defining and managing the roles and
access privileges of individual Network
entities to a variety of cloud and on
premise applications the users can
include customers Partners employees
devices like computers smartphones
routers Etc the core objective of IM IM
systems is one digital identity per
individual or item once the digital
identity has been established it must be
maintained modified and monitored
throughout each users or devices access
life cycle access and user are two vital
IM Concepts access refers to the actions
permitted to be done by a user like view
create or change a file users could be
employees Partners suppliers contractors
or even customers furthermore employ can
be further segmented based on their
roles IM systems are designed to perform
three key tasks identify authenticate
and authorized meaning that only the
right person should have access to
computers Hardware software apps any it
resources
etc for the entry of new users or the
changing of the roles of existing users
the list of access privileges must be up
to date all the time IM functions
usually fall under it departments or
section that handle cyber security and
data
management now that we understand the
importance of IM am in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework we have
multiple components that Aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them
individually principle is an entity that
can perform actions on an awsc Source or
any Cloud management system a user a
role or an application can be a
principal it's always the principal who
raises a concern to access or modify
data on servers serving as the first
point of contact in the IM am
workflow authentication is the process
of confirming the identity of the
principal trying to access the product
the principal must provide s credentials
or required keys for authentication this
step can be further enhanced by multiple
authentication factors and Googs among
other things once the identity is
confirmed the principle has the ability
to view the data behind the wall of
security and take the necessary
steps when it comes to requests a
principal then sends a request to the
cloud management system specifying the
action and which resource should perform
it in this step the user can ask to
modify delete edit or affect other users
in this particular buket of organization
by changing the data or the
information when it comes to
authorization it carries out the rest of
an organization identity and access
management processes once the user has
been authenticated users are granted
authorizations according to the role at
an organization the practice is referred
to as role based access control or
rbac authorizations determine a roles
resources and level of access in the
network these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more for example an accounting
department employee who regularly works
with payroll software must be authorized
to do such if authentication resamples a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it well
authentication is fully straightforward
authorizations and their management are
far more challenging authorizations
consist of complex set of rules and
policies and groups which are permitted
explicitly configured per user
account with the working of I Frameworks
out of the way let's cover some of the
tools that these systems work
on SSO is an IM tool that enables a user
to log into one an organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a designed set of other
properties for example when you log into
Google you're automatically logged into
your Gmail and your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single sign on
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application for organizations SSO
helps in collecting valuable insights
about user behavior and preferences
since it taxs them as they move from one
application to another connected by one
single
login next is multi multifactor
authentication or
MFA implementing multiactor
authentication is crucial to protect
your organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of
MFA however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security for example in business to
Consumer scenarios you need to consider
ux and try not to create unnecessary
fiction for users who don't want to be
subjected to heightened scrutiny every
time they log in for Workforce you may
want a more stringent MFA since the
consequences of an unauthorized party
gaining access to your private Network
can be so devastating a modern IM
solution will allow you to implement MFA
only when it's needed this can be
accomplished through setup
authentication or adaptive
authentication in which users only
trigger MFA if they're trying to access
sensitive data or their behavior is
flagged as
risky in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted fishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box there are multiple ways IM
systems can help detect and mitigate
these malicious attacks IM Solutions
detect attacks by monitoring signals
such as the velocity of traffic
detection of login patterns that differ
from a user's routine use of a breached
password use of devices and IP addresses
with a poor reputation among other
things these are some of the most widely
used tools when it comes to IM
Frameworks but why do we go through
setting up so many tools and
firewalls let's go through some of the
advantages of using IM systems in both
corporate and consumer
environments IM solution helps identify
and mitigate security risks you can use
IM to identify policy violations or
remove inappropriate access privileges
without having to search through
multiple distributed systems you can
also leverage IM to ensure that security
measures are in place to meet Regulatory
and auditing
requirements IM provides a common
platform for Access and identity
management information you can apply the
same security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the
organization the IM framework can help
you enforce policies related to user
authentication Privileges and validation
and attend to the privilege creep
problems IM simplifies signup and user
management processes for application
owners and users and system
administrators it makes it simple to
provide and manage access and PR mostes
user
satisfaction IM am Services can also
lower operating costs using Federated
identity Services means you no longer
need local identities for external users
this makes application Administration
easier cloud-based IM Services can
reduce the need to buy and maintain on
premise infrastructure so importance of
a cyber security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
ects the first is the training itself
which allows me to gain the knowledge
which allows me to understand the
aspects of security or whatever the
certification is there for the second
aspect is the exam itself how do I need
to prepare myself for the exam and how
do I need to approach the exam how do I
need to ensure that I pass in my first
attempt and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that pre prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific rule uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
Advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in the
job profiles so cyber security cred uh
certifications can be classified in
three different different aspects the
first one being the foundational level
then the managerial level and the
advanced level uh in the previous video
we just had a small overview here we are
going to discuss about what the
certification covers how the exams are
conducted and uh the price points for
each and every exam so let's start with
the foundational certifications we start
off with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish their routing uh the pathing
of how data packets will travel across
the network this certification covers
all the basic concepts that you require
to understand networking the basic
requirements for this certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that
there are no other prerequisites so it's
just that you need a bachelor's degree
and then you can apply uh you can study
for this you can undergo a training and
then you can attempt the exam uh the
certification provider obviously assist
CIS so the knowledge that is limited to
this training and certification is for
Cisco devices only the exam fees for
this certification is approximately
$325 the exam when it is conducted uh it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 90 minutes the
type of questions that you're going to
get is multiple choice questions where
you have a question and four answers and
you have to choose the correct answers
among those drag and drop where you have
to click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate place from probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular uh position if you
place it correctly you answer the answer
the question correctly otherwise it's
wrong and a simulator where you where
there could be a configuration you need
to configure it in a particular Manner
and then check whether the configuration
is correct or not the pass Mark is
around 800 to 850 out of a possible,
marks so each question will have a
different weightage depending on the
depth of the question depending on the
difficult level of the question or the
difficulty level of the question which
uh would then count towards your marks
and if you score 800 to 850 that's when
you clear the exam the job roles as we
have discussed over here would be more
more on the network administrator side
or a network engineer side depending on
the level of experience that you have
the salaries uh that are expected from
this job roles in the US are around
$55,000 to $90,000 annually the next one
is the comcha certification called
Security Plus comare is also a global
certification Authority for uh infosec
courses so this certification teaches
candidates on how to secure applications
networks and devices it focuses on
Hands-On practical skills in the field
of network security I have trained
people on this certification myself so
uh I know this certification is quite
Hands-On it deals with the concepts to
the core it helps you understand the
concepts and then in the Practical
Hands-On demo uh you need to execute the
Practical yourself so that uh you can
gain that knowledge the recommended
level for a candidate to attempt this
training would be at least around 2
years of experience in the it sector in
addition if you have already been
certified for Network plus certification
from comia which is the Baseline
networking certification this is also a
preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is
$339 the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's 1 minute
per question it sounds like a lot of
time but believe me the questions can
can be a little bit confusing can be a
little bit lengthy so you will require
all those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance-based the pass Mark for this
exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900 the job profiles for this
kind of a certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security engineer's position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are on goinging in the organization uh
the average annual salary of this uh
person would be around
$72,000 then comes the CH or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC Council now this is a very well-known
course and also uh EC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from ethical
hacker perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a
pentester where you go into an
organization you test their security
controls or you'll test their devices
find out flaw flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have 2 years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of netw workking maybe a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary uh before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC Council and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
4 hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for C there
are two exams one is the multiple choice
questions and the second is a practical
exam where uh you need to solve some
given problems to you in a IAB scenario
and if you are able to solve them
properly you then get certified for CH
practical the cut off varies from 65 to
85% depending on the questions that you
have answered and the weightage
associated with each and every question
as said the job roles would be as a
penetration tester or security engineer
and your salaries would start from
around $90,000 annually then comes the
CND or the certified Network Defender
also from EC Council now this is more on
the network defense side so here again
the job rules would be where you uh
where there's a network that you have
and you're going to try to secure the
network and the communications that are
going to travel over the network so you
need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or uh in a
similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is EC Council
and the certification is placed a little
bit below C so it becomes Network
defense then C where you're going to
become a penetration Tester the exam
fees for for this certification is
$350 the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in 4 hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
pass percentage again varies from 60 to
85% depending on the questions answered
and the weightage of that question job
roles to be applied Network defense
technician CN analyst or a security
analyst from a network perspective
salaries would range from 65,000 to7
$25,000 per anom then comes the forensic
investigator course which is exactly
what it is digital forensic investigator
this will help you understand how
computers work where data is stored and
how you can retrieve that data to
investigate a crime that has uh taken
place so the candidate must have at
least 2 years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databas es
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is s after mainly in the
law enforcement areas but there are a
few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to uh conduct their own
investigations the certification
provider for this is also AC Council and
the exam fees are $500 this is an
advanced level certification so uh
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
before you attend this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in 4 hours again
it's just a multiple choice question
exam the cut off again is from 60% to
85% depending on the questions and the
weightage of each and every question job
rules it security specialist network
security pro the job roles foreign sake
investigators law enforcement agencies
security Specialists homeland security
jobs and your salaries would be around
$888,000 and above all right now let's
talk about the managerial level
certifications kit stands for control
objectives for information and related
Technologies it's a certification that
will give a candidate an in-depth
knowledge of the framework which kobit
is all about and the framework helps you
manage and govern Enterprise it
environments now this is Advanced
certification so around 8 years of
managerial experience is suggested
before you attempt the Coit 5
certification to understand all the
aspects and to help you implement the
framework properly the certification
certificate provider is isaka the exam
fees are around
$175 now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's a very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50% the job roles associated with
this certification would be to uh when
you apply for uh information security
manager or as a security consultant or a
cyber security manager and your roles
and responsibilities would be the govern
and uh it space that the organization
owns so all the servers desktops the
network the data flows the datab basis
everything and how it needs to be
managed and how it needs to be governed
in a secure manner annual salaries would
be around $100,000 plus then the cism
also called as sism it stands for
certified information security manager
and as the name suggests it's a security
manager certification it helps the
candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
information security so now you're going
into the space where you're not only
technical in nature but you also have to
understand the business needs the goals
of the business and you have to align
the information security of your
infrastructure along with the business
needs and the business goals so it is
your inputs that are going to go to the
management to see if the infrastructure
is aligned to the business goals or if
the infrastructure or the business goals
need any fine-tuning around 5 years of
work experience is is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the 5 years
the candidate must have a background as
an information security manager for 3
years so you have some experience as a
manager uh you have implemented those
things yourselves which will give you a
better understanding and then you
attempt the certification again
providing by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members is
$575 for non-members it is
$760 the exam is where you have to
answer1 50 questions in 4 hours uh quite
a bit of time but questions are going to
be uh scenario based questions where
they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of 800
your job profiles would be either a risk
manager or a risk consultant analyzing
the business requirements to the
infrastructure security that uh that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around $888,000 and above then the cisa
or the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information l landcape again a minimum 5
years of work work experience in the
field of Information Systems auditing
control or security is necessary now
here the question would be what's the
difference security is where your
technical in nature you have done let's
say a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even uh UTM
and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
uh ISO 2701 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members are
$575 whereas non isaka members will have
to pay $760 for the certification 150
questions again in 4 hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand the real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanism should be in place
pass Mark is 450 out of 800 your job
rules would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or a Information
Technology consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103,000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as krisk uh
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field of is controls
that means information security controls
you should have knowledge about
Fireballs you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after which you're going
to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risks and
treat those risks in their lifetime
certificate provider again is isaka $575
for isaka members
$760 for non isaka members for the exam
fees a similar question 150 questions to
be answered in 4 hours multiple choice
based on performances so they may give
you a scenario where you have to perform
a risk analysis and provide a report and
a solution based on your findings again
the pass Mark is 450 out of 800 the job
profiles Associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to identify risks
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact analysis to a
certain how uh the organization is going
to be affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned concerned
average annual salary would be 119,000
and above moving on to advanced level
certification now this is where we come
across the cissp or the cisp
certification certified information
system security professional this is the
gold standard of all certifications if
you have this certificate it's you can
basically be assured of a job in the IT
world now just to qualify you'll have to
have 5 years of experience in the
information uh security field there are
eight domains that specified by cissp
and you have to prove that you have
knowledge and you have work experience
of around 5 years in at least two of
those domains if you do not have those
kind of experiences you can still
attempt the exam but you become an
associate of ISC Square which means that
you've get 6 years to accomplish the 5
years of uh experience requirement for
this certification before taking up the
cisp certification it is suggested that
the candidate clears all the
intermediate level certifications not
all but some of them in fact I've seen
people do the other way way around they
qualify for cissp they give the exam
once your cissp the cisa or cesm cisa or
cism exams are way easier to crack but
you need to have that kind of experience
I have seen people with 15 years of
experience and more fail at this
certification in the first attempt the
certificate provided is IC Square the
exam fees is
$699 like I said this certification is
where most sought after the gold
standard in fact there is hardly any
other certifications after this that you
might want to do the questions now the
exam has changed if it is the English
version that you're giving it's 150
questions to be answered in 3 hours if
it is the non-english exam that you're
attempting then it is 250 questions in 6
hours it's a marathon and if you're
opting for the 6- hour exam you need to
plan it really well it sounds really
easy but the questions are quite tough
they're scenario based and the answers
are quite confusing as well you would
get multiple choice questions you would
get dragon drop and you might get
simulators as well uh the pass Mark is
700 out of 1,000 but each question has a
different weightage so uh it depends on
which questions are asked of you and
which questions you've answered
correctly the job rules associated with
this certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the ceso RO the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer and
any role that you might think of as a
risk from a risk compliance strategy
could be achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is
$18,000 for this certification and if
you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security that
is by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who sits
to switch careers with cyber security by
learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from the MIT schwarzman
College of Engineering
and the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered and before we begin if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schi College of computing the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered in today's interconnected world
the significance of cyber security has
reached Paramount levels as technology
continues to advance at an unprecedent
pace so do the risk and threats lurking
in the digital landscape recently in
April 2023 the shields Healthcare Group
a medical service provider located in
Massachusetts experienced the most
significant data breach towards the end
of the month reports surfaced revealing
that an individual involved in cyber
crime had illicitly accessed the
organization systems and successfully
obtain the personal information of
approximately 2.3 million individuals
organizations and individuals alike are
realizing the critical need for
qualified professionals who possesses
the skills to defend against cyber
attacks one such certification that has
gained widespread recognition is the
certified ethical hacker or C
certification so in this video on
step-by-step guide to C exam we will be
covering various topics like why C what
is C exam eligibility criteria for C and
how to prepare for C exam also make sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel and
press the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now before
moving forward let me ask you a quick
question so which of the following terms
describes an individual who gains
unauthorized access to computer systems
with malicious intent option A is white
hat hacker option b is black black hat
hacker option C is gray hat hacker and
option D is script Kitty now you can
pause this video and answer in the
comment section below now let's start
with the first topic which is YC or
certified ethical hacker so there is a
high demand for cyber security experts
in various businesses to hire these
experts organizations have certain
requirements these profession need to
have a good understanding of security
Concepts and be familiar with the latest
tools processes and Frameworks to stay
ahead of of cyber criminals and prevent
data breaches certifications like C or
certified ethical hacker offered by EC
Council play a significant role in this
scenario the C programming is designed
to train ethical hackers comprehensively
covering the latest hacking Trends and
introducing professionals to
technologies that help prevent data
breaches this certification is
recognized globally meaning your skills
and knowledge will be valued by
organizations around the world
regardless of your location the course
instructs participants on P tactical
strategies that can be used in real life
situations and future careers the CH
exam focuses on understanding how
malicious individuals exploit weaknesses
in addition to offering promising job
prospects the C certification training
provides a wealth of knowledge that is
not easily obtained through other
information security courses so if you
are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities
then try giving a shot at simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT shadman College of
Engineering the link is in the
description box that will navigate to
the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered also have a look at what our
Learners has to say about the course hi
I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old and last
year I upskill with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the it sector
and various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and C ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course course I must say was packed
with practical examples it was led by
highly skilled and certified instructors
with many companies before a security
analyst and architect on a contract
basis but I needed some stability which
I got with the job I just started with
infosis as a cyber security consultant
happened on first now let us understand
about this certified ethical hacker or C
exam so the CH exam focuses on
theoretical understanding and does not
involve hacking actual systems it
emphasizes comprehension of hacking
Concepts tools and methodologies however
to obtain the C Master's designation you
must also pass a six hour practical exam
with 20 challenges this exams evaluates
your practical application of Knowledge
and Skills in real life scenarios but
that's a choice if you want to apply for
Masters so the CH exam is 4 hours long
the exam consists of 125 multiple choice
questions the passing score required for
certification where is depending on the
specific exam some exams state in
passing score as a percentage While
others base it on the difficulty of
questions and the knowledge or skills
needed to demonstrate competence in the
subject the actual cut score determined
by subject matter experts depends on the
difficulty of the questions and ensures
fairness in evaluation skills if you
encounter more challenging questions
fewer correct answers are needed to pass
while an easier set of questions
requires higher percentage of correct
answers
thus performance relative to the passing
standard can be higher even with fewer
correct answers in a difficult question
set so now let's have a look at the
sections so the sections covered in the
program includes section number one that
is background then there is section
number two which is analysis or
assessment then there is section number
three security then comes section number
four tools systems and programs section
five is procedures and methodology
section six is regulation and policy
section seven is ethics so this was
about the C exam now let's have a look
at its eligibility criteria so the
eligibility criteria for CH exam before
you start preparing for CH exam it's
important to meet certain requirements
firstly you must show this EC Council
that you have at least two years of
experience in information security and a
specialization in that field through
your educational background additionally
keep in mind that the CH exam has a cost
of 100 US
and make sure you fulfill these criteria
before moving forward to avoid wasting
your time so this was about the
eligibility criteria for CH exam now
let's understand how to prepare for CH
exam so the first step in preparing for
CH exam is joining a forum so there are
many online forums and blogs dedicated
to C where people with similar interest
and goals gather these forums are filled
with individuals who are either
preparing for CH exam or have already
taken it they share share valuable tips
strategies and general advice based on
their experiences by participating in
these forums you can interact with other
C students and professionals this allows
you to exchange knowledge and discover
each other's strengths and weaknesses
it's a great way to identify areas where
you may need to improve your
understanding remember what one person
is good at another person may struggle
with through discussions on the Forum
you can learn from others and reinforce
your own knowledge through repetition
which helps with better retention the
second thing you can do is create
important topics checklist so once you
have identified the areas where you lack
knowledge as a hacker it's important to
make a checklist of study topics
prioritize the topics that need more
attention don't forget to allocate some
study time to the topics you already
know it's always beneficial to reinforce
and refresh your existing knowledge
however the main focus should be on
addressing the knowledge gaps First Once
you have addressed those gaps you can
revisit the other topics later along
with this you can also take take up EC
council certification assessment EC
council certification assessments refers
to the international evaluation process
conducted by the international Council
of electronic Commerce Consultants the
certification assessment typically
involves an examination that accesses
the candidates understanding of the
relevant Concepts tools and best
practices in their chosen certification
track the exam is educational and the
questions are beneficial for studying
purposes using the training platform the
candidate can access the levels of
Readiness and analyze their preparedness
for the exam along with taking self
assessment you can also take help from
study guides while we emphasize the
importance of not relying solely in
books it cannot be denied that books
hold a wealth of knowledge when
preparing for the CH exam it is
essential to thoroughly read the
recommended books this approach will
addresses all your what and why
questions regarding cyber security and
ethical hacking the content provided in
these books is of top quality offering
precise definition ations descriptions
and diagrams for almost every topic we
suggest dedicating at least 1 hour daily
to study in order to grasp all the
concepts covered in the training so by
understanding the exam objectives
setting up study plan utilizing quality
resources and reviewing your weak areas
you are well equipped for Success
remember to stay focused manage your
time effectively and maintain a positive
mindset throughout your preparation with
dedication and perseverance you can
confidently approach the CH exam and
achieve certification goals hello and
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in today's video we will be discussing
the Intriguing world of ethical hacking
with the rise of cyber threats and the
increasing need for robust cyber
security ethical hackers have become an
integral part of the modern digital
landscape in this video we will explore
what ethical hacking is why ethical
hacking are in high demand salary Trends
in the field of ethical hacking skills
required for a career in ethical hacking
and tips for starting a successful
career as an ethical hacker at the end
of this video we we will be sharing some
useful tips so keep watching till the
end of this video so let's dive in
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question so what is the main goal
of an ethical hacker option A is to hack
into systems and steal sensitive
informations option b is to test and
identify vulnerabilities in systems and
networks option C is to create new
security threats and exploits option D
is to cause harm and damage to the
Target organization now you can pause
the video and answer in the comment
section below so let's start with the
first topic that is what is ethical
hacking ethical hacking also known as
Whit hat hacking is the practice of
intentionally probing computer systems
networks or applications to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses the main
difference between ethical hackers and
malicious hackers is the intent and
legality of their actions ethical
hackers operate with the permission of
the system honor and their goal is to
identify vulnerabilities before they can
be exploited by malicious hackers they
use their skills and knowledge to help
organization strengthen their cyber
security defenses and protect sensitive
data from unauthorized access as
Reliance on technology and the internet
continues to grow so does the risk of
cyber threats organizations both large
and small are constantly seeking ways to
secure their digital assets and
Safeguard their business operations the
demand has led to a significant need for
skilled ethical hackers who can
proactively identify and fix
vulnerabilities in systems ethical
hackers play a crucial role in helping
organization prevent data breaches
protect customer information
maintain compliance with industry
regulations and Safeguard their
reputation with the increasing awareness
of cyber security threats ethical
hackers are in high demand across
various Industries including Finance
Healthcare technology and government
sectors now let's discuss some salary
trends for ethical hackers the rising
demand for cyber security expertise has
led to a significant need for ethical
hackers consequently skilled
Professionals in the field have
experienced favorable salary Trends in
recent years several factors impact the
salaries of ethical hackers including
their experience certifications industry
and region the roles that fall under the
umbrella of an ethical hacker may
include penetration tester penetration
tester also known as pentester if you're
interested in pursuing a career as a
penetration tester you will need to
develop a strong skill set in various
technical areas including programming
operating system networking and cyber
security principles pentesters are
responsible for conducting authorized
test on computer systems networks and
applications to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses and provide
recommendation for improving security
with an average salary of 5 lakhs per
year in India and
$12,000 in the United States becoming a
penetration tester can be productive
career choice simply learns professional
certificate program in ethical hacking
and penetration testing is designed to
equip you with the necessary skills to
analyze the threat landscape and develop
strategies to ensure the stability and
security of systems through Hands-On
training in real world cases you will
Mar Master's essential cyber security
skills in just 6 months you will learn
the advanced cyber security strategies
that will enable you to protect networks
and data from breaches next is
vulnerability accessor this role
involves identifying and accessing
potential vulnerabilities in computer
systems networks and applications using
various tools and techniques to
determine the level of risk associated
with those
vulnerabilities the average salary of a
vulnerability accessor is 950,000 in
India and $61,000 in the United States
next up we have information security
analyst an information security analyst
is a professional responsible for
protecting and organization information
assets including Data Systems Network
and applications from potential security
breaches and cyber threats information
security analysts play a critical role
in safeguarding sensitive information
and ensuring the confidentiality
integrity and availability of data the
average salary of an information
security analyst is 6 lakhs per year in
India and and $999,000 per year in the
United States the Caltech cyber security
boot camp is designed to help you
develop the skills needed for this tool
this comprehensive course curriculum
covers defensive and funship cyber
security digital forensics penetration
testing infrastructure design and much
more you'll have the access to labs and
assisted practices that expose you to
several in demand cyber security tools
allowing you to gain practical hands-on
experience in a supportive learning
environment security analyst this role
involves monitoring and analyzing
computer systems networks and
applications for security incidents and
breaches and taking appropriate actions
to respond to and mitigate these
incidents the average salary of an
information security analyst is 6 lakhs
per year in India and 999,000 per year
in the United States now let's discuss
skills required for a career in ethical
hacking a successful career in ethical
hacking requires strong foundation in
cyber security and a diverse skill set
some of the key skills that aspiring
ethical hackers should possess include
Proficiency in programming language such
as python C++ and Java understanding of
networking Concepts like protocols
knowledge of operating systems and
databases expertise in tools and
Technologies used in ethical hacking
such as metas sploit wi shark and nmap
and familiarity with cyber security
Frameworks and best practices
additionally ethical hackers should have
excellent problem solving skills
critical thinking abilities attention to
detail and the ability to work
independent or as a part of the team
continuous learning and staying updated
with the latest developments in cyber
security is also a crucial for
successful career in ethical hacking now
let's have a look at some tips starting
a career as an ethical hacker can be
exciting and rewarding here are some
tips to help you Kickstart your journey
first is demonstrate an ethical hacker
mindset develop curiosity problem
solving and continuous learning mindset
to excel in the field of ethical hacking
second is obtain relevant certifications
certifications like CE eh Caltech cyber
security boot camp OSP and advanced
executive programming cyber security
these certifications add credibility and
demonstrate expertise these
certifications will help you in securing
a nice job in the market third is build
practical experience practice ethical
hacking in a controlled environment such
as setting up your own lab or practicing
in CTF competitions to gain hands-on
experience Real World experience will
help you develop practical skills and
insights into different types of systems
networks and applications next is stay
updated with the latest threats and
Technology cyber security landscape is a
constantly evolving and it's a crucial
to stay updated with the latest threats
vulnerabilities and Technologies follow
industry blogs forums and new sources
practice in online communities and
attend conferences and workshops to stay
informed and continuously improve your
skills hello everyone and welcome back
to Simply learns YouTube channel ethical
hacking is the practice of using hacking
techniques to test the security of a
computer system Network or application
ation with the goal of identifying
vulnerabilities and improving the
overall security of the system with
increasing Reliance on digital systems
in various Industries there has been a
growing demand for skilled ethical
hackers ethical hacking offers a
lucrative career option with a high
salary and the potential to work as a
freelancer or as a part of a team with
that being said it is sufficiently
evident that cyber security and ethical
hacking are amazing career options for
every individual out there so without
any further delay let's jump onto our
topic right away if you want to enter
the field of cyber security and grab a
high-paying job then simply learn
postgraduate programming cyber security
in collaboration with the MIT University
is surely the right option for you this
post-graduate program in cyber security
will help you learn comprehensive
approaches to protecting your
infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance you'll get foundational to
Advanced skills through industry leading
cyber security certification courses in
this program for admission to the this
postgraduate program in cyber security
candidate should have a bachelor's
degree with an average of 50% or higher
grades and candidates with one plus year
of work experience are preferred so join
now the course link is mentioned in the
description box below let us start by
understanding what ethical hacking is
ethical hacking often referred to as
Whitehead hacking involves using your
cyber security skills to protect systems
and networks in 2024 this field is more
critical than ever due to the increasing
number of cyber attacks your role as an
ethical hacker is to find
vulnerabilities before malicious hackers
do and secure digital environments
before we begin let's talk about the
prerequisites to excel in ethical
hacking you should have a strong
foundation in computer science or it
familiarity with programming languages
like python C++ and Java will be
beneficial as they are commonly used in
cyber security tasks it's essential to
follow a structured learning path so
start by gaining a deep understanding of
networking you need to comprehend how
data flows through networks the various
protocols in use and security mechanisms
that protect them next delve into the
world of operating systems understanding
the intricacies of most popular
operating systems like Windows Linux and
Mac OS is crucial for ethical hackers
you'll often encounter vulnerabilities
at this level certifications play a
pivotal role in your ethical hacking
career consider pursuing certifications
like certified ethical hacker certified
information system Security
Professionals coma Security Plus and
certified information security manager
cism these certifications are recognized
by industry professionals and can open
up doors to many exciting job
opportunities learning by doing is
crucial in ethical hacking engage in
Hands-On experiences such as capture the
flat competitions participating in bug
bounties and setting up your own home
lab these activities will sharpen your
practical skills and deepen your
understanding of vulnerabilities and and
exploits cyber security is a rapidly
evolving field stay updated with the
latest threats tools and techniques by
following cyber security news attending
conferences and engaging with online
communities the ability to adapt to New
Challenges is a Hallmark of a successful
ethical hacker ethical hacking is all
about doing good alliv us are there to
the law obtain proper permission when
testing systems and respect privacy and
confidentiality ethical behavior is not
just a requirement it's a Cornerstone of
this profession as you progress build a
strong portfolio document your
achievements successful hacks and
projects a well-maintained portfolio
will not only showcase your skill but
also make you stand out to potential
employers building strong networking
skills is essential attend cyber
security conferences and join
professional associations like Issa
information system security Association
or
isaca information systems audit and
Control Association networking not only
enhances your knowledge but also opens
doors to job opportunities and
collaborations coding and scripting are
your secret weapons Master scripting
languages like Python and Powershell
these skills are invaluable when
automating security tasks creating
custom tools and analyzing malwares
incident response is a critical aspect
of cyber security understand how to
detect respond to and recover from
security incidents familiarize yourself
with incident response Frameworks like
nist and ISO
271 this expertise is highly sought
after by organizations looking to
Bluster their cyber defenses don't
underestimate the importance of soft
skills effective communication teamwork
and problem solving abilities will set
you apart in the workplace ethical
hackers often collaborate with cross
functional teams and strong
interpersonal skills are essential for
success in this aever evolving field
continuous learning is your best friend
stay curious and explore some emerging
technology Oles like Ai iot and Quantum
Computing as they bring new security
challenges learning about these
Technologies and their Associated
security risks will make you an
invaluable asset to any
organization join online communities and
forums where ethical hackers share
knowledge and experiences platforms like
GitHub and stack Overflow can be
invaluable for collaboration and
learning engaging with the community
allows you to tap into the collective
wisdom of experienced hackers looking
ahead consider specializations with
ethical hacking such as mobile security
iot security or Cloud security these
niches offer exciting career paths and
opportunities to become an expert in a
specific area of cyber security ethical
hacking is a field that will continue to
grow in coming years and you can upskill
yourself to start your professional
career in this amazing field welcome to
a world of ethical exploration in India
a realm of top-n ethical courses awaits
you these courses not only equip you
with essential skills but also guide you
in making responsible choices so let's
embark on a journey to discover the top
five ethical courses in India where
learning meets consigns in the most
accessible and engaging way possible but
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question so what is the primary
objective of ethical hacker option A is
to steal sensitive information option b
is to comprise computer systems option C
is to identify vulnerabilities option D
to spread virus now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below now let's start with the first
course on the list which is postgraduate
program in cyber security so this
comprehensive course equips you with the
skills to safeguard your system and data
effectively from risk assessment to
compliance you'll gain solid foundation
in cyber security this course is offered
by simply learn this program offers a
range of courses spanning from
fundamental to Advanced levels and
include prestigious indust
certifications key highlights of this
program includes simply learns
post-graduate certification upon
completion exclusive masterclass hosted
by MIT modules curated in collaboration
with MIT SEC and EC Council real world
cyber security case studies from various
Industries access to C kit for Hands-On
practice engage in 25 plus practical
projects to enhance your skills then
there is cumulate your learning with a
Capstone project across three domains
then you can also become a part of MIT
csil professional program community so
these were the key highlights of this
program other than this you will be delv
into a diverse area of skills including
Advanced hacking Concepts Network packet
analysis ethical hacking ideas firewalls
Security Management cryptography and
more so if you are really interested to
become a cyber security expert then this
CES for you enrolling this program is
really easy apply online start by
completing the userfriendly online
application form share your details and
intent to join the cyber security
certification program second is
selection our admission panel will
review the applications and short list
candidates based on their qualifications
and aspirations then third is
confirmation if you're among the chosen
candidates you'll receive an offer of
admission secure your support by paying
the program fee so this is how you can
enroll in this program so this was about
postgraduate program in cyber security
by simply learn now let's move on to the
next program which which is cyber
security expert Masters program by
simply learn simply learn cyber security
expert Masters program is designed to
help cyber Security Professionals to
develop skills at different levels that
is foundational intermediate and
advanced these skills are backed by top
certifications like C cism cissp and
ccsp Etc the program kicks off with
basic technology training and then moves
to more advanced topics like reverse
engineering and network penetrating
testing Etc by completing this course
you will be able to first of all stay
updated keep yourself informed about the
latest cyber security Trends learn how
to implement effective security measures
using suitable hardware and software for
your organization second would be defend
against fishing learn ethical security
practices to protect against fishing
attacks and other risks then third is
Embrace cloud computing understand the
importance of cloud computing for your
business and how to use it for success
then there is ensure compliance get
familiar with legal requirements privacy
policies and auditing process for your
Cloud environment then after that there
is optimize it infrastructure streamline
your it setup and invest in right
software solutions for a well organized
infrastructure partner with experts who
have your best interest in Mind by the
time you complete this master's program
you will become skilled in handling
Advanced hacking Concepts which will
help you manage information security
effectively upon completion you'll be
able to safeguard the moment of data
perform actions of recovering from
disasters manage security for client
databases and handle security aspects
related to cloud service providers and
many more things like that upon
completion of this master's program you
will receive the certificates from
Simply learns in cyber security courses
in the learning path this certificate
will testify to your skills as an expert
in cyber security upon program
completion you will also receive an
industry recognized Master's certificate
from Simply Lear so this was about cyber
security expert Masters program now move
on to the next program which is Advanced
executive program in cyber security this
Advanced executive program in cyber
security will help you develop expertise
in defensive cyber security application
security malare analysis ethical hacking
Etc in partnership with triple it
Bangalore and npci this program is
tailored to empower you with the skills
in defensive cyber security ethical
hacking malware analysis and and more by
completing this program you earn a
prestigious certificate from triple it
Bangalore sh sing your accomplishment
engage in Enlighten master classes led
by trop TripIt Bangalore faculty gaining
insights from their wealth of knowledge
moreover receive a virtual internship
certificate from npci and reaching your
practical experience the course is
designed for Hands-On learning featuring
over 30 demos and multiple projects
conducted in integrated Labs with
lifetime access to self-based video use
you can learn at your convenience a
valuable triple it bangler transcript
validates your skills in ethical hacking
penetration testing cryptography
ransomware analysis malware analysis
Enterprise security network Concepts and
threat hunting this program is your
gateway for a promising future in the
dynamic realm of cyber security the
admission process for this Advanced
executive program in cyber security
consists of three easy steps interested
candidates will need to apply by
submitting the application from online
candidates will be shortlisted by an
admission panel for this PG in cyber
security based on the application
submitted then selected candidates will
be awarded an offer of admission that
they can accept by paying the program
fee upon completion you will get the
final program completion certificate
from Simply learn individual course
completion certificate for all the
courses in the learning path from Simply
learn then there is executive program
certification from MIT certified ethical
hacker certificate from EC Council MIT
then there is professional program
Community membership also you'll get so
these all the things you'll get in this
Advanced executive program in cyber
security all right now let's move on to
the next best course which is
professional certificate program in
cyber security this professional
certificate program in cyber security
offered by IIT kpur in collaboration
with simply learn equips participants
with expertise to access the threat
landscape and devise strategies for
ballst string system security and
stability this program facilitates the
Mastery of vital cyber security
proficiencies through imersive Hands-On
training embedded in real world
scenarios completion of this program
Awards a certification from IID kpur and
simply learn candidates will gain
exclusive access to Enlighten master
classes hosted by esteemed I kpur
faculty the curriculum culminates in a
practical Capstone project that engages
participants in Industry relevant use
cases fostering hands-on experience
simply learn Learning Management system
that is LMS provides seamless access to
integrated Labs enhancing practical
understanding the program
comprehensively covers essential skills
including ethical hacking cryptography
Concepts ideas firewalls and honey pods
network security vulnerability
assessment penetration testing and web
app threats the admission process for
this professional certificate program in
cyber security consist of three easy
steps that is interested candidates will
lead to apply by submitting the
application from online then candidates
will be shortlisted by admission panel
then selected candidates will be awarded
an offer of admission that they can
accept by paying the program fee now
coming to the last course which is
Caltech cyber security boot camp the
celtech cyber security boot camp offers
a comprehensive learning experience to
master defensive and offensive cyber
security digital forensics penetration
testing infrastructure design and more
this course equips you with practical
expertise using in demand cyber security
tools through Hands-On labs and guided
practices with a focus on Real World
skills the program covers network
security vulnerability assessment risk
management threat analysis business
continuity data privacy and security and
other things like digital forensics and
Incident Management by enrolling you can
earn a prestigious celtech ctme boot
camp certificate and add up to 26 cus
along with CCH ctma Circle membership
this program's online conation led by
program director adds to the experience
Additionally you will Master the
utilization of various Cutting Edge
tools equipping you for a successful
journey in the field of cyber security
so this was calch cyber security boot
camp so we have discussed five best
courses for ethical hacking the link of
these courses you'll get in the
description you can choose as per your
choice and there you have it folks we
hope you enjoyed this insightful dive
into the essentials of ethical hacking
for beginners remember ethical hacking
is a continuous learning process and
this is just the beginning if you like
this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any questions then
you can drop them in the comment section
below thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more from Simply loan staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here